Hallo, hier ist die Freakshow. Schönen guten Abend. Wir sind beisammen.
Das fasst mich jetzt schon wieder an.
Dieses Intro. Das dachte ich mir auch.
Mich auch. Mir ist das erste Mal aufgefallen, das ist tatsächlich die Stimme von Steve, oder?
Naja, die tatsächlich ausgestrahlte Version davon ist von Richard Dreifuss gesprochen worden.
Die ist mal aufgenommen worden mit ihm, mit seiner Stimme, aber so nie veröffentlicht worden.
Das hat trotzdem irgendwie den Weg ins Internet gefunden.
Aber ich dachte mir, das wäre jetzt dann doch vielleicht mal die Variante, die man nehmen könnte.
Ja, ja, ja, gute Wahl.
Genau.
Ja, hallo, hier ist die Freakshow und bin wieder da nach nur vier Wochen.
Tada, tada. Hätte es gedacht, genau, nämlich Roddy da da.
Ja, Dada.
Und Ralf Dada.
Wunderschönen guten Abend.
Alles total Dada. Im letzten LNP habe ich ja versucht, Linus mal zu erklären, was Dada ist.
Von Dadaismus meinst du?
Ja, ja, ja. Aber das hat ihn irgendwie überhaupt nicht.
Das kannte er doch hoffentlich, oder?
Erstens kannte er es nicht und zweitens hat sie ihn auch irgendwie nicht berührt
und mitgenommen. Und das war natürlich die Jugend von heute, weißt du?
Linus als Jugend von heute zu beziehen, aber egal.
Naja, im Vergleich zu mir ist er auf jeden Fall näher am heute dran mit seiner Jugend als ich jetzt.
Als Berufsjugendlicher streite ich das natürlich regelmäßig ab.
Wir halten uns ja eigentlich auch immer noch verbunden mit unserer Startzeit.
Und okay, du nicht. Das kann natürlich sein.
Ich gebe das langsam auf.
Ja?
Ja, ja, das ist gesünder.
Ich nicht, ich nicht. Also wirklich.
Mein altes Motto. So jung wie ich bin, müsst ihr erst noch werden.
Ich finde es schwierig, dass um einen herum die Welt immer jünger wird.
Also man ist plötzlich so auf der Arbeit, dass man zu 80% plötzlich von Menschen
umgeben, die jünger sind als man selber.
Das ist schon irgendwie weird.
Naja.
Das wird nicht besser. Sichtlich. Bringt die Logik so mit sich.
Ja, aber es war schon immer so.
Ja, aber man ist dann auch von Leuten umgeben, wo man sich zunehmend denkt,
habt ihr immer noch nichts gelernt? Aber nee, haben sie natürlich nicht, weil sie sind ja jünger.
Ja, also wie auch immer, wir sind auf jeden Fall bereit, heute ein bisschen
in die Vergangenheit zu blicken.
Das wollte ich hier mit diesem Intro auch schon mal anstoßen.
Denn, ihr werdet es ja alle mitbekommen haben, Apple gibt es jetzt seit mittlerweile über 50 Jahren.
Das war jetzt interessanterweise am 1. April 2019.
Haben die ja gegründet worden.
Echt?
Ja, echt. Auch wieder so ein Titbit.
Ist das aber in den USA überhaupt doch April Fool's Day? Ist da genau so ein Ding?
Ja, natürlich, aber vielleicht war das ja auch ein Witz. Also, wer weiß.
Steve Jobs ist alles zuzutrauen. Andererseits, egal.
Ich meine, die Kisten mussten irgendwie das Licht der Welt sehen und dann saßen
sie halt zusammen und Ich weiß jetzt auch ehrlich gesagt nicht mehr so ganz
genau, was jetzt an diesem Tag konkret passiert ist.
Also ob das jetzt, keine Ahnung, vielleicht hat ja irgendein Amt einen Stempel
unter einen Antrag gesetzt, um die Firma offiziell als eingetragen zu deklarieren,
da lag das ja gar nicht so in ihrer Hand, keine Ahnung.
Es gibt ja tausend Retrospektiven dazu und ich kann euch jetzt schon mal sagen,
wir wollen jetzt hier keine Apple-Retrospektive machen, die jetzt irgendwie
50 Jahre Apple nacherzählt.
Darum geht es uns nicht.
So viel Zeit haben wir alle nicht.
Nee, aber es wird, sagen wir mal, Teile dieser Sendung informieren und inspirieren.
Da kommen wir dann auf jeden Fall noch dazu. Ja, ja.
Aber damit müssen wir ja nicht unbedingt anfangen. Können wir mal so gucken,
was erstmal so an Feedback reingekommen ist.
Genau, die letzte Sendung, da hatten wir so ein bisschen das Thema Entschittification
und zwar nicht im Digitalbereich, sondern im physisch-realen Kohlenstoff-Weltuniversum.
Und da gab es erwartungsgemäß viel Meinung zu.
Ich würde sagen, das meiste haben Leute noch absurdere Dinge gemeldet,
als das, was wir schon so in der Sendung hatten.
Da habe ich ein wirklich sehr, sehr schönes Beispiel jetzt nochmal mitgebracht und zwar von Hansi.
Der hat uns nämlich was geschickt, was in der Tat komplett jenseits von meinem
Radar gelaufen ist. Tim, ich schaue meistens mal in den Chat rein und dann können
wir da mal gemeinsam das bestaunen. Rufst du mal die URL auf.
Und zwar, das haben mehrere uns geschrieben, das heißt, it's the thing,
wie zum Teufel wir denn die Taschenlampen ignorieren konnten.
Da ist was dran, ja.
Und das ist ein Chart jetzt, wo, genau, rufen wir einfach da,
da kommt einfach nur ein Bild, mehr ist das nicht, ja.
Genau, über eine Anduriel 2 UI-Diagramm.
Und zwar einmal in der Simple-UI-Version und dann einmal in der Advanced-UI-Version.
Und das sind also die verschiedenen Klickpfade, wie viele verschiedene States
man einer Taschenlampe beibringen kann, die nur einen einzigen Button hat.
Also wie in welchem Rhythmus und mit welchen Abständen dort,
welches Untermenü quasi, unsichtbare Untermenü, dieser Ein-Button-Taschenlampe zu sehen ist.
Ich würde ja schon simpel nicht hinkriegen.
Mit Battery Check, den man noch aufrufen kann.
Also wild. Also Menschen machen sich Gedanken und arbeiten gegen uns.
Also gegen das, was wir in der Sendung proklamiert haben.
Dass man doch lieber wieder eher mehr Buttons haben möchte, statt weniger.
Und Dinge irgendwie dezidiert und weniger Touch und so. Das war ja so ein bisschen unser Credo.
Ich verstehe schon diese Grafik kaum. Also, wo, was, wie, RAM, Chlor?
C ist Click und H ist Hold. Das
heißt, von off 13 mal Hold ist der Factory Reset. Ist doch ganz einfach.
Es gibt einen Lockout-Mode.
Ja, also modale Systeme sind natürlich nochmal so ein Problem für sich.
Man kann einen Timer setzen.
Alter, was ist denn das hier alles?
Aber schön, wenn man es mal gesehen hat.
Wie wir ja alle nicht sehen, also wir blicken gerade auf ein krasses Wirrwarr
an Linien und Erklärungen und was man wann wo drücken kann und also allein die Energie,
die in die Gestaltung dieser Grafik geflossen ist, muss einem doch schon mal klar machen,
dass das kein Mensch verstehen kann.
Und dann hat das auch noch jemand programmiert oder ist das jetzt nur?
Because we can.
Ja, vor allem hat es erstmal einer programmiert und danach musste es irgendjemand
dokumentieren, weil Technik first und User last, das wird noch ein wiederkehrendes Thema sein.
Ich habe mir darüber Gedanken gemacht, also Entschittification,
was heißt das eigentlich auf Deutsch?
Also man könnte ja sagen Verscheißerung.
Ja, also Besudelung. Also hier das Buch, was ich vorgestellt hatte,
hat das ja mit Verkrempelung übersetzt quasi so für sich. Aber weil es ihm halt
auch sehr stark um diese Gegenstände ging.
Finde ich aber zu zahm als Ausdruck.
Verkackung wäre wahrscheinlich ein bisschen treffender.
Ja.
Ich meine, der Shit muss schon in irgendeiner Form da auch.
Verküllung der Welt oder.
So. Ja, das ist dann immer so hintenrum. Man muss schon ehrlich sein,
ne? Also Verkack-Eierung vielleicht.
Ja, aber das heißt ja verarschen eigentlich.
Ja, das ist ja im Prinzip geht das ja mit dem ganzen einen her.
Die Verkackung von allem.
Ja, aber es gibt auch gute Nachrichten. Gibt es ja immer.
So, Freakshow wirkt. Es ist ja nicht so, dass wenn wir hier sowas in der Sendung
besprechen, dass dann nicht noch Leute zuhören und reagieren.
Auch Großkonzerne drehen dann den Tanker um.
VW hat die Zeichen der Zeit erkannt. Wir sprachen in der Sendung darüber.
Und eine Woche nach unserer Sendung bringen sie also die Meldung raus,
dass Befehl von ganz oben Markenchef Thomas Schäfer sagt, die Ära der berührungsempfindlichen
Bedienelemente sind vorbei.
So, wem hat das zu verdanken, denkt dran.
Aber in der Sache ist es wirklich spannend, Und VW wird jetzt also in seinen
neuen Produkten diese ganzen Touch-Geschichten alle wieder runterfahren und
wieder echte, drückbare Buttons mit vielleicht sogar State vernünftig einführen.
Das ist God-given. Also das ist wirklich, als jemand, der sich unter viel Leidensdruck
an den Scheiß gewöhnt hat, muss ich sagen, so, ja, das ist echt nötig.
Also in China ist es ja sogar, das steht ja auch in dem Artikel nochmal drin,
dass sie das vorschreiben werden, dass diese ganzen Touch-Interfaces einfach
nicht mehr erlaubt sind und auch diese bekloppten Tür.
Ja, aber EU doch auch, oder? Euro NCAP oder so hat doch auch angekündigt.
Ja, die wollen Bewertungssterne abziehen.
Dann kriegst du halt nicht mehr diese volle Bewertung, aber es ist nicht im
eigentlichen Sinne verboten.
Aber wenn du dann halt gut dastehen willst bei diesem New Car Assessment Program,
dann musst du halt was anderes bauen. Das wird sicherlich auch seine Folgen haben.
Und ich meine, da haben die Leute einfach mit klar abgestimmt,
dass das halt einfach Quatsch ist. Das ist halt auch ein Sicherheitsfeature.
Und genauso sollte man auch Sterne abziehen, wenn das bei Computer Software scheiße ist.
Ja.
Ansonsten gab es noch viel, viel Rückmeldung zu der Herddebatte,
was auch so ein bisschen mein Startpunkt war des ganzen Themas.
Und da gibt es aber, da gibt es wirklich wenig Hoffnung.
Also da haben ganz, ganz viele geschrieben, ja, ist scheiße, ist auch bei meinem so.
Und auch die Fraktion, wir hatten das kurz erwähnt, dass es jetzt Modelle gibt,
wo man dann so ein Magnet-Button quasi oben drauf legt, um den dann irgendwie drehen zu können.
Das ist auch alles nicht gut, weil die gehen dann viel zu schnell kaputt und
kriegt man nicht nach und kosten absolut viel Geld.
Also da muss da muss noch Vernunft einkehren, was das angeht.
Da sind wir noch nicht am Ziel.
Ja, also für Autos, das ist schon ein bisschen absurd.
Das Auto war ja eigentlich so ein Paradebeispiel für Universal User Interface.
Also du konntest dich ja bis vor kurzem weltweit in irgendeinem Auto von irgendeinem
Hersteller sitzen und du wusstest, wie man es fährt.
Geht so. Also ich weiß nicht, als ich mal hier einen Leihwagen mir in Berlin
vor, das ist jetzt aber auch schon knapp zehn Jahre her,
und ich habe den 10 Minuten nicht gestartet bekommen, weil diese Konvention
du hast einen Schlüssel eingesteckt und hast einen Schlüssel im Schloss gedreht
und das ging auch, aber dieses Auto ist nicht angegangen, stattdessen musstest
du zusätzlich noch einen Startknopf drücken. Niemand weiß warum.
Ich zitiere mal hier ein paar neue Terms aus dem Chat, das ist dann schon so eine Kackifizierung.
Ich meine davor, da hat man einen Schlüssel reingesteckt.
Davor war alles gut.
Ja, man wusste, wie man den dreht und der war eigentlich in der Regel auch immer
an der gleichen Stelle, nur die Franzosen haben sich immer mal wieder was Neues
einfallen lassen, auch was so Schaltungen betrifft, so Revolverschaltungen und
sowas, weißt du, so R4 und so, kennst du das noch?
Da war so der Hebel so direkt neben dem Lenkrad.
So ein Zughebel. Ja, gab es mal, ja.
Ja, das lag aber auch daran, wie sie den Motor eingebaut haben.
Wenn ich das richtig in Erinnerung habe, war nämlich das Getriebe vor dem Motor.
Und deswegen brauchten sie die lange Stange, um dann tatsächlich die Schaltung durchzuführen.
Und es gab natürlich aber auch solche Spezereien wie so eine Choke.
Erinnert sich da jemand dran?
Ja, aber der Choke war ja eine technische Notwendigkeit.
Ja, der Choke war eine technische Notwendigkeit.
Ja, aber das hatten halt auch nicht alle Autos. Das heißt, du musst es auch
erstmal gucken. Da sitzt du jetzt halt in einem Auto wo oder wo nicht und wo ist es.
Alle Diesel hatten das.
Das stimmt.
Nee, Benziner hatten auch Chokes.
Was?
Ja, in den 70ern schon.
Du hast da kurzfristig das Mischungsverhältnis von Luft zu Benzin.
Welchen Fahrzeug? Hast du das in Erinnerung?
Also ich meine nicht, hätte ich mal eine Gemüse gehabt.
Also der R4 hatte auf jeden Fall auch einen. Jaja, also es war in diesen Unzeiten,
wo noch richtig Qualm aus dem Auspuff kam, hat man auch Choke ziehen müssen.
Dieses, dass der Motor von alleine erkennt, dass er kalt ist und das Mischungsverhältnis
ändert, kam viel später.
Sehr schön der Chat gerade, hier er, Eri, an der Mercedes-Handbremse mit Fußbedienung
sind schon Diebe gescheitert.
Daran erinnere ich mich auch. Ich habe irgendwann meinen Mercedes gesehen, was zum Teufel, wo?
Also die guten alten Zeiten lernen wir wieder so richtig gut.
Wann sein Auto aufgehen. Die Ausnahme bestätigt die Regel, man hat sich aber
doch weitgehend irgendwie geeinigt.
Also es war schon, abgesehen von so ein paar Ausreißern, war Lenkrad,
Schlüssel, Handbremse, Gangschaltung, Blinker, Scheibenwischer in bestimmten
Maße, war schon irgendwie alles ganz gut.
Und jetzt wird, man kann natürlich auch sagen, wenn man es mal positiv deuten
möchte, die Zeit, ja, wir leben in einer Welt, der...
Des mutigen,
Neudenkens. So ein bisschen Startup-Sprech. Man macht so, man stellt alles in
Frage, damit man auch wieder zu neuen Lösungen kommt und ich will auch gar nicht
ausschließen, dass man da zu neuen Lösungen kommt.
Gerade was jetzt so die Elektrifizierung so mit sich bringt,
die ändert ja schon ein paar Sachen, die auch geil sind.
Also was weiß ich, so mit Rekuperationen fahren und so weiter.
Das sind ja auch so Sachen, die will man dann auch unbedingt haben.
Und wenn man dann wieder in so einem normalen Verbrennerfahrzeug sitzt,
dann denkt man sich nur so, öh.
Das hatte ich jetzt lange nicht mehr, aber ich kann es mir vorstellen.
Ich hatte jetzt in Italien auch eine Automatik wieder zum Fahren.
Das ist einfach in jeder Welt so viel geiler, als irgendwie diese ollen Schaltwagen.
Automatik, aber Verbrenner.
War ein Hybrid. Aber der war so, das war ein Citroen C3 irgendwas.
Der hat irgendwie 90% seiner Arbeit auf Sprit gemacht und irgendwie nur ab und
zu mal so pro forma Elektro dazugeschoben.
Der hat ja mal so eine Anzeige, wo du sehen kannst, ist Rekuperation gerade
aktiv oder unterstützt es gerade oder fährt er komplett elektrisch.
Und ich glaube komplett elektrisch konnte der gar nicht fahren.
Das war gar nicht vorgesehen. Aber Automatik geil.
Also leider, dass wenn ich die Bremse langsam hochziehe, dass er dann schon
mal ständig nach vorne fährt oder auch nach rückwärts fährt.
Und egal, wir hatten wirklich schwierige Hotelsituationen, wo du also quasi
direkt am Berg anfahren musstest.
Und das ist einfach mit so einer vernünftigen modernen Automatik überhaupt kein Ding.
Du machst halt die Bremse hoch und das Ding rollt in genau derselben Geschwindigkeit nach vorne.
Ja, wobei er nur so eine Minimalbeschleunigung aufrechterhält,
um dem Zurückrollen etwas entgegenzusitzen.
Ich glaube, die modernen elektrischen haben ja dann auch schon so eine Erkennung,
dass die einfach dann auch stehen.
Also egal, wie schräg du am Hang stehst, der beschleunigt nicht nicht,
sondern der beschleunigt so weit, dass er steht.
Also die Elektro-VWs machen das so, wenn du auf die Bremse steigst und der kommt
zum Stehen, dann hält er.
Das soll er ja wohl auch tun. Also ganz einfach Auto holt. Very definition of a brake.
Nee, aber im Sinne von... Mit dem Motor, nicht mit den Bremsen. Doch, mit der Bremse.
Nein, du steigst auf die Bremse, das Auto kommt zum Stehen, du lässt die Bremse
los und dann bremst er weiter, er steht weiter, hat die Bremse weiter engaged,
auch das Bremslicht ist noch an übrigens,
was man irgendwie in gut reflektierenden Autos hinter einem dann auch sieht
irgendwann und erst wenn du aufs Gaspedal drückst, löst er die Bremse und du kannst losfahren.
Okay, finde ich auch so ein bisschen, ja, okay.
Der Chat liefert natürlich die ganzen weiteren Ausnahmen. Porsche Zündschloss
links, Automatik nur startbar, wenn man auf der Bremse steht.
Das hatte ich auch mal.
Saab Zündschloss in der Mittelkonsole.
Und natürlich die generelle Unschlüssigkeit darüber, wie denn nun der Rückwärtsgang
tatsächlich eingelegt werden soll.
Also was mich immer wahnsinnig gemacht hat bei Opel zum Beispiel,
ist, dass du da immer noch an dem Ring noch mit hochziehen musst,
um den Rückwärtsgang einzulegen.
Wahlweise runterdrücken das Ganze.
Oh ja, runterdrücken ist noch schlimmer.
Das ist aber lustig. Ich habe ja für meinen Sim Racing Rig, habe ich ja auch
einen Schalthebel, also einen H-Schalthebel.
Das ist Sim Racing Rig?
Das ist im Prinzip ein Gestell mit so einer Art Autositz.
Drei Tasten unten, so für Kupplung, Gas und Bremse.
Ein Lenkrad mit einem Force-Feedback-Motor und einer Gangschaltung,
also so einem Gangschaltungshebel.
Was machst du damit?
Fahren. Virtuell.
Womit?
Wie womit?
Was ist so, Trecker-Simulationen 2026?
Nee, vor allen Dingen Rallye. Und BeamNG, davon habe ich auch schon mal geredet.
BeamNG ist ein großartiges Spiel, weil es ist eigentlich mehr eine Physik-Simulation.
Und er simuliert Autos sehr fein.
Und jeden Schaden, den man verursacht, sieht man dann auch, auch im Verhalten des Autos.
Also man kann Autos da sehr stark zerstören, wenn man es richtig macht.
Das ist wirklich sehr spaßig. Was ich eigentlich erzählen wollte,
dieser Schalthebel, den ich habe, der ist auch so, dass er links vom ersten
Gang den Rückwärtsgang hat und man muss auch runterdrücken, um den einzulegen.
Der hat aber auch, er hat auch rechts vom fünften Gang noch einen siebten.
Aber Gott, die meisten Autos geben das eh nicht her, insofern ist es egal.
Sim Racing Cockpits.
Soft Body Physics. Wir gucken gerade hier auf diese BeamNG.
BeamNG kann ich jedem empfehlen, der einfach mit Zerstörung Spaß hat.
Gibt es da noch ein anderes Ziel als Zerstörung?
Nein, du kannst auch Rennen fahren und es gibt so einen Free-Roaming-Modus und
so weiter. Es ist halt so...
Das ist halt gnadenlos. Also wenn du aus der Kurve getragen wirst,
dann ist das Auto auch hinüber. Dann kannst du von neuem anfangen.
Das ist relativ schön, weil die meisten Spiele mit Autos lizenzieren ja oft
offiziell von Firmen die Autos.
Und wenn man dann Schaden baut, dann dürfen die nicht zu kaputt aussehen,
weil der Autohersteller will ja sein Hochglanzmodell nicht kaputt in der virtuellen Welt sehen,
weswegen du also durchaus Autos hast in Spielen, die überhaupt gar nicht kaputt gehen.
Also hast du dann irgendein Schadensmodell und dann fährt es auch nicht mehr,
aber es sieht halt so aus, als wäre es halt gerade aus der Wäsche gekommen.
Irgendwie ist es völlig absurd, aber gut.
Ist das, was ich hier gerade aufgerufen habe, das, was du da...
Fanatec. Ja, von Fanatec ist Lenkrad und Schalthebel und so weiter.
Und du hast ja auch so einen kompletten Apparat mit Gestell.
Ja, aber nicht von Fanatec, sondern von einer anderen Firma.
Grundgütiger.
Bewegt sich das dann auch? Also legst du dich damit dann auch in die Kurve und so?
Nein, nein. Also so etwas gibt es.
Ja.
Aber dann ist man schon im Apple-Rechts-Unten-Universum.
Ja, das ist ja am schönsten eigentlich.
Nein, so preislich. Also so 5.000, 6.000 Euro für simple Systeme kann man dann
schon auf den Tisch legen und ob die dann so gut funktionieren, weiß ich nicht.
Also nein, aber allein schon ein gutes Force-Feedback-Lenkrad zu haben,
gibt einem schon deutlich mehr Gefühl, was man da tut.
Funktioniert das auch mit Mario Kart?
Ich glaube nicht ich glaube nicht weil man das soweit ich weiß gibt es keine
lenkräder oder anderen sim racing kram den du an eine nintendo konsole anschließen
kannst also für sony gibt sachen für xbox gibt sachen für pc sowieso,
Aber für Nintendo wäre mir nicht bekannt. Also das Einzige sind ja diese Plastiklenkerräder,
wo man den Controller reintut.
Das gab es noch damals.
Die aber erstaunlich gut funktionieren.
Oh ja, in der Tat, die haben gut funktioniert. Habe ich auch immer benutzt.
War jetzt auch nicht ganz ernst gemeint. Das würde mich dann doch sehr überraschen.
Aber das ist ja irgendwie das einzige Racing, was ich mache.
Obwohl, ich fände es reizvoll, tatsächlich so ein Mario Kart mit Force Feedback
mal zu spielen. Das wäre wirklich lustig.
Wo man so richtig gegen die Wand bollert und so.
Ja, wenn man auf der Art Banane ausrutscht, keine Ahnung, wie sich das dann
anfühlt. Also das fände ich super.
Ach ja, genau. Also wir stellen fest,
Autos haben lange gut durchgehalten, mit wenig Ausnahmen ein sehr homogenes
User-Interface dargeboten.
Und dann kam Tesla.
Dann kam Tesla und auch alle anderen und jetzt hat man sozusagen versucht,
alles mal zu überdenken.
Aber man kommt jetzt auch wieder zu Sinnen und stellt fest, nicht alles, was neu ist, ist geil.
Und gerade in diesem Bereich Touch ist halt diese Verlockung,
alles billiger zu machen.
So ein bisschen der Holzweg und ich würde meinen, das werden wir dann wahrscheinlich
auch bald im Produktdesign wieder sehen, dass Touch da nicht mehr kommt.
Also ich glaube, dass man gerade bei VW halt sieht, dass dieser Deez, der lange CEO war,
halt einfach Elon-Fan war und einfach unkritisch alles übernommen hat,
was Tesla in seine Autos reingebaut hat und dann haben sie ihn geschasst und
jetzt dauert es halt fünf Jahre und dann sehen die die Sonne wieder.
Aber ich kann mir auch vorstellen, dass ein Autohersteller, der so viel Autos
verkauft, halt auch sehr viel Feedback bekommt.
Und mal ganz ehrlich, das VW-Lenkrad mit seiner Touch-Bedienung ist halt echt schlimm.
Also du kannst ja nicht einparken und ausparken, ohne irgendwie Lautstärke zu
ändern oder im Podcast hin und her zu springen oder weiß ich nicht.
Geschwindigkeit vom Abstandstempomaten zu verstehen.
Das kann man doch nicht ausschalten, den Scheiß?
Nee, du hast ja die Sensortasten auf den Speichen vom Lenkrad drauf.
Also das Einzige, was du machen kannst, ist dir anzugewöhnen,
wirklich nur am Rand anzupfen.
You're holding it wrong, Mann.
You're holding it wrong, ja. Das ist schon hart.
Ja, in der Tat, das ist in der Tat hart.
Aber vielleicht sollte man auch einfach nicht so hektisch lenken, keine Ahnung.
Ja, das stimmt.
Mein Lenkrad ist jetzt so alt, dass diese Gummischicht wegschmoddert.
So ihr kennt das, so diese spezielle Hart- oder Weichplastik Gummi-artige Geschichte,
die so nach 15 Jahren einfach irgendwann End of Life ist und jetzt so sich wie so ein Kaugummi,
eindrücken lässt Du.
Musst da so ein Puschelding drauf.
Machen Ja, so.
Ein Puschel, in der Tat.
Das Außenrum ist stabil Oder so ein Seeming drauf machen Aber der ganze Mittelteil
wo dann halt auch ein paar Buttons dass echte physische Buttons noch drauf sind.
Das ist einfach ein neues Lenkrad. Ruf auf den Schrott und dann holst du dir ein neues.
Das ist übrigens auch so ein Ding. Also das Simrace, das Lenkrad,
was ich an diesem Dings dran habe, das hat physische Buttons.
Die sind wirklich besser als das, was in dem VW drin ist und wenn ich könnte,
würde ich das Lenkrad nehmen.
Besser als die Realität.
Ja. Selbst Fanatec das hinkriegt, um mal an die letzte Sendung anzunehmen. Aber egal.
So habt ihr denn schon euren Desktop-Picture ausgetauscht?
Mhm.
Gegen die Fotos, die Artemis 2 auf der Erde zurückgesendet hat?
Nee, hab ich nicht gemacht. Aber ich hab den Start live geguckt.
Immerhin.
Tatsächlich.
Das hat mich doch so weit interessiert, wobei spannender war ja eigentlich hinterher
der Wiedereintritt, wenn man so den Expertenmeinungen glauben durfte.
Spannender im Sinne von, dass die Wahrscheinlichkeit...
Ja, wird der Hilfseschild halten oder sind alle tot? Da gab es auch durchaus
Stimmen, die gesagt haben, das sei doch irgendwie eine Selbstmordmission und
wird so alles nicht funktionieren.
Krauss, NASA kann das noch.
Kann das noch so ein bisschen, ja.
Ja, aber das war doch Boeing, die diese Kapsel gebaut haben,
oder nicht? Die hatten mit dem Ding ja auch schon fürchterlich Probleme vorher.
Die Kapsel ist tatsächlich von der ESA.
Von der ESA? Ah ja, dann. Dann mache ich mal keine Sorgen.
Ja, also die ist ja entwickelt worden auf Basis der, oh Gott,
jetzt habe ich den Namen nicht mehr parat, Also die Orion basiert auf dem ATV.
Das ist das Automated Transfer Vehicle. Genau, das Automated Transfer Vehicle.
Das ist das Modul, was so sechsmal, glaube ich, zum Einsatz kam,
um die ISS zu versorgen und anzuheben.
Und da haben sie halt, also das war sozusagen Teil der, diese Barta-Geschichte
im internationalen Weltraum, Klimbim, wenn du so geteilte Missionen hast,
wie es jetzt zum Beispiel der ISS ist, da hat die ESA ja auch ihr Modul und einen Anteil,
halt einen kleineren Anteil als jetzt die Russen und die Amerikaner,
aber um dann quasi einen Beitrag zu leisten, legt man nicht irgendwie Geld hin,
sondern man sagt, wir bauen das, ihr baut das und so weiter.
Und diese ATV-Kapsel, die haben sie dafür entwickelt und das war so diese erste,
die dieses ganze vollautomatische Docking gemacht hat.
Also da waren sehr viele Innovationen drin und das haben sie dann sozusagen
auf den nächsten Level gehoben für diese Orion-Kapsel.
Ja, gut. Aber trotzdem, also ich meine, es war natürlich so ein bisschen,
ja weiß ich nicht, war das jetzt pointless?
Gut, die wollen ja irgendwann wieder landen mit Menschen und dass sie das jetzt
einmal testen mit ohne landen, kann man nachvollziehen.
War natürlich jetzt nicht so das Mega-Highlight, aber ich fand halt dieses eine Foto so geil,
weil sie ja zufällig durch den Zeitpunkt des Starts, der ja immer durch Verschiebung
und so weiter sich ja mehr oder weniger ergibt.
Hatten sie ja eine Konstellation, wo sie dann tatsächlich eine Sonnenfinsternis
hatten, wo also der Mond die Sonne abgedeckt hat, aus ihrer Perspektive,
und sie ja, dann mal aus dem All direkt vor dem Mond, also vor so einem Riesenmond
Fotos machen konnten. Das sieht so irre aus.
Also das sind finde ich mit die besten Fotos, die so je gemacht worden.
Die gibt es hier bei der NASA.
Du bist schon dabei, genau.
NASA Artemis 2 Eklipse.
Ja, genau. Diese Eklipse-Fotos finde ich halt einfach am geilsten.
Wo ist es denn jetzt hier? Ja, oh, kack. Entschuldigung.
Es ist wirklich Das Internet, das will einem irgendwie auch nicht mehr.
Das ist alles wirklich ein Problem.
Hä, wurden denn die Bilder, die ich eben gerade noch gefunden hatte?
Du bist gerade auf DuckDuckGo auch. Ich weiß nicht, ob das Absicht ist.
Absicht ist ein großes Wort, aber vielleicht suche ich einfach mal auf Google.
Also hast du Helium gerade am Start, heißt das ja startmäßig.
Ja, genau. Das meine ich. Also, wo du wirklich nur den Mond im All siehst.
Aber so weit waren die doch gar nicht weg vom Mond, oder? Wie ist das jetzt
hier auf dem Bild? Ist das echt? Ist doch fake.
Das ist der Rückweg. Die waren dann sozusagen wieder auf dem Weg zur Erde.
Also auf dem Weg zur Erde.
Ach, das ist nicht der Mond, sondern das ist die Erde.
Nein, das ist der Mond.
Ah, okay, jetzt verstehe ich.
Was gibt es denn da zu verstehen?
Ja, mein Hirn hat...
Mond ist zwischen Sonne und Raumkapsel.
Okay, I see. Welchen Streich hat dir denn das Gehirn jetzt gerade gespielt?
Ich komme halt von diesen Bildern, wo du immer sowohl Mond als auch Erde drauf hast.
Achso, ja genau, aber die fand ich jetzt gar nicht so interessant,
sondern ich fand halt einfach dieses Bild interessant und vor allem finde ich
es deshalb interessant, weil du ja den Mond quasi, also du blickst auf die Dark Side of the Moon.
Die ja nie dark ist, wie wir wissen, aber sehr selten. Also genauso selten wie die Vorderseite.
Nein, die Darkseite ist immer dark.
Das ist doch die Nachtseite, könnte man auch sagen.
Ja, aber die wandert ja über den Mond drüber. Es gibt eine Erdzugseite des Mondes
und eine Erdabgewandte.
Ich rede aber nicht von der Erdzuwendung, ich rede von der dunklen Seite im
Sinne von, die nicht der Sonne zugehört ist.
Die Nachtseite.
Ja, die ja aber immer wechselt.
Ja, natürlich wechselt ihr.
Die bei der Erde auch.
Ja, aber das ist jetzt gerade auf diesem Foto die dunkle.
Also ich reite ja jetzt das, oder wir reiten da alle gerade so drauf rum,
weil das ja in der Berichterstattung, auf gar keinen Fall dürft ihr jemals sagen,
die dunkle Seite des Mondes, weil die gibt es nicht. Natürlich gibt es sie.
Die gibt es schon, aber halt nur genauso lange, wie es eine dunkle Seite der Erde gibt.
Nee, die ist länger, weil...
Nein, das Problem, was du ansprichst, ist, dass wenn die Leute Dark Side of
the Moon sagen, sagen wir sie entweder ein Album oder die erdabgewandte Seite.
Die ist aber nicht dark, die sehen wir halt nur nicht.
Die ist manchmal auch dark.
Manchmal ist die dark.
Bei Vollmond ist die halt dark. So, aber eben nur bei Vollmond.
Also das ist sozusagen die erdabgewandte Seite und die Dark Side äquivalent.
Hier blicken wir auch auf die Dark Side. Ja, die ist nicht, wir erkennen hier
aber an diesem Foto auch, dass es sich hierbei nicht um die erdabgewandte Seite
handelt, zumindest nicht vollständig. Woran sehen wir das?
An diesen Mares hier, die sich so ein bisschen abläuft.
Genau, man sieht nämlich etwas. Man sieht nämlich etwas. Und das ist halt Erdschein.
Das ist Erdschein.
Ja, Sonnenlicht, was von der Erde auf den Mond geworfen wird.
Ja, guter Punkt.
Aber warum ist das dann auch schon so leicht sichelförmig?
Na, weil halt die Erde links ist. Mann, 3D, Mann. Ja, also.
Du musst erstmal wach werden hier heute.
Ja, jetzt weiß ich, was du meinst.
Du schaust, die gucken in Richtung Sonne.
Aber auf dieser Richtung ist halt der Mond dazwischen. Deswegen siehst du nur
die Corona von der Sonne und natürlich ist auf der anderen Seite alles hell,
also ist natürlich auf der Seite, wenn die Sonne hinter dem Mond ist, dann ist es halt dunkel.
Aber hier ist halt ein Teil noch hell und das ist das Licht,
was von der Erde auf den Mond zurück reflektiert wird.
Ja, ja, das verstehe ich schon.
Also Erdschein.
Ah, Moment. Und deine These oder wie auch immer ist das, also ich hatte jetzt
innerhalb von der Logik her quasi die Erde schon im Rücken, aber du sagst,
die Erde ist gerade links oben.
Ja, so leicht.
Und scheint von da aus quasi dann noch so leicht.
Also links oben ist jetzt auch, ja, auf dem Foto ja, genau.
Es gibt ja in dem Sinne kein oben und links. Also auf jeden Fall ist sie,
du siehst, ein Teil ist nicht komplett dunkel.
Was es wäre, wenn die Erde auch noch dahinter wäre.
Aber die Erde ist halt nicht auch noch dahinter, sondern die Erde ist irgendwo
jetzt links auf diesem Foto und deswegen siehst du noch etwas von der Oberfläche
der dunklen Seite der Macht.
Okay. Jetzt habe ich es verstanden. Danke.
Für Artemis ist es Neumond. Für Artemis ist es Neumond, für die Erde ist es
ein Halbmond oder so. Genau.
Und ich finde einfach das Wort Erdschein so schön.
Der Erdschein.
Genau.
Kein Mondschein offensichtlich.
Ja,
sehr viel mehr kann man, glaube ich, zu dieser Mission auch gar nicht sagen.
Ansonsten ist ja in der Kultur ist ja Space wieder angesagt.
Weil es wieder einen neuen Science-Fiction gibt und du hast ihn schon gelesen, gesehen.
Moment, eine Sache zu der Mission noch. Es gibt eine BBC-Folge mal wieder und
zwar von den Leuten, die die 30 Minutes to the Moon gemacht haben.
Zumindest ist es im gleichen Feed drin.
Ich habe es noch nicht gehört, aber es gibt irgendwie 13 Folgen,
also die waren da die ganze Zeit dabei.
13 Minutes to the Moon kann man sowieso mal hören. Also das ist ein wirklich geiler Podcast.
Er ist ein bisschen überproduziert. Ich meine, wenn man Hans Zimmer engagiert,
um die Musik zu machen, dann weißt du, es ist jetzt nicht der normale Podcast,
aber nee, ist wirklich gut.
Also 13 Minutes to the Moon von der BBC ist eine echte Hörempfehlung.
Und wie gesagt, da sind jetzt neue Folgen drin über Artemis 2,
13 Stück oder so sind es jetzt.
Ich habe es ja aber noch nicht gehört, insofern ist es kein Tipp in dem Sinne.
Musst du noch Link machen.
Muss ich noch Link machen.
So, jetzt mal ein geschickter Übergang zu einem anderen Thema.
Oder einem zumindest angrenzenden Thema. Ich war mal wieder im Kino,
was Nachrichtenwert hat.
Wenn man kleine Kinder hat, hat man für sowas ja nie mehr Zeit.
Aber die waren eine Woche bei Oma und Opa. Und dann hat man plötzlich wieder
ein echtes Leben. Und dann geht man ins Kino.
Und da bin ich in den neuen Film von Andy Weir gegangen, also von dem Autor,
der Marsianer geschrieben hat.
Hail Mary heißt das. Gutes Stück. Und das hat irgendwie so Raving Reviews auf
IMDb, hat irgendwie eine IMDb-Score von 8,4 oder sowas. Also erstaunlich viel.
Und parallel dazu hatte ich dann aber, weil ich mich gefreut habe,
dass überhaupt mal ein neues Buch wieder rausgemacht hat.
Marsianer war glaube ich irgendwie 2009 oder 2011 oder sowas.
Also schon ein Weilchen her. Und dazwischen hat er noch mal eins geschrieben,
was sich aber auch irgendwie an mir komplett vorüber gegangen ist,
was irgendwie um eine Kolonie auf dem Mond ging.
Und jetzt hat er, ja ich würde nicht sagen unbedingt jetzt den spirituellen
Nachfolger, aber vielleicht schon so ein bisschen vom Marsianer geschrieben.
Auf Deutsch der Astronaut, auf Englisch Hail Mary.
Und ich finde das, das ist ja so vom Genre her, ist das ja die sogenannte Hard Sci-Fi.
Haben wir glaube ich auch schon mal über Marsianer gesprochen,
über ein Buch und ein Film.
Dieses Buch hatte ich empfohlen, als ich aus Amiland zurückkam und dass niemand
diesen Weir kannte zu dem Zeitpunkt, ich natürlich auch nicht,
aber der war damals in Portland City of Books von der Belegschaft als Tipp angegeben
worden. Habt es halt einfach gekauft.
Habt es dann hier vorgestellt und alle so, weißt du, willst du ein Buch vorstellen?
Und es war auch noch, bevor überhaupt klar war, dass es verfilmt wurde.
Das war wirklich sehr witzig.
Genau, da gab es dann auch die Verfilmung, die waren auch ganz,
ganz, ganz, ganz brauchbar, fand ich die.
Und was dieses Buch, dieser Marsianer, fand ich, gut transportiert hat,
war so ein Mitlerneffekt.
Das heißt also, da war ein Mensch in einer sehr ungewöhnlichen Situation,
der ganz offensichtlich unfassbar intelligent und clever war und sich da halt
aber mit reiner Wissenschaft quasi durchgeboxt hat durch die Story.
Und das auf eine Art und Weise geschrieben, dass man so den Eindruck hätte,
hätte ich in der Schule besser aufgepasst, dann könnte ich sowas vielleicht sogar auch.
Also ich finde, das hatte sowas Einladendes, sich mit diesen Themen irgendwie
so ein bisschen zu beschäftigen. Und,
War aber auch immer so ein bisschen mein Verdacht, vielleicht ist das jetzt
auch so ein One-Trick-Pony so und jetzt hat er halt ein Buch rausgebracht,
was wieder ein bisschen ähnlich funktioniert, aber schöne andere Twists und
Grundprämissen hat und da will ich jetzt also auch gar nichts spoilern,
wenn ihr euch das noch anguckt, das wäre jetzt blöd.
Also alle, die den Marsianer gut fanden, können da glaube ich bedenkenlos zugreifen.
Wie üblich fand ich das Buch jetzt besser als den Film aus so ein paar Gründen.
Der Film ist aber auch jetzt überhaupt keine Katastrophe, aber ich würde den
jetzt nicht als großes Sci-Fi-Kunstwerk oder so bezeichnen.
Aber zum Beispiel hier Claudia hat nicht das Buch vorher gelesen und die fand
den Film jetzt viel mitreißender und zugänglicher als den Marsianer damals,
hatte sie auch das Buch nicht gelesen.
Von daher, die einen sagen so, die anderen so.
Film ist aber wirklich keine Katastrophe, kann man schön schauen,
ist aber auch jetzt überhaupt nichts, was einen jetzt, finde ich,
aus der Bahn wie oft, ist eher so ein bisschen feel-good- Sci-Fi,
so würde ich sagen. Aber kann man machen.
Muss ja nicht alles Horror sein.
Muss nicht alles Horror sein. Irgendwann muss ich nochmal das Buch in der Mitte
lesen, das ist glaube ich auch gar nicht so schlecht.
Aber dieses so, wir denken mit und lernen was und fühlen uns am Ende schlauer
als vorher, das produziert jetzt auch der Astronaut sehr schön.
Ich habe den Film nicht gesehen, ich habe auch das Buch nicht gelesen und ich
weiß auch noch nicht, ob ich mir den Film angucke, aber was ich mir angeguckt habe ist eine,
nicht die ganze Serie, aber es gab ein Interview von Andy Weir durch Dr.
Becky, sagt dir Dr. Becky etwas, das ist meine Lieblingsastronomin im Internet.
Ich glaube, du hast sie schon mal irgendwann erwähnt. Jetzt,
wo ich das Bild hier so sehe.
Es kommt mit leicht klingelt irgendwas. Beggies, Matt Hurst und das ist so eine
super Erklärerin für All Things
Space, gehört so ein bisschen zu meinen Standard-Space-YouTube-Abos.
Und ja, sie haben für diesen Film sich da eine ganz interessante Social-Media-Strategie
auch einfallen lassen, indem sie
so im Vorfeld eine ganze Menge auch so im Science-Bereich gemacht haben.
So nach dem Motto, was stimmt denn davon und was nicht und so.
Und es ist wirklich interessant, weil dieser Andy Weir, der kniet sich richtig rein.
Also es ist Science Fiction, aber er versucht all diese potenziellen Übertreibungen,
die ja natürlich zwangsläufig damit einhergehen,
schon aus so einer tatsächlichen wissenschaftlichen Erkenntnis heraus zu entwickeln.
Und geht da wirklich auch in Formeln
und in Details und rechnet das alles irgendwie durch und so weiter.
Also ziemlich bemerkenswert und das wurde unter anderem in diesem Video und
so weiter sehr schön abgeglichen. Sie hat auch noch ein Interview mit Ryan Gosling gemacht.
Das war halt, naja, eher so, ja, okay, gut.
Also Ryan Gosling ist ja Hauptdarsteller in dem Film.
Das ist der Ken aus dem Barbie-Film.
Der Ken aus dem Barbie-Film, genau.
Der das aber ganz gut macht, aber es ist durch ihn und seine Figur halt auch
schon eine Tonverschiebung, Film versus Buch, muss man sagen.
Also der Film ist deutlich klamaukiger als das Buch, um es mal so zu sagen.
Naja gut, ist ja auch in Ordnung, ist ja ein Film, aber ich fand den Wissensgewinn
jetzt nicht so groß aber ich fand das ganz charming dass der Ryan Gosling,
Also ich meine, du merkst es so richtig so, ich meine, sie interviewt jetzt
nicht jeden Tag so Weltstars.
Auf der einen Seite, auf der anderen Seite war auch dieser Ryan Gosling eigentlich
ganz kleinlaut, weil er wusste, er hat von dem ganzen Scheiß,
keine Ahnung, aber sie ist halt richtig gut unterwegs.
Also sie ist so spezialisiert auf schwarze Löcher und so weiter,
aber ist halt auch so generell so eine Astro-Erklärerin, kann ich nur sehr empfehlen, ihr zu folgen.
Ich mache das schon sehr lange und sie ist auch sehr unterhaltsam und macht das richtig gut.
Ja, ja Gut Dann,
Könnten wir nochmal über Können wir nochmal über Apple reden Würde ich sagen,
Weil, ja, hatten wir ja schon Erwähnt, jetzt sind 50 Jahre rum,
Und ich weiß nicht, hat euch das irgendwie erreicht, diese Information?
Hat das irgendwie euch tangiert in irgendeiner Form?
Macht das was mit euch oder ist das eigentlich nur eine Zahl?
Also die Information hat mich natürlich schon erreicht.
Macht das was mit euch? Da würde ich eher sagen nein. Aber ich bin eh nicht so ein Jubiläumstyp.
50 Jahre Mondlandung hat mich jetzt auch nicht so aus der Bahn geworfen und weiß ich nicht.
Um mich da gleich ranzuhängen, ich sehe das ähnlich wie Roddy vor allen Dingen
prangere ich immer diese Fixierung auf Jahrzehnte an ich glaube ich habe das
irgendwann auch schon mal in der Sendung schon mal gebracht, also,
irgendwie die Jahrzehnte, so die 80er und die 90er und warum aber nicht 1984 bis 1992,
das war vielleicht die viel bestimmte und wichtige Epoche nur weil wir so auf
dieses Dezimalsystem irgendwie fixiert sind und Brücke zu dem Film oder zu dem
Buch vielmehr, weil in einem Film taucht das nicht auf.
Da wird unter anderem auch nochmal durchdefiniert, wie sähe es denn aus,
wenn wir Menschen keine zehn Finger hätten.
Weil also eine veritable These ist, dass wir deshalb überhaupt nur im Dezimalsystem
rechnen, weil wir zehn Finger haben und damit halt irgendwie einigermaßen das...
Und wenn wir jetzt sechs Finger hätten, wird unsere Mathematik halt anders aussehen
oder die Art und Weise, nicht die Mathematik, aber die Art und Weise,
wie wir Zahlen halt einfach darstellen und wie wir rechnen.
Und dann werden wir wahrscheinlich auch überhaupt nicht so Jahrzehnte fixiert
und darum finde ich dieses 50 Jahre ist Quatsch.
Aber da werden wir ja Dutzende fixiert.
Ja, werden wir Dutzende. Oder halbe Dutzende oder was auch immer.
Dutzend ist real. Also ich meine, ist nicht alles Zehner basiert.
Ja, am wichtigsten ist das Schock. 60 Stück. Hat unglaublich viele Teile.
Wo kommt das Dutzend her? Du tust so, als wüsstest du, wo quasi die Zwölfer war. Woher?
Hast du eine These?
Sumera würde ich sagen.
Das ist eigentlich recht einfach. Also zwölf kann man halt durch vier und durch
drei und durch zwei teilen.
Das ist einfach eine sehr praktische Einheit auf dem Markt.
Du hast halt irgendwie zwölf Tomaten und das ist ein Dutzend und das ist,
sagen wir mal, zwölf ist halt so eine Menge, also nicht,
guck mal, eins, zwei, drei, vier, fünf, sechs, sieben, acht,
neun, zehn, elf, zwölf, bis dahin ist es eine Silbe.
13, 14, 15.
Was aber jetzt eine deutsche Eigenart ist.
Was eine deutsche Eigenart ist, ja. Wenn du jetzt guckst, französische.
Im Englischen ist es auch so.
Tres, Gardons, Gans.
Ich habe überhaupt keine Rolle hier.
Die Set, dann wären es zwei.
Ja, aber worauf ich hinaus will ist, die Zwölf ist schon irgendwie drin und
es hat halt einfach schlicht damit zu tun, dass Zwölf ist einfach eine praktische Menge.
Zwölf kann man überblicken. Wenn ich sage Zwölf, dann hast du da jedes einzelne
Objekt irgendwie im Kopf.
Jetzt kann man natürlich argumentieren, ja, 13 kann ich mir aber auch noch vorstellen.
Tut jetzt nichts zur Sache, ist einfach eine praktische Menge.
Oft sind zwölf irgendwie eine gute, so eine Gesamtmenge, die du aber vielleicht
nicht unbedingt immer brauchst, die du aber immer irgendwie überblickst.
Und dann kannst du sie halbieren, du kannst sie dritteln, du kannst sie vierteln,
also du kannst sie gut aufteilen.
Und deswegen ist das Zwölfer-System bei uns wichtig, selbst wenn wir nur zehn Finger haben.
Also sozusagen der praktische Teil ist da.
Ich möchte eine Gegenthese entwerfen. Und zwar das Jahr hat zwölf Monate.
Und diese Monate werden aber nicht dadurch gebildet, dass man einfach durch
zwölf teilt, sondern dass ein Umlauf des Mondes 28 Tage sind.
Und das bedeutet, dass der Mondkalender halt zwölf Monate hat.
Gut, dann bleiben irgendwie elf Tage übrig oder so zwischen den Jahren,
also zwischen dem Mondkalenderjahr und dem Sonnenkalenderjahr.
Da kommt das übrigens her, zwischen den Jahren.
Und deswegen glaube ich, hat die Zwölf auch schon immer eine sehr zentrale Rolle
im Leben der Menschen gespielt.
Also das ist schon klar, dass das Jahr 13 Monate lang ist.
Ne, es bleibt kein ganzer Mond übrig am Ende des Mondjahres.
Also, 13 mal 28 ist 364. Das ist im Prinzip ein Jahr.
Ja, es sind ja nicht ganz 13, nicht ganz 28, sondern ich glaube ein bisschen mehr.
Das ist ja auch 364, fehlt ja auch noch.
Nein, aber das sind keine gleichen Teile.
Ja, aber zu sagen, das Jahr besteht aus zwölf Monaten, das ist Quatsch, das ist nur so.
Das Mondjahr, ja.
Das Mondjahr. Ach, du meinst nach zwölf?
Achso, nach zwölf ist es wieder da, wo es vorher war? Oder wie? Was meinst du damit?
Also nach zwölf? Aber der Mond hat sich dann noch nicht, also die Erde hat sich
noch nicht um die Sonne gedreht.
Also das ist ja, ein Mondjahr existiert ja nicht.
Hektisches Tippen.
Beim Mond gibt es ja nur den Monat. Das ist ja nur ein Mond.
Der Mond ist ja egal.
Wie schnell die Erde um die Sonne geht. Der dreht sich ja unabhängig davon.
Der Mond dreht sich unabhängig davon.
Genau, das heißt, dem Mond ist es scheißegal. Deswegen kann es...
Das Matching auf das Jahr ist eine reine mathematische Geschichte.
Und wenn du es mathematisch machst, dann zahlt 13.
Nicht 100 Prozent, aber deutlich besser als 12.
Hat auf jeden Fall... also das Dutzend hat und da garantiert nichts mit dem Mond zu tun.
Keine Ahnung. Auf jeden Fall sind es wohl die Sumerer, die das mit dem 12 und
dem Gros, das waren 60, ne?
Ne, das Schock waren 60 und das Gros sind 12 mal 12, 144, irgendwer hat das da.
Also da kommt das auf jeden Fall her. Vielleicht kommt es auch von der Art,
wie die gezählt haben, sodass man halt irgendwie dann bei 12 rauskommt.
Man muss ja nicht mit jedem Finger einzeln zählen.
Wie sind wir denn da jetzt eigentlich drauf gekommen?
Naja,
du hast angefangen mit dem Dezimalsystem.
Ich habe gegen Jubiläen gelästert.
Und ich habe gesagt, es gibt auch andere Zahleneinheiten, die für die Menschheit
eine Rolle spielen, unabhängig von der Anzahl der Finger.
Ich würde mal noch hexadezimal in die Runde werfen.
Das wollte ich auch noch hinterherwerfen, aber das ist ja eher eine neuere Entwicklung.
Ja, aber auch das Oktalsystem hat seine Berechtigung, allerdings auch nur im Computerbereich.
Und jetzt muss ich noch mal kurz nachdenken.
Genau genommen, wenn man jetzt genetisch rechnet, also das Genmaterial ist dann,
Wie war denn das? Jetzt will ich mir keinen Unsinn erzählen,
aber ich würde es wahrscheinlich Unsinn erzählen. Wisst ihr überhaupt, wovon ich rede?
Nicht so ganz.
Naja, wir haben ja vier, also unsere Genetik besteht ja aus vier Ziffern.
G-A-T-C-H oder was.
Ja, genau. Und es sind ja sozusagen immer so definierte Paare.
Also gibt es im Prinzip vier Symbole. Also es ist quasi das Vierersystem.
Wenn man so will, ja.
Wenn man so will, genau.
Also Ziffern und Zahlen und Zahlensysteme verstehen, finde ich,
ist eine ganz, ganz, ganz wertvolle Eigenschaft.
Falls ihr damit Schwierigkeiten habt, würde ich euch raten, das mal zu updaten.
Aber wir haben uns nun mal darauf geeinigt, dass Jubiläen nun mal dezimal abgerechnet
werden und deswegen ist es halt jetzt so.
Ist es die 50, kann man nichts machen.
Ja, es ist halt einfach die 50 und es ist eigentlich auch ziemlich Wumpe.
Trotzdem kann man sagen, halbes Jahrhundert prägt dieses Unternehmen das Computing
und ich wollte mal so ein bisschen drüber reflektieren, was mir so durch den Kopf gegangen ist.
Ich meine, ich habe natürlich diese ganzen Zelebrierungen und Zusammenfassungen
und Apple-Historie und so weiter alles so halbwegs zur Kenntnis genommen.
Mir interessiert mich das jetzt auch nicht so groß, aber ich habe so ein bisschen
für mich selber darüber nachgedacht, okay, was ist denn da eigentlich jetzt passiert?
Weil mein Leben begleitet das ja quasi von Anfang an.
Und also ich habe zwar jetzt, als ich,
sieben, acht Jahre war das nicht mitbekommen dass Apple gegründet wurde das
hat eine Weile gedauert bis ich davon erfahren habe aber ich habe es dann vergleichsweise
bald irgendwann auch mitbekommen,
dass es das gab und ich hatte glaube ich meine erste,
Begegnung mit einem Apple Macintosh.
Also erst mit einem Macintosh?
Ja, mit einem Macintosh. Also ich hatte, naja, ich habe einen Apple II nie wirklich benutzt.
Ich hatte, glaube ich, mal einen gesehen. Wann hast du den benutzt?
Oh, gute Frage. Das muss ganz früh 80er gewesen sein.
Also ich weiß, dass ich auf dem Apple II den Microsoft Flight Simulator gespielt habe.
Den aller allerersten, wo die Framerate sehr überschaubar war,
besonders wenn er mehr als drei Linien auf dem Bildschirm zeichnen musste.
Aber immerhin, man hatte das Gefühl, man bewegt sich irgendwie durch den Raum.
Auch wenn es ansonsten extrem unspannend war, wenn ich mal ganz ehrlich sein soll.
Ich habe damals auch diese, zumindest mal reingeguckt, diese Tabellenkalkulation.
Visikalk.
Visikalk, genau so hieß die. Die allererste Tabellenkalkulation.
Habe das damals natürlich überhaupt nicht verstanden, warum das gut sein soll.
Aber ich habe es mal gesehen und zur Kenntnis genommen, sagen wir mal so.
Und dann weiß ich, einen Apple 3 habe ich tatsächlich auch mal benutzt,
der ist ja irgendwie komplett krepiert.
Und der war nicht erfolgreich auf dem Markt.
Ja, der war überhaupt nicht erfolgreich, war auch irgendwie nicht groß anders
als der Apple II, wenn ich mich recht erinnere.
Ich glaube, er war anders genug, als dass er keinen Erfolg hatte.
Er war inkompatibel genug, als dass er keinen Erfolg hatte, aber nicht besser
genug, als dass man jetzt, genau.
Und dann den ersten Mac war tatsächlich der erste Mac, den ich dann gesehen
habe. da hatten wir damals unsere Schülerzeitung drauf gemacht.
Auf dem ersten Mac.
Auf dem ersten Mac, ja dem Würfel-Mac. Keine Ahnung, vielleicht war es auch
nicht der allererste, sondern schon ein etwas besseres Modell.
Aber der Mac mit dem ikonischen Mac-Gehäuse in Würfelform. Ja, genau.
Ja, also das erste Mal, dass ich mit dem Mac in Verbindung kam,
das muss auch so 84, 85 irgendwie gewesen sein.
Also da war Apple dann so, warte mal jetzt, 26, also knapp 20.
Nee, Quatsch. Zehn Jahre alt.
Und ich habe kurze Zeit später tatsächlich auch mal eine Lisa benutzt.
Da hatte aber jemand schon das macOS-Betriebssystem drauf gemacht,
weil das gab es wohl für die Lisa rückwirkend dann doch nochmal von Apple.
Also man konnte das Macintosh-Betriebssystem, das hat ja keinen Namen damals,
konnte man von Macintosh auf der Lisa auch benutzen, weil die Hardware war relativ ähnlich.
Bist du sicher?
Ja, ziemlich.
Das sah nur so ähnlich aus, glaube ich.
Nein, das Lisa OS sah anders aus, war auch viel rudimentärer als das,
was bei Macintosh dann gekommen ist.
Das Teil war ja auch unglaublich teuer und war auch kein Erfolg,
aber weil die Hardware von Macintosh sehr ähnlich war zu dem von der Lisa,
konnte man dann das Macintosh, ich weiß nicht, ob es eine spezielle Version
war oder so, also auf jeden Fall konnte man das auf der Lisa benutzen.
Die Lisa hatte ja so ein, keine Ahnung, so ein Bildschirm, der war so groß,
wie heute ein Trackpad ist.
Neben zwei, dreieinhalb Zoll Diskettenlaufwerken. Irgendwie alles so in einer
Kiste, die man rumschleppen konnte.
Völlig absurd, das Ding.
Also das Internet sagt, das war nicht so.
Das war nicht so?
Und ich meine auch, damals waren einfach diese Betriebssysteme zu sehr,
diesen Maschinen auf den Leib geschneidert und es gab ja überhaupt keine Notwendigkeit,
da irgendetwas zu portieren.
Naja, spielt auch jetzt erstmal keine Rolle, das sind alles so Details,
darum wollte ich jetzt eigentlich gar nicht hinaus, sondern ich wollte so ein
bisschen darauf hinaus, was das eigentlich so mit mir gemacht hat.
Generell diese Welt zu entdecken, weil da kamen ja gerade so die Homecomputer,
und dann so im Laufe der 80er Jahre kamen dann auch so diese,
PCs dann eben auf, so diese ersten PC-Klones und man hatte im Prinzip so eine Welt, die bestand aus,
IBM-PCs, Microsoft,
erste Klone, das war so das eine, da fragte man sich halt auch noch so ein bisschen,
was man damit eigentlich machen sollte, weil die war ja irgendwie ein bisschen blöd.
Dann gab es halt den C64, der ja im Prinzip zahlenmäßig verkaufstechnisch die
80er Jahre dominiert hat.
Das war ja definitiv der erfolgreichste Computer, aber halt jetzt nicht im Ansatz
so sophisticated, was jetzt so Speichermengen, Größen und Erweiterbarkeiten und so weiter betrifft.
Ja, gar nicht.
Ja, genau, gar nicht. Aber ist gut gestartet und zeigt wieder auch,
wenn so ein System gut definiert ist,
viele Möglichkeiten bietet, dann kann das sehr lange gut gehen,
solange die Leute sich da drauf stürzen und irgendwie alles rausholen,
was irgendwie rauszuholen ist.
Das war irgendwie immer so das Markenzeichen.
Ähnlich war es ja dann mit dem Amiga auch.
Atari ST genauso.
Dann gab es noch diesen Atari ST, der halt so ein etwas weirder Versuch war,
irgendwie so zu sein, wie so ein DOS-Rechner eigentlich.
Auf der einen Seite.
Ja, nicht ganz. Also sie hatten so einen DOS-ähnlichen Unterbau.
Das waren die Original-PC-DOS-Calls, die sie da implementiert haben auf dem
68.000. Das hieß ja auch TOS.
TOS, ja, auch dieses 8.3-Naming im Dateisystem.
Und dann hatten sie aber so ein Gem, hieß das ja, diese Benutzeroberfläche obendrauf
gestrickt, die so Mac-ähnlich aussehen sollte, auch aussah und sich auch so ähnlich benutzt hat.
Also ich meine, ich glaube, der wäre krepiert, wenn er nicht die MIDI-Schnittstelle
gehabt hätte, fest eingebaut.
Das war, sagen wir mal, so ein bisschen die Welt, die sich da abgebildet hat
und dann gab es halt noch die größeren Computer, so die, wie auch immer,
so Workstations und so, da war dann wie so dieses Unix.
Und das war so im Prinzip, Anfang der 90er Jahre war das so ein bisschen so die Welt.
Und dann ging es ja Apple erstmal nicht so gut, aber der Mac hat es trotzdem
irgendwie geschafft, so sich durchzusetzen, weil in der Lage war,
mit den Features, mit denen der erste Mac eben kam,
zwei, drei Branchen komplett neu zu erfinden. Vor allem natürlich die ganze
Grafikbranche, die einfach gesagt hat, geil, Print.
Das sogenannte Desktop-Publishing.
Genau, Desktop-Publishing. Das war einfach so das, was den Mac dann auch gerettet hat.
Und als ich dann irgendwie so auf den Mac kam, das war dann erst so Anfang der
90er, also ich habe den 80er mal gesehen und ein bisschen ausprobiert,
aber nie einen gehabt war, war ja irgendwie auch alles zu teuer und so.
Gehabt habe ich selber auch keinen.
Und dann hatte ich halt auf einmal einen, diesen 2CI und dann bin ich halt schon,
voll auf diesen Film gekommen mit, wow,
wenn irgendwie so Software und Hardware aufeinander abgestimmt ist, dann passiert da was.
Also das war irgendwie daneben stand so mein PC,
wo ich dann immer so Jumper auf Karten setzen musste, um das Ding überhaupt
erstmal in Betrieb nehmen zu können und so ein Mac schaltest du halt einfach
ein und dann lächelt der einen an und dann ist er irgendwie da und sagt,
benutze mich. Das fand ich irgendwie geil.
Wenn ich jetzt vorspule auf heute, was für mich jetzt quasi die,
ich sag mal so, also was ist für mich von Wert im Computerbereich?
Und das ist ja jetzt nicht nur Apple oder so. Ich kann irgendwie allem so ein
bisschen was abgewinnen und kann auch nicht einer Sache alles abgewinnen, sondern es sind immer so.
Teilaspekte, aber was schätze ich selbst eigentlich am meisten und was hilft mir auch am meisten.
Und da sind es, würde ich sagen, im Wesentlichen zwei Sachen und das ist so
die Formbarkeit von Unix,
die mich total geprägt hat, was also einfach das System ist,
wo du einfach am tiefsten mit deinen Armen in den Maschinenraum reingreifen
kannst und du kannst mit so einem Unix-System alles automatisieren,
alles bauen, alles erreichen,
alles importieren, exportieren, durchleiten,
kontrollieren, steuern.
Also diese Universalität ausgehend von dieser Simplizität des Kernels,
der Kommandozeile einfacher Ideen, das war irgendwie,
weiß ich nicht, für mich einer der größten Werte, die diese ganze Computerentwicklung
in den letzten 50 Jahren so genommen hat. Auf der einen Seite.
Und auf der anderen Seite ist es für mich halt so die Software mit Qualität,
die vom Nutzer her gedacht ist.
Wo man merkt, hier wird wirklich an den Menschen gedacht und darüber nachgedacht,
wie kann man ein bestimmtes Problem lösen.
Und man ist nicht so von der Technik her gekommen und dann gucken wir mal,
was man damit machen kann.
Und das kulminiert bei mir irgendwie so. Und als dann Apple angekündigt hat,
ja, wir fusionieren jetzt hier irgendwie Next Step, also Unix,
mit dem Mac, ich war in Ekstase.
Also das war einfach, macOS 10 war einfach die Lösung aller Probleme.
Da war sozusagen die beiden Sachen, die ich am allermeisten schätzte,
bis heute, kamen irgendwie zusammen.
Und jetzt hast du eben diese Systeme, die man kaufen kann und die,
weiß ich nicht, die so rund sind irgendwie.
Ich meine, ich habe hier meinen Laptop vorhin aufgestellt, habe den dann Strom
angeschlossen, habe den eingeschaltet und dann fiel mir auf so,
ah, Akku war komplett alle. Ist leer gegangen. Was macht er?
Ja, er hat einfach seinen RAM zu dem Zeitpunkt, als er gemerkt hat,
dass er keinen Strom hat, einfach auf die Platte gehibernated.
Und irgendwie in dem Moment, wo ich wieder Strom reinstecke,
so schlurpste sich das RAM-Image von der Platte und wacht wieder auf.
Aber es gab halt keinen Datenverlust.
Man hat also, abgesehen davon, dass ich ein paar Sekunden warten musste,
bis dieser Vorgang da war, das ging einfach so.
Und dann dachte ich mir so, geil, wenn einfach Hardware, Software aufeinander
abgestimmt ist und das irgendwie so als ein Ding gedacht wird.
Wo ich bereits sagte, also Windows kann das prinzipiell auch, wenn es funktioniert.
Wobei ich jetzt nichts dazu sagen soll, wie gut das funktioniert,
weil ich hatte nie einen Windows-Laptop. Ja, insofern, ja.
Also ich habe im Vorfeld für die Sendung auch überlegt, was ist so der Kernpunkt,
der mich eigentlich irgendwie dann zu Apple gebracht hat oder da auch hat bleiben
lassen so lange. Bis ich jetzt natürlich zu Linux drüber laufe.
Und ich habe das ja schon mal ein, zwei Mal in der Sendung erzählt.
Von daher habe ich nur die totale Kurzfassung.
Ich war ja wirklich sehr, sehr lange Windows-Fanboy gewesen.
Ja.
Wirklich lange. Bis ich 27 war. Da bin ich ja wahrscheinlich für dich die Ausnahme
hier in dem Podcast. Und das hat aber auch seinen Grund.
Also ich habe drei Jahre in einem Computerladen gearbeitet, damals Comtech und
irgendwie Windows-Rechner zusammengeschraubt und so.
Und ich hatte für das Mac-Lager zu dem Zeitpunkt eigentlich nur,
ja Verachtung ist jetzt ein starkes Wort, aber ich konnte die überhaupt nicht ernst nehmen.
Und der Grund war das Design.
Das Design insbesondere so von Mac OS 8 und 9. Ich fand das pottenhässlich.
So, das sah alles noch genauso aus wie auf dem Amiga damals.
Irgendwie null Entwicklung nach vorne. Und Windows zu dem Zeitpunkt,
da müsste man vielleicht nochmal AB-Screens nebeneinander halten,
ob ich das im Nachhinein verkläre.
Aber Windows, in meiner Erinnerung, hatte da einfach eine viel frischere.
Freundliche.
Das muss so, also sagen wir mal so, Jahr 1998.
Windows 98?
Nein.
Ja, und dann guck dem gegenüber mal macOS 9 dir an.
Aber ich glaube, was du da wirklich verklärst, ist wie Amiga aussah.
Ja, das stimmt. Das habe ich neulich mal gemacht und mich durch alte Screenfotos durchgelacht.
Ja, aber darum, also das habe ich dann nochmal mit macOS verbunden.
Und wir hatten damals bei Medienwissenschaftlern, Uni Göttingen,
hatten wir Leute, die dann plötzlich mit Macs ankamen, wo dann halt macOS 9 drauf war.
Und ich habe mir das angeguckt und kam dann halt so, ja, das ist das Überlegene und Usability und so.
Habe mir das angeguckt und dachte mir so, Leute, das ist total hässlich.
Wie könnt ihr euch sowas den ganzen Tag denn angucken?
Ja, das ist doch nicht schön hier. So, genau.
Andersrum ging es mir allerdings auch so, dass ich das dann als Windows 95 kam
und ich dachte, boah, das ist hässlich. Das kann man sich doch nicht an.
Tim hat jetzt ja gerade mal für Windows 98 einen Screen. Ja,
und wenn du jetzt dem gegenüber mal einen Mac OS 9 Screen dagegen hältst,
sieht das im Vergleich würde ich auch heute noch sagen altbacken aus.
Ja, sehr pixellig, sehr grobkantig, sehr irgendwie bemüht.
Ich würde sagen, zu dem Zeitpunkt hatte designtechnisch Windows die Nase vorne.
So und dann kam aber eben Mac OS X und Aqua Oberfläche und der Bernd Többen,
der Mediendesigner, neben dem ich damals im Büro saß, hat dann halt relativ
früh, ich weiß nicht, ob es jetzt 2000 oder 2001 war, aber so genau um die Ecke,
halt seinen ersten Mac, wo er das drauf hatte und das war alles clunky und ruckelte
und die ersten Versionen waren ja wirklich noch ziemlich mit Schmerzen behaftet. Vielen Dank.
Aber meine Güte, habe ich das Licht gesehen. Es sah so schön aus.
Und da war wirklich binnen Sekunden hat das in meinem Gehirn sich auf ewig verdrahtet,
so das ist der Weg, das ist die Zukunft, das ist wunderschön.
Wenn ich heute auf die ersten Aqua-Versionen gucke, denke ich auch so,
so toll sah es jetzt auch nicht aus, aber der Kontrast war einfach so brutal
von macOS 9 zu dieser Fassung und auch zu dem, was Windows zu dem Zeitpunkt hatte.
Das muss ja auch schon Windows 2000 gewesen sein oder sowas.
Mein Gott, war das schön damals.
Ja, da hat Steve Jobs damals wirklich auf die Tube drücken lassen,
in der Rückschau ein bisschen zu sehr.
Diese Schlagschatten, die da plötzlich irgendwie waren, das war alles irgendwie
die ganzen Abstände, das konnte atmen, der Whitespace wieder mit umgegangen
wurde, es war einfach fantastisch.
Und dann kam ja diese skurrile Phase, hatte ich ja auch schon ein paar Mal erzählt,
ja mach mal das 9.0, das fand ich noch härter. Wo sind noch so...
Das sah genau so aus.
Also ich hab hier einen, guck dir das mal an. Ich hab jetzt einen von dem ersten Neuner.
Mal hier.
Das sieht doch schon scheiße aus.
Das ist genau das gleiche.
Nee.
Doch, da hat sich gar nichts dran geändert.
Ich guck doch alleine hier die ganzen Rahmelemente an. Das sieht schon anders aus.
Ich muss meine Origin-Story da jetzt aber noch droppen, weil ich war nämlich
also angefangen mit dem C64, wie vielleicht viele,
bin ich damals tatsächlich dem Commodore-Lager treu geblieben und bin auf den
Amiga gewechselt und hab tatsächlich
einen der ersten Amiga 1000 dann auch irgendwie mir zusammengespart,
der übrigens heute noch im Computerspielemuseum hier in Berlin ist,
just jenes Gerät, ähm,
Und hatte dann noch einen Amiga 3000. Das war eigentlich auch ein ganz cooler Rechner.
Und vor allen Dingen, was Amiga halt damals schon hatte, sie waren relativ Unix
ähnlich, weil sie ein kooperatives, nicht ein kooperatives, sondern ein präemptives Multitasking hatten.
Also Programme sind wirklich gleichzeitig gelaufen.
Und als dann klar war, dass Commodore und Amiga, dass das alles kein gutes Ende
nehmen würde, habe ich das Ding dann verhückert und habe auf ein Mac gewechselt.
Irgendso ein Performa hieß der. Performa 475. Furchtbar. Und was war das für ein Erwachen?
Also das so, für mich war das erste Ankommen auf dem Mac, ich habe mich doch
ein wenig eingesperrt gefühlt.
Also es war immer noch besser als alles, was irgendwie in der PC-Welt,
da war ja Windows noch, ich glaube, da gab es noch ein 3.1 oder so,
wenn überhaupt, das meiste haben die Leute eh unter DOS gemacht.
Das war schon schwierig irgendwie, bis man so gelernt hat, wie man aus dem System
so halbwegs was rausholen konnte, irgendwie hatte ich das Gefühl.
Ja, da hatte ich dann irgendwann ein Power Mac und dann wurde es besser.
Und dann tatsächlich, als Apple dann Next gekauft hat, weil in der Ära, also auch Mac OS 9,
ich glaube 9 ist tatsächlich schon auch unter Steve entstanden.
Das war ja auch nur so ein Übergangsding für, wir brauchen noch ein bisschen
mit 10, aber wir machen mal 9 hier.
Da hatte ich dann tatsächlich irgendein Developer Preview mir rangeholt.
Da hieß es dann so, Apple so, ja, wer das haben will, schreib uns mal, wir schicken es euch.
So ungefähr war das. und habe ich hingeschrieben, habe ich eins zurückgekriegt
und die PC-Version allerdings und habe das dann auf irgendeinem PC installiert und das war schon geil.
So der erste Blick so, hey, das funktioniert mal ordentlich.
Ja, keine Ahnung.
Aber ich merke bei mir, dass das bis heute verfängt. Ich möchte nicht auf hässliche
Nutzeroberflächen schauen.
Ich möchte auf, Tim, du hast da gesagt, so die UX, wie bedient sich das und
ist das so vom Nutzer aus gedacht?
Ja, das kann ich schon auch alles verstehen, aber für mich so die magischen
Mac-Momente waren immer,
wenn ich dann beispielsweise meiner Schwester viele Jahre später so mit großen
Trara ihren ersten Mac eingerichtet habe und man dann so App um App,
damals nannten das glaube ich noch Programme, da gab es noch keine Apps,
so gestartet habe und dann wirklich so die Augen funkeln, weil das alles so schick und so nett war.
Also beispielsweise gab es damals so ein Programm, da konnte man seine Videokassetten
und DVD-Sammlungen drin scannen und seine Bücher.
Erinnert ihr euch noch daran?
Ja, Outer Mac OS X. Ja, ja.
Library.
Ganz starkes Choreophorphe.
Genau, was mit Library. Irgendwie Nice Library oder Delicious Library.
Ja, genau. Delicious Monster hieß nämlich auch die Firma.
Du konntest die Kamera ansprechen, dann konntest du einfach den Barcode einscannen
und dann fluppte das, was du gerade in der Hand hielst, fluppte dort in dein
virtuelles Bücherregal rein.
Und wenn du das Leuten damals gezeigt hattest, Ja, das fühlte sich ja exakt.
Delicious Library 2 war das damals, ja.
So, das war so nett einfach alles. Und das gab es woanders überhaupt nicht auf
so einer Qualitätsebene.
Ja, so auch die frühen iTunes-Versionen. iTunes war ja auch mal richtig toll
im Vergleich zu dem, was Winamp so zu dem Zeitpunkt irgendwo hatte.
Das heißt, du hattest dann irgendwie zwei Stunden selber Spaß,
weil du anderen Leuten plötzlich die Zukunft zeigen konntest und wusstest,
deren Leben wird jetzt gerade besser.
Das haben wir auch schon ein paar Mal darüber gesprochen. Damals gab es halt
auch noch einen anderen Entwicklerinnen-Ethos.
Wie muss so eine App gebaut sein und wie muss sich das anfühlen?
Und wir brauchen so ein bisschen Magic und so ein bisschen Feenstaub irgendwie drauf.
Dinge ein bisschen anders machen, netter, detailverliebter als anderswo.
Und das ist halt alles weg.
Und darum bin ich jetzt auch gegen, jetzt haben wir halt Glas hier.
Und deshalb bin ich jetzt auch gerade so aufgeschlossen für diese ganze Linux-Geschichte.
Da werden jetzt halt Sachen probiert. Und das gucke ich mir jetzt mal an.
Offensichtlich muss, kennt einer von euch noch die Drombuschs?
Vera, du hast deine Mitte verloren.
Ach nein. Also designtechnisch hat Apple, was Software angeht,
einfach gerade irgendwie keinen guten Lauf.
Und mögen sie sich gerne wieder erholen und dann bin ich da auch wieder begeistert
dahinter, aber ich habe seit langer Zeit nicht mehr diesen Moment gehabt,
das ist mal geile Apple Software hier.
Das macht mal richtig Spaß, da ist eine coole neue UX-Idee drin verbaut.
Sowas hätte ich gerne wieder. Ein delicious Library fürs neue Jahrtausend.
Also ich meine, diese Softwarekritik, die ist ja auch berechtigt und sicherlich
muss Apple hier gerade mal wieder ein bisschen anziehen, aber es ist ja jetzt
nicht so, dass sie jetzt ihre ganzen Systeme irgendwie verkackt werden.
Gerade als wir diese Linux-Debatte hatten, kam ja auch so in den Kommentaren
ja immer so viel so, oh Tim, warum hängst du denn so an deinem Mac?
Ja, du kannst doch das auch alles mit Linux haben.
Und da habe ich viel drüber nachgedacht in letzter Zeit und dachte mir so, ist denn das so?
Und eigentlich ist es...
Überhaupt nicht so, weil eigentlich in dieser Linux-Welt zählt im Wesentlichen
eigentlich nur Technik.
Es hat sich halt ein bisschen entwickelt und breiter aufgestellt,
mehr Leute benutzen das, da kommen dann halt auch mal Leute dazu,
die andere Hobbys haben,
aber was nicht irgendjemandes Hobby ist, ist halt dort eigentlich auch nicht wirklich zu Hause.
Also es entwickelt sich alles nur aus dem System und aus der Technik heraus.
Mir geht es jetzt nicht darum, hier irgendwie so ein Linux-Baschling zu machen,
sondern ich wollte es eigentlich eher umdrehen auf diese Frage mit,
was läuft denn so mit mir und meinem Apple-System?
Und jetzt können ja alle anfangen mit Ja und Abhängigkeiten und irgendwie Stockholm-Syndrom
und so weiter, aber diese Produkte liefern mir ja was und es ist halt vor allem
diese vertikale Integration,
die ich so schätze, die ja generell kritisch gesehen wird.
Man sagt ja mal, ja, aber Standards und alles muss mit allem zusammengehen.
Jetzt kommt ja auch so die EU und sagt so, ja, ihr müsst aber hier überall irgendwie,
Plugins schaffen und Schnittstellen und Leute reinlassen, weil der Markt und so.
Und Apple würde halt lieber so ein bisschen in Ruhe gelassen werden.
Und dann ist natürlich schnell so diese Unterstellung im Raum so,
ja, ihr wollt ja gar keine Wettbewerber haben und teilweise ist das sicherlich
auch so. Aber ich denke, dass es ihn auch einfach,
generell nicht in den Kram passt, weil es halt einfach ihrem Softwaremodell widerspricht.
Und das Softwaremodell ist halt, wir integrieren alles und unsere Kernidee ist,
wir stimmen alles sehr gut aufeinander ab.
Und das ist halt das, was du eigentlich außerhalb des Apple-Ökosystems nirgendwo hast.
Also ich wüsste kein Beispiel für irgendeinen anderen Hersteller,
bei dem diese ganze vertikale Integration überhaupt irgendeine Bedeutung hat.
Also wo das im Mittelpunkt steht. Vielleicht mal irgendein kleines Start-up
und so weiter, die was gut machen, aber die natürlich überhaupt nicht über so
ein Ökosystem verfügen.
Aber bei Apple ist es halt das Prinzip.
Und was heißt denn das jetzt für mich? Also erstmal, ich habe zum Beispiel diese Apple Watch.
Für diese Apple Watch gibt es überhaupt gar keinen Ersatz in der Linux- oder
Windows-Welt. nichts, was auch nur ansatzweise das tut, was dieses Teil für mich tut.
In der Android-Welt meinst du jetzt?
Welcher? Android, Windows, Linux, keine Ahnung. Es gibt ja nicht so viel.
Doch, es gibt schon Smartwatches unter Android, die auch ganz brauchbare Dinge tun. So ist es nicht.
Ja, klar gibt es Smartwatches, die brauchbare Dinge tun. Da gibt es auch Computer,
die ganz brauchbare Dinge tun. Aber sie sind halt nicht alle integriert ineinander.
Naja, zu dem restlichen Android-Ökosystem natürlich schon.
Aber du hast jetzt natürlich eine Integration zwischen Android und macOS nicht.
Oder zwischen Android und irgendeinem Desktop-System nicht, weil Google ja auch
das mit dem Chrome OS verkackt hat.
Ja, aber du wirst nichts finden, was so sehr miteinander verbunden ist,
wie das halt innerhalb des Apple-Universums miteinander verbunden ist.
Das geht halt einfach sehr weit.
Das fängt von der einheitlichen User-Interface-Geschichte an,
aber vor allem den ganzen kryptografisch abgesicherten Datenaustausch,
das automatische Syncing, was hier stattfindet.
Ich trage dieses Teil, es misst die ganze Zeit meinen Puls, es trackt meinen
Schlaf, es macht all diese ganzen Dinge und es fügt sich komplett nahtlos hier einfach mit ein.
Ich habe damit genau überhaupt gar keinen Ärger.
Ich kaufe mir eine neue Version von der Uhr, die Daten sind in 0,
nix auf dem neuen System aus dem iCloud Backup übertragen.
Es läuft einfach so weiter.
Genau das Gleiche findet in meinem Telefon statt, mit dem iPad,
mit der Vision Pro, mit dem Mac.
Alles evolviert, alles läuft zusammen.
Es gibt sicherlich noch Bereiche, wo ich mir mehr Integration wünschen könnte.
Aber insgesamt ist dieses Ökosystem extrem leistungsfähig.
Es deckt nahezu alle Bereiche des Personal Computings ab.
So und das ist natürlich eine Leistung, die muss man auch mal anerkennen.
Aber ich würde sagen, relativ dicht dran kommt aber schon so der Google Stack.
Also von Chromebook über Android-Smartphone über Android-Smartwatch.
Was da auch so die Integration der Datenebene angeht, würde ich sagen,
hat man da nicht viel Distanz zum Apple-Universum.
Das wäre jetzt neu, dass das da alles nicht geht.
Google macht aber keine Hardware.
Naja, Google Pixel-Handys hast du durchaus. Chromebooks, die daraufhin optimiert sind.
Das ist ja aber auch nur anderer Leute Hardware. wurde.
Ja gut, aber entlang von kleinen Spezifikationen, die von Google vorgegeben
werden. Also dafür hast du dann ein bisschen Auswahl. Das ist ja auch nicht so verkehrt.
Klar, die probieren das. Aber es ist halt nicht ansatzweise so weit entwickelt,
wie das halt im Apple-Universum der Fall ist.
Also da würde mich jetzt mal so eine A-B-Tabelle interessieren.
Also da würde ich mal vermuten, dass du jetzt in den Kommentaren im Blockwüste
Gegenbeispiel Beschimpfungen für einen sammelst.
Ich glaube, wenn du dich mit Leib und Seele dem Google-Universum verschreibst,
wie wir es jetzt dem Apple-Universum tun, hast du da nicht viel Unterschied
in der User-Experience.
Da habe ich jetzt natürlich einen Datenpunkt, weil bei uns in der Firma arbeiten
ja auch viele Android-Entwickler und die arbeiten alle auf dem Mac.
Also niemand von denen hat ein Chromebook oder irgendwie sowas.
Die Android-Entwickler. Also das ist irgendwie so, auf dem Desktop ist Google
im Prinzip ja nur ein Browser.
Ein sehr erfolgreicher Browser, weil sie es geschafft haben,
auch sehr viel, was mal Desktop-Programme waren, quasi zu Webseiten zu machen.
Aber am Ende ja, weiß nicht also der Punkt von Tim ist natürlich richtig,
also die Integration in der,
Güte, wie sie Apple hinkriegt in der Konsistenz, wie sie Apple hinkriegt,
ist unbesehen das Einzige, was mir jetzt in vertikaler Integration jetzt noch
am ehesten einfallen würde ist Tesla,
die im Prinzip auch fast alles selber machen,
bauen ihre Motoren bauen ihre Sitze und so weiter.
Klar, die haben auch Zulieferer, aber sie machen ihre eigene Software und so
weiter. Sie machen ihre eigenen Backends, sie machen ihre eigene AI, bla bla bla.
Nicht, dass ich jetzt sagen wollen würde, dass,
Tesla jetzt die Autos sind, die ich unbedingt haben würde. Also das,
was da draußen mit vier Rädern steht, spricht eine andere Sprache.
Aber in Sachen vertikaler Integration sind die schon ganz gut dabei, würde ich sagen.
Ja, definitiv. Und ich glaube auch gerade im Zulieferbereich sind sie auch extrem
hinterher, all diese ganzen Komponenten auch selber zu entwickeln.
Das ist halt auch etwas, was durchaus für Tesla spricht, wenn sie nicht so einen
scheiß Nazi als Chef hätten, dann hätte ich vielleicht durchaus auch Gefühle für Tesla.
Ja, beziehungsweise ab und zu mal halt die Quartalszahlen wichtiger sind als die Qualität.
Ich habe auch jetzt Gefühle für Tesla, aber keine schönen.
Ja, aber als du Delicious Library angesprochen hast, das ist eine sehr interessante Zeit gewesen.
Also in der Zeit war ich quasi, habe ich angefangen für Mac-Plattformen zu entwickeln
und es war damals eine unglaubliche Aufbruchsstimmung bei Third-Party-Entwicklern.
Schon allein deswegen, weil die Plattform selber ja so auf so einer steilen Kurve war.
Und wenn du da wusstest, was du getan hast, hast entsprechend Arbeit reingesteckt
und ein schönes Produkt gemacht, dann hast du von alleine richtig viel Geld verdient, weil,
Die Plattform wurde ja immer größer, es kamen immer mehr User dazu,
die das gesehen haben und toll und das muss man jetzt hier haben und so weiter.
Und diese Aufbruchstimmung ist komplett weg.
Also schon das iPhone hat diese Aufbruchstimmung gar nicht mehr so richtig.
Oh, das würde ich nicht sagen.
Ich rede jetzt von Third-Party-Entwicklern.
Das erste Jahr nach App-Store war der Hammer. Ich weiß es, weil ich war mal
auf Platz 3 des App-Stores Deutschland.
Ja, natürlich. Das war irre.
Und dann ist irgendwann das Ganze immer weiter verdichtet, kommerzialisiert.
Du musstest immer größere Budgets reinstopfen.
Heute ist das ganz anders. Vor allen Dingen, als Apple anfing und den App Store
öffnet hat und noch in der Keynote, als es um den App Store ging,
Apps vorgeführt hat, die alle einstellige Dollarbeträge gekostet haben.
War irgendwie allen klar, allen Third-Party-Entwicklern klar so,
oh, die wollen uns die Preise drücken und mal so richtig.
Also hier kriegen wir kein ordentliches Geschäftsmodell auf den Boden.
Und dann die 30 Prozent, die damals wirklich unerhört waren.
Gut, heutzutage Steam nimmt so viel, Sony nimmt glaube ich auch so viel, ist egal.
Aber das war halt, wo wirklich dann diese Aufbruchsstimmung echt im Keim erstickt
wurde. Und dann wurden ja von Apple reihenweise Apps abgelehnt,
die irgendwas versucht haben.
Der erste Podcast-Client, der rauskam, zack, weg.
Nee, ihr verbraucht zu viel Daten, bla bla bla und so weiter.
Nee, nee, das war die Replikation vorhandener Funktionen. Das war der Grund,
warum das Ding abgedehnt wurde.
Nee, aber es gab ja von Apple keine Podcast-App.
Wirklich ganz am Anfang.
In iTunes war das damals integriert, aber halt. Du konntest auf dem iPhone glaube
ich schon immer in iTunes Podcasts.
Ja, es gab die iPod. Podcast war immer dabei.
Echt?
Auf dem Phone, an der iPod. Breakthrough Communication Device. Ja, aber ich glaube.
Du konntest gar nicht vom iPhone selber aus die Podcasts runterladen,
sondern die wurden irgendwie über den Mac gesynkt oder so.
Also das waren alles so Sachen, immer wenn jemand was probiert hatte,
wurde er abgeschnitten und alle waren immer mehr so, ey, was soll denn das?
Sollen wir jetzt Apps für euch machen oder nicht?
Ich glaube, dafür musste sich selber erstmal diesen Gedanken irgendwie gewöhnen,
dass das iPhone mehr ist als nur Wessel für ihre eigenen Sachen.
Ja, bei der Uhr halten sie es ja ähnlich so, ne, du kannst jetzt hier keine
beliebigen Watchfaces releasen dafür und so.
Also Watch-Apps sind extrem eingeschränkt in dem, was sie tun können. Zu Recht, aber...
Ich würde gerne nochmal auf dein Ding gehen. Aber hier Android bietet dir doch
das gleiche. Das Argument.
Das ist einfach ganz faktisch falsch, weil es gibt kein Desktop Android OS.
Und was betreibt ein Chromebook? Also damit kannst du ja nicht die Dinge tun,
die du von einem Computer erwartest.
Genau, damit kann ich nicht die Dinge tun, die ich von einem Computer erwarte.
Aber damit kannst du die Dinge tun, die vielleicht 80 Prozent der Leute da draußen
völlig ausreichend finden. Ist mir doch egal.
Was 80 Prozent der Leute vollkommen ausreichend finden. Ich will ja einen richtigen
Computer haben und nicht irgendeinen Scheiß.
Das ist aber halt eine Exotenmeinung und keine Mainstream-Meinung.
Naja gut, aber ich meine, Chrome OS ist auch eine Exotenmeinung.
Also mal ganz ehrlich, ich kenne niemanden, der das ernsthaft benutzt.
Da gibt es doch auch keine ernsthaften Apps dafür.
Da brauchst du ja nicht, weil ja schon alle dabei sind.
Aha, ja, was ist denn da dabei?
So, da ist Google Docs drauf, Google Kalk und Google Mail und Chrome zum Browsen.
So, mehr brauchen die Leute da draußen nicht.
Ach so, es geht nicht um die Leute, es geht um mich.
Ja, das ist mir schon klar. Aber wenn du sagst, das funktioniert nicht,
dann musst du halt immer so, das funktioniert für dich nicht.
Für andere da draußen funktioniert das sehr wohl. Von nichts anderem.
Ich habe damit auch begonnen, was ist für mich wichtig, was ist für mich der Wert dieser Plattform.
Das ist meine ganze Prämisse.
Ihr habt alle andere Meinungen, ihr habt alle andere Computer.
Völlig in Ordnung. Aber die Frage war ja, warum machst du denn nicht X?
Und dann kann ich einfach nur sagen, ich bin zwar hier nicht mit allem zufrieden,
weil ich bin nie mit allem zufrieden.
Man darf auch nicht mit allem zufrieden sein, aber sie haben schon wirklich
ein sehr rundes System abgeliefert, in dem sich vor allem auch eine ganze Menge Entwickler,
Firmen, Einzelpersonen tummeln, die einfach auch einen geilen Style haben.
Und das ist so ein bisschen das andere Ding.
Apple hat es schon immer vermocht und eigentlich über die Jahre auch weiter ausgebaut.
Vielleicht ist es so ein bisschen am Schluss so ein bisschen verloren gegangen,
aber grundsätzlich kannst du immer noch sagen, du hast da sehr viele,
sehr gute Entwicklerteams, die Software machen für dieses Ökosystem,
weil sie auch genau Leute adressieren, ich sag mal wie mich.
Also Leute, die, oder auch wie dich. Also dir ist es ja auch wichtig,
dass es gut aussieht, dass es sich ordentlich bedienen lässt,
dass auch das letzte Detail und der Feinschliff stimmt und der Schattenwurf und Pipapo.
Und das Fondspacing, das Kerning muss irgendwie stimmen und ansonsten fängst
du ja an, Mülltonnen anzuzünden. So viel ist man sicher. Ja genau so.
Und das einigt auch glaube ich alle, die bisher hier um diesen Freakshow-Tisch
herum immer saßen. Wir sind diese Leute.
Wir sind diese Leute, die das geil finden. Wir haben eine Begeisterung für diese.
Computerkultur, die sich darüber entwickelt hat.
Und das ist so ein bisschen das, was uns auch so fasziniert an diesen Maschinen
und warum wir auch bereit sind, da einfach nochmal tausend Euro mehr auszugeben,
weil scheiß drauf, sieht geil aus.
Und das ist schon, das ist das Lagerfeuer Apple.
Und da gibt es kein anderes Lagerfeuer, was die ähnliche Farbgebung hat. Gibt es einfach nicht.
Die anderen Lagerfeuer, da brennt auch Feuer.
Aber das flackert nicht so schön.
Das ist halt so ein Heizstrahler.
Genau, die sitzen da um den Heizstrahler herum.
Da knistert es nicht. Da sind die kleinen Funken, die so durch die Luft feuern.
Ja, reicht mir doch, ist doch warm.
Ja, das ist die Windows-Welt, oder?
Ja, genau, das ist die Windows-Welt.
Und das ist...
Das ist der Hauptgrund. Der andere Grund ist natürlich, mich begleitet das jetzt
schon so lange, ich schmeiß den Scheiß natürlich nicht weg.
Und es tut ja nach wie vor alles richtig für mich.
Also ich bin jetzt eh nicht die
Zielgruppe, um irgendwie jemanden von dem Apple-Ökosystem wegzumigrieren.
Aber natürlich ist die Frage, wie können sie diesen Spirit auch aufrechterhalten und neue Leute sehen.
Und ich denke, das werden wir jetzt an diesem MacBook Neo, werden wir das sehr schön sehen.
Das haben wir ja letztes Mal auch schon andiskutiert, dass das Ding ja eigentlich der Knaller ist.
Und bis erst im Nachgang eigentlich klar geworden, warum das Ding eigentlich so ein Knaller ist.
Weil, also, okay, es ist, sagen wir mal, ein MacBook, das kostet so nicht ganz
die Hälfte, aber so gefühlt die Hälfte als eine entsprechende MacBook Air Option.
Also hat einen ganz anderen Einstiegspreis und ist von daher natürlich für viele
Leute dann überhaupt schon mal so auf einen Wunschzettel oder sagen wir mal
zumindest wird es erstmal erwogen.
Ja, deutlich unter 1000 Euro kann ich ausgeben. Über 1000 Euro könnte ich oder
würde ich nicht ausgeben wollen.
Und dann sieht das Ding irgendwie ganz nett aus etc.
Und dann dieser Preis. Und dann guckst du mal so ein bisschen in diesen Windows-Markt,
auf dem ich mich zugegebenermaßen nicht gut auskenne.
Aber ich habe so mit Interesse verschiedene Analysen mir jetzt so angeschaut,
die Leute so gemacht haben.
Nach dem Motto, ja, gibt eigentlich gar nicht so viele Windows-Laptops,
die jetzt mit diesen Specs so groß mithalten können.
Und selbst wenn sie bei den Specs halbwegs mithalten können,
also was so Performance, Speicher und so weiter betrifft, sehen sie halt scheiße aus.
Das ist halt irgendwie so Plastikbomber mit den von dir schon monierten schlechten
Trackpads und anderen Sachen.
Und dann kommen sie noch mit irgendwie tonnenweise Bloatware vorinstalliert.
Und der Grund dafür ist natürlich, dass einfach zu viele Unternehmen da mit drin sind.
Der Prozessorhersteller will seine Marge.
Der Gerätehersteller will seine Marge.
Windows will seine Marge.
Grafikkarten.
Also wenn du eine dedizierte hast, will seine Marge. Aber in der Preisklasse
hast du keine dedizierten Grafikkarten in Laptops.
Das fängt an. Also ich habe auch ein bisschen recherchiert, weil es gab auch
ein paar Kommentare zur letzten Sendung.
Hier guckt euch doch Gerät XY an, das kann das doch auch alles.
So für irgendwie nur 50 Euro weniger.
Dann habe ich wirklich nochmal zwei Stunden investiert und dann ein bisschen
rumrecherchiert und ich finde die Lage da nicht so komplett eindeutig.
Also es ist schon, die sind da jetzt auf so einem Preissegment,
wo du auch schon wirklich brauchbare Windows-Laptops bekommst.
Auch schon mit Unibody und Metall und nicht mehr nur Plaste.
Ich weiß jetzt nicht, wie gut die Tastaturen sind, wie gut die Trackpads sind.
Da hatte ich ja in der letzten Sendung auch das eine oder andere zugesagt.
Aber Retina-Screens kriegst du schon auch in der Preisklasse.
Das ist also auch alles nicht anhört auf. Und den meisten, die dann dort sind,
hast du dann 16 GB RAM drin.
Und eine 512er-Platte. Das ist dann dafür schon in dem Preissegment bei Windows totaler Standard.
Brauchst du auch.
Unter Windows auf jeden Fall eher als unter macOS, ja, Punkt.
War ja mein Argument auch letzte Sendung, so mit dem 8 GB kommt man wahrscheinlich
gar nicht mal so schlecht hin.
Das ist also auch das, was die ganzen Tests hier alle zeigen.
Du kannst damit 4G Video schneiden, ohne dass das irgendwo nennenswert oder
überhaupt irgendwo ruckelt, weil du konntest es auf dem iPhone auch schon.
Das hatte auch keine 16 GB RAM mit dem selben Setup.
Also auch wieder ist es glaube ich nicht ganz so eindeutig, wie du sagst.
Aber sagen wir mal so, du kriegst nicht für 150 oder 200 Euro weniger,
was auch nur ansatzweise vergleichbar ist im PC-Lager. Und das ist schon neu, die Situation.
Weil dass du für 1100 Euro einen Top-Windows-Laptop bekommst,
was mit jedem Air quasi mithält, das ist einfach mal so. Da brauchen wir nicht
anfangen zu diskutieren.
Da ist die Bild-Quality wirklich sehr vergleichbar in dem Segment.
Aber so um diese 600 Euro rum, da ist die Luft auf jeden Fall schon mal ganz
schön dünn und ich habe auch, da haben wir wahrscheinlich dieselben Sachen gelesen,
es gingen so ein paar Standards rum,
die PC-Industrie ist jetzt auch nicht so ganz tiefenentspannt, was diese Neos angeht.
Und sagen so, okay, das kommt jetzt so ein bisschen unerwartet und passt uns
gerade eigentlich nicht so.
Wir hatten eigentlich nicht vor, jetzt hier die große Qualitätsoffensive zu
machen, weil ich war gerade heute wieder bei Mediamarkt aus Gründen und da hatten
sie jetzt das in Blau, nicht meine Farbe. Wie gesagt, dieses Gelb.
Geil, Citrus, ja. Aber dieses Ding fühlt sich einfach geil an.
Also wenn du das in der Hand hast und du hast dann daneben irgendwas aus Plastik
bei Windows, da weiß ich, wo die Leute sagen würden, ja, dass da vorne ist,
aber schon irgendwie deutlich schöner.
Also ja, man findet welche im Windows-Lager, aber die stehen dann vielleicht
auch nicht bei Mediamarkt, direkt daneben. Das ist vielleicht auch so ein Faktor.
Also wie lange suchst du dann auch, um wirklich diese drei, vier Geräte zu identifizieren,
die da mithalten können versus du hast es halt wirklich jetzt in jedem Eulen-Store
einfach mal stehen und ist ein Statement.
Dieses Gerät ist in Sachen Bild-Quality, ist das ein super Statement,
was man zu dem Preis machen kann, wenn man will.
Ich habe mir im Nachgang auch nochmal drüber nachgedacht und ich finde einen
ganz anderen Aspekt eigentlich sehr spannend.
Nämlich, wie Apple mal wieder eine Low-Cost-Schiene aufmacht.
Also dieser Performer, von dem ich sprach, was mein allererster Mac war,
war ja im Prinzip damals Low-Cost-Schiene.
Wir geben Leuten, die nicht so viel Geld,
haben oder bezahlen wollen, ein Gerät an die Hand und sie können Mac machen.
Irgendwann gab es den iMac, der im Prinzip auch so ein bisschen ein Low-Cost-Gerät war unten.
Dann gab es den Mac Mini nochmal als Low-Cost-Gerät und in dieser Schiene fährt das Neo komplett mit.
Das ist auch das Low-Cost-Gerät, was plötzlich alle anderen Geräte von Apple
im Preis super unterbietet und was halt so ein Einstiegstor ist für Leute,
die noch nie darüber nachgedacht haben, dass sie ein Mac haben,
weil er ihnen einfach zu teuer ist. Und plötzlich kommen sie mit so einem Teil um die Ecke.
Also das ist schon nicht wirklich weltbewegend neu, aber wieder mal gut gemacht.
Es gab doch bei den MacBooks auch mal dieses Plastikding mit diesem Haltegriff.
Erinnert ihr euch? Ein Buch G4. Dieses sehr runde Knubbelige.
Wo lag das preislich? Habt ihr das noch irgendwo im Kopf? Ob das eigentlich
auch in so einer markanten Preisregion unterwegs war? Oder war das Feuer?
Es war auf jeden Fall.
Ich kann den Originalpreis in Dollar sagen, wenn dir das weiterhilft.
Also ich kann mich erinnern, dass es sehr stark auf Studenti,
Studis getrimmt war. auch dieses, es hat den Griff und man nimmt es mit zur
Vorlesung und so weiter.
Keine Ahnung. Ich fand das damals nicht übermäßig hübsch und hätte mich mit
Händen und Füßen gewehrt, falls mir jemand so ein Ding unterschieben hätte wollen.
Ich habe die auch wenig in the wild gesehen. Ich könnte mir nicht entsinnen,
dass man die viel gesehen hätte.
Aber ja, sind vielleicht auch in dieser Produktkategorie.
Wir müssen mal wieder User einsammeln, die nicht in unser Ökosystem kommen wollen,
mit einem günstigen Angebot. Kann durchaus sein.
Also ein Buch.
Aber ich glaube, die waren nicht so 2000.
Kamen die raus.
Ich dachte, das wäre der Preis. Nein.
Und der Preis?
Steht hier gar nicht. Wieso steht der hier nicht?
Was sagt der Mac-Tracker?
Ich bin der Mac-Tracker.
Aber da steht der Preis nicht. Ist da nicht früher immer der Preis dabei?
Doch, der müsste in einem der hinteren Tabs in so einem Infodialog sein.
Ach so, hier, 1599,
US-Dollar. Also keine Ahnung, was das damals als in D-Mark war.
Aber 900 Dollar billiger als das Powerbook. Also vergleichbar.
War aber nicht so der Preisbrüller, wo man sagt, das ist ein No-Brainer,
jetzt da irgendwo hinzugehen und zum Teil zu kaufen.
Nee, eindeutig nicht. Das hätte ich gedacht, wäre deutlich unter 1.000 auch gewesen.
Nee, aber ich weiß, dass der Mac Mini zum Beispiel damals, glaube ich,
auch mit 600 anfing. Oder waren es 500 Dollar oder so?
Irgendwie sowas. Bring your own shit.
Der erste Mac Mini.
Der erste Mac Mini, ja.
Der kam 2005 raus und der hat 499 US Dollar gekostet.
Ja, 500 Dollar. Der war, ja, also der war damals wirklich so,
oha, zu dem Preis, ein Mac.
Und ich glaube, das Neo ist halt in dieser Schiene drin.
Genau.
Ich kann nur wiederholen, für mich wäre es wahrscheinlich nichts.
Aber gut, das soll niemanden abhalten.
Ja, also um es vielleicht mal abzurunden, das finde ich ist halt schon jetzt
eine Leistung, die Apple über all diese Jahrzehnte geleistet hat.
Und sie haben halt ihren festen und wie ich finde auch berechtigten Spot in
dieser ganzen Computerlandschaft und es gibt halt nichts, was so ist wie Apple.
In der Computerwelt.
Ja, also es gibt halt, wie du schon jetzt mit Tesla angefangen hast,
es gibt so einzelne Unternehmen, die in ihren Branchen versuchen,
einen ähnlichen Style zu fahren, ob das jetzt bewusst oder unbewusst ist.
Man kann ja gewisse Lehren daraus ziehen.
Das ist ja auch völlig in Ordnung und ich finde, da kann man sich auch eine Menge abgucken.
Es ist ein bisschen schwierig, diese spezifische Kultur, die sich da jetzt sozusagen
über die Zeit auch erarbeitet haben, irgendwie vollständig zu replizieren.
Das gelingt ja auch vielen Ex-Apple-Mitarbeitern, die dann ihre eigenen Firmen
aufbauen und versuchen irgendwas zu machen.
Auch nicht so ohne weiteres. Das ist auch, glaube ich, nicht so einfach kopierbar.
Das kann in dem Sinne auch nur wahrscheinlich da sein, wirklich,
wo es herkommt und wo es ja auch sagen wir mal an Landleute,
Orte und so weiter auch angedockt ist.
Es muss auch jetzt nicht unbedingt alles, so wie Apple sein.
Ich würde mir manchmal mehr wünschen, es gäbe mal andere Contender,
die diesen Weg versuchen einzuschlagen.
Aber die meisten sind halt dann doch eher immer so von so Sales Joits angeführt,
die dann halt, ja, nee, das muss ich rechnen, bla bla bla, alles viel zu teuer und so weiter.
Und mit diesem Luxus Appeal schafft es halt Apple da ein.
Eine ganz andere Erwartungshaltung zu machen. Also es ist halt für die Leute,
denen es dann am Ende auf diese 50 Dollar nicht ankommt.
Und wenn du sagst, okay, jetzt gibt es aber einen Windows-Laptop,
dann guck mal, der kostet aber sogar noch 100 Euro weniger als so ein MacBook Neo.
Das ist ja ungefähr so, als ob du sagst, ja hier, guck mal, der Fiat,
der kostet ja irgendwie 100 Euro weniger. Für 100 Euro mehr könntest du hier
einen Mercedes kriegen.
Zeigst du mir doch mal den Vogel, mit dem Fiat aus der Sonne,
weil du dann einfach diesen Brand Value natürlich noch obendrauf hast und wenn
Apple jetzt wie so gerüchtet wird, gerade so,
ja, naja, dann schrauben wir mal so unsere Margen-Erwartungen in diesem Segment
mal ein bisschen zurück und verdienen mal nicht 38% an jedem Gerät,
was so ihre Durchschnittsmarge ist, sondern wir gehen jetzt mal auf, keine Ahnung, 35, 32,
weil verdienen wir ja immer noch was dran, aber wir können jetzt unter Umständen
mal den Markt mal pushen.
Also ich wäre jetzt, ich will da nichts voraussagen, aber ich wäre nicht überrascht,
wenn wir in einem Jahr feststellen, wenn sie ihre Macintosh,
Verkaufszahlen dann mal wieder veröffentlichen, im nächsten Quartal vielleicht
schon, dass da auf einmal ein spürbarer Bump drin ist.
Also könnte mir fast, also ich will jetzt nicht von Verdoppelung reden,
aber ich glaube, wir werden eine deutlich vergrößerte Macintosh Userbase sehen und wenn,
Apple da die richtigen Lehren draus zieht und das vielleicht auch noch auf andere
Produktsegmente erweitern kann.
Ich meine, beim iPhone haben sie es ja auch schon so ansatzweise gemacht mit
diesen SE-Dingern und wie heißt jetzt das neue?
R?
Günstige?
Achso, nee, das ist das nicht.
E. SE2?
Genau. Geht ja auch schon so ein bisschen in diese Richtung und wahrscheinlich
für das nächste Neo der noch größere Brüller sein, wenn sie dann halt 12 GB RAM drin haben und.
Aber bekommt man das nicht auch mit 16? Irgendwie war doch da was für ein Honig mehr.
Nee, geht's nicht. Du kannst es mit mehr Festplatte machen und mit,
was war die andere Änderung?
Du hast dann Touch-ID noch mit dabei.
Achso, ja. Ja, Marktsegmentierung, das ist natürlich auch wichtig.
Das machen die Sales-Droids halt auch.
Dann, wenn du halt in einem anderen Markt unterwegs bist, dann musst du halt
für einen anderen Markt dann auch das Geld hinlegen. Das ist irgendwie...
Also ich bin ja ganz froh, dass das alles so gekommen ist, weil ich muss sagen,
ich war, als Apple in der Krise war, 95, 94, so als Apple so richtig kurz vorm
Exodus war, da war ich echt deprimiert.
Ich war da sehr schadenfroh.
Ende 97 haben sie dann Next gekauft. Oder Ende 96.
War es nicht 95?
Nee, nee, nee. Also ich weiß noch, wie ich bei irgendeiner Party war und ein
Bekannter von mir so ankam und meinte, ja, so Apple hat Next gekauft.
Und ich hab so, was haben sie gemacht?
Ende 96.
Ende 96, genau.
Und wann war Bill Gates auf der Bühne? Das war dann ja auch so ein Moment,
so Achtung, Microsoft rettet jetzt hier Apple. Ich meine, das war danach gewesen.
Das war danach, weil erst mit dem Kauf kam ja Steve Jobs überhaupt zu Apple wieder.
Stimmt.
Ja, da hast du recht.
Ja, dieser Auftritt, das war auch echt ein Schachzug, weil...
Und eigentlich hat er ja gar nicht wirklich was verkündet.
Also eigentlich stand er ja auf der Bühne und hat nur zwei Dinge gesagt,
nämlich wir werden Office weiter für den Mac entwickeln.
Ja und sie haben investiert in Apple.
Ja, aber nur in nicht stimmberechtigten Aktien. In Vorzugsaktien, genau.
Aber das sind ja immer noch Aktien.
Klar, aber das war so. Das ist ja auch ein Geld.
Das über den Tisch gegangen ist.
Genau.
97 war das.
War nur so ein Signal.
Ich glaube stimmberechtigte Aktien, da hätte dann auch das Kartellamt.
Ja, natürlich, klar, aber es ging so ein bisschen unter.
Auf jeden Fall, 1995 war so dieser Moment, wo man nicht mehr wusste, okay, wo geht es hin?
Dann kam irgendwie Windows 95 raus, der Windows-Hype ging total durch die Decke
und alle nur so, Apple ist doomed. Und ich weiß noch, dass ich da wirklich….
Apple selber hatte aber auch keine gute Figur gemacht.
Dann hatten die Powerbooks Qualitätsprobleme ohne Ende.
Es war alles scheiße. Es war alles am Ende. Sie haben ihre Betriebssystemstrategie völlig verkackt.
Sie haben es komplett gegen die Wand gefahren, weil einfach Leute da halt so
Sales Joits am Start waren.
Also die hatten ja erstmal diesen, wie hieß er noch gleich hier,
dieser Pepsi-Manager, der Steve Jobs rausgeschmissen hat,
der hat ja schon mal sozusagen den Untergang eingeleitet und als es dann irgendwie
schwierig wurde, dann haben sie den dann irgendwie auch noch rausgekantet,
dann kam dieser Typen, der Diesel,
der war aber zu sehr Ingenieur, der hatte keine wirkliche Produktvision,
das hat irgendwie nicht so richtig funktioniert und man merkte,
dann haben sie diesen Jill Amelio geholt, der sollte das dann irgendwie alles
retten, das war ja auch irgendein Sales-Stroy von irgendeiner anderen Technik-Bude.
Der war vorher bei Motorola gewesen. Ja, nein, nicht ganz.
Also da tut man dem, glaube ich, ein bisschen Unrecht, weil er hatte das iMac-Projekt angestoßen.
Und er hatte halt dann...
Projekt war von Jobs.
Nee, nee, nee. Das hat Jobs zwar immer so gesagt, aber angestoßen hat es ursprünglich Emilio.
Das war noch nicht allzu weit, als sie ihn dann geschasst hatten,
aber angestoßen hatte er das.
Und er hat halt auch dann betriebssystemmäßig gesagt, alles das,
was wir bisher jetzt versucht haben mit Next-Gen-Betriebssystem, hat keinen Sinn.
Wir kaufen jetzt was. Das war seine Entscheidung.
Und das war auch die Entscheidung, die Apple letzten Endes gerettet hat.
Also klar, sie haben halt dann Steve an Bord geholt und so weiter und so weiter.
Da war ja noch dieses BOS im,
in der Sprache, aber von diesem wie hieß er, mit dem französischen Namen,
auch ein Ex-Apple Mensch, egal, also auf jeden Fall, das ist ja dann nichts geworden und also.
IMac ist nicht von Julamelio, da wirst du keine Quelle zu finden,
definitiv nicht das war ja das originäre erste Projekt was Steve Jobs gemacht
hat, Steve Jobs kam in den Laden wieder zurück, hat erstmal alles geaxed, hat alle,
weggemacht und hat dann diese 2x2 Matrix aufgemacht wir brauchen irgendwie einen
Desktop und ein Portable brauchen wir im Consumer-Bereich und im Pro-Bereich
und dann hat er eben mit dem iMac angefangen da das erste Kästchen zu füllen.
Girmilio hat nur diesen 20th anniversary Mac und so ein Kram irgendwie übersehen,
aber das war halt irgendwie alles nichts.
Worauf ich aber eigentlich hinaus wollte, ich wollte jetzt nicht die Geschichte
nacherzählen, ich wollte nur dieses Gefühl schildern, was ich irgendwie in dem
Moment hatte und ich war wirklich deprimiert.
Also ich dachte mir so, was wäre wenn jetzt Apple verschwindet?
Also wenn die jetzt irgendwie nicht mehr da sind.
Dann hätte Microsoft wirklich gewonnen gehabt.
Und es wären nur noch diese PCs da. Das war ein Gefühl, ich kann das gar nicht beschreiben.
Also ich war total angewidert von diesem Gedanken.
Und ich habe ernsthaft überlegt, das dann mit den Computern sein zu lassen. Ich dachte mir so.
Was mit Holz zu machen.
Ja, also das war für mich überhaupt gar kein Erträger. Ich dachte mir so,
es kann nicht sein, dass es irgendwie nicht den Ort gibt, wo einfach die schönen Dinge entstehen.
Und wenn das einfach komplett vom Markt verschwunden wäre, was ja durchaus irgendwie
im Raum stand, so als Angst, ob es dann wirklich so gekommen wäre,
auch ohne diesen Schritt mit Steve Jobs.
Aber ich weiß noch, wie mich das einfach total schockiert hat und ich auf einmal keine Lust mehr hatte.
Also ich dachte mir so, nee, dann mache ich irgendwas anderes.
Weiß ich auch nicht, ob das so gekommen wäre, aber so war zumindest mein Gefühl.
Insofern bin ich da ganz froh, als sie den Steve geholt haben,
weil, ich meine, nicht ohne Grund ist er hier immer im Outro der Freakshow so,
that's what we have for you today, weil ich finde, er hat die Sachen immer gut auf den Punkt gebracht.
Ich habe übrigens noch was ausgegraben in dem Zusammenhang und ich weiß nicht,
ob ihr diese Szene kennt, die gibt das schon mal sehr schön wieder.
Es ist ein etwas längeres Segment, aber es ist durchaus wertvoll nochmal zu
machen und zwar ist das die WWDC nach seiner Rückkehr,
wo er irgendwie alles beendet hat.
Also er hat die Computerlinie beendet, dann halt sein iMac-Projekt intern gestartet,
wo noch alles komplett offen war und wo vor allem so diese Betriebssystemstrategie
dann auch erstmal ausgenudelt werden musste.
Also was machen wir jetzt mit Mac OS und es war ja eh klar, irgendwie mit Next
Step was. Also das war ja der Grund, warum sie Next gekauft haben.
Sie haben ja unter Gil Amelio diese technologische Findungskommission gegründet,
die sagt, okay, was ist denn die Basis für unser nächstes Betriebssystem?
Weil es war ja offensichtlich, dass macOS.
Am Ende war. Da waren sich ja alle einig. Apple hat es ja selber versucht mit
Copland und dann zusammen mit IBM noch mit diesem Pink.
Also zwei Betriebssystemprojekte hatten sie parallel oder hintereinander laufen.
So als das ist jetzt die Zukunft. Ich glaube Copland war das zweite.
Beides hat irgendwie nicht funktioniert. Genau, Telligent haben sie dann noch
gegründet, zusammen mit IBM und so. Also alle möglichen Sachen.
Und um irgendwie mal ein stabiles Betriebssystem mit Memory Protection an den
Start zu kriegen mit richtigem Preemptive Multitasking. Weil das hatten sie halt nicht.
Das hatte Windows nur so begrenzt. Windows 95 war ja auch noch so eine Nudel, aber sie hatten halt NT.
Und NT konnte das alles. Und als ich mir mal NT installiert hatte,
mir das angeschaut hatte, da hatte ich richtig schlechte Laune.
Also das weiß ich noch, da dachte ich mir so, scheiße.
Die haben den Kack hier, der NT-Körnel war halt gut.
Der merkte so richtig, okay, bei Microsoft ist zwar, die haben zwar keinen Geschmack,
aber zumindest haben sie jetzt einen Körnel, der so halbwegs funktioniert und
wir haben einen Scheiß. Das war so mein Gedanke.
Ich habe auf NT4 meine Diplomarbeit geschrieben.
Mit LaTeX, aber es war eine NT4.
Ja genau. Und dann gab es noch OS2. Damit habe ich ja auch viel entwickelt damals.
Aber bei Apple sah es halt einfach scheiße aus.
Und dann hat halt diese Findungskommission gesagt, wir machen das mit Next Step.
Das hat am meisten Überschneidungen. und sicherlich war der Aspekt mit,
dass das Steve Jobs Firma war, auch irgendwo naheliegend.
Also in hindsight passt das natürlich nicht alles zusammen, aber es war halt irgendwie offen.
BOS war auch ein bisschen in der Verlosung. Das war ja auch so dieser Jean-Louis
Gasset, dieser Ex-Apple-Manager, der das gemacht hat. Das war auch ganz interessant, aber das war halt...
Das war zwar super performant und so, aber das war halt nicht ansatzweise so
rich im Application-Framework wie jetzt Next Step.
Und Next Step hat ja wirklich die Antworten geliefert.
War auch ehrlich gesagt zu dem Zeitpunkt auch noch nicht wirklich reif für irgendwas.
Nee, nee, aber es war echt schnell. Also es war wirklich faszinierend schnell.
Vor allen Dingen das einzige Betriebssystem, wo ich das je erlebt habe,
dass Teile eines Programms abstürzen. andere Teile weiterlaufen und irgendwie,
also es war wirklich ein merkwürdiges System.
Aber es war irgendwie geil, aber nicht geil.
Alles lief gleichzeitig, hatte man das Gefühl, bei BOS, aber so richtig.
Und dann haben sie halt Decks gekauft und ich dachte mir so,
Gott sei Dank, ich kann weiter mit Computern arbeiten.
Das war dann so. Und dann kam halt irgendwie, was ich ganz am Anfang gesagt
habe, dann kam einfach Unix und der Mac kam irgendwie zusammen.
Und ich dachte mir nur so, geil.
Ja, dieses Rhapsody, wie das ja dann hieß als Codename erstmal,
wo ich dann die Beta installiert habe, das war ja so geil, die sah ja aus wie Mac OS 9 noch.
Also sie hatte einen farbigen Apfel links oben in der Ecke und so die haben
sie halt schnell die Mac-Menüs draufgeklatscht und alle Next-Programme sahen
aber eigentlich immer noch aus wie Next-Programme und es hatte das alte Next-Doc und so weiter.
Aber es lief relativ zuverlässig.
Naja, da ging es dann halt langsam los. Aber bevor das alles passiert ist,
gab es diese WWDC und die ganze Apple-Community stand halt Steve Jobs gegenüber
und Steve Jobs hat gesagt, das ist alles scheiße und es stinkt und wir schmeißen
das jetzt hier alles weg.
Unter anderem die heilige Kuh damals war OpenDoc. Das war so diese letzte Idee,
die auch nicht in Heilzeit,
Das war so dieses, ja, also es war so ein bisschen diese Frage mit,
wie werden Programme in Zukunft sein?
Und alle redeten immer über Modularisierung und so weiter.
Und OpenDoc war so diese Idee, alles in so Komponenten zu machen.
Apple hat ja sogar einen eigenen Webbrowser damals rausgebracht, erinnerst du dich noch?
Der auf OpenDoc basierte? CyberDoc.
CyberDog, ja.
Ich habe ihn ausprobiert.
Der hat nie so richtig gut funktioniert.
Ich fand den geil, weil der war irgendwie ganz pfiffig. Du hast so eine URL
aufgemacht und du hast nicht gleich so eine ganze Seite gehabt,
sondern der hat halt erstmal einen Fetch gemacht auf die URL und geguckt,
was kommt denn da und nur wenn da kam, jetzt HTML, dann so ah ja,
okay, dann mache ich auch mal das Fenster auf.
Aber wenn das so eine FTP-URL war, dann blieb das halt einfach so ein kleines Fenster.
Und CyberDog war so ein bisschen der Versuch mit zu zeigen, so ja,
hier OpenDog und so weiter, wir machen das jetzt hier alles Modular und Pipapo
und so, aber es war so eine technikverliebte Geschichte, die noch sehr in der alten macOS festhing.
Und der Clip, den ich jetzt mal einspiele, das ist ein paar Minuten,
aber es lohnt sich, ist, Steve Jobs steht alleine auf der Bühne auf dieser WWDC,
und dann haben die etwas gemacht, was man sich fast gar nicht mehr vorstellen könnte. Ein Q&A.
Da konnten Developer an Mikrofonen gehen und Fragen fragen.
Und dann kam halt so ein Typ, der dann einfach mal ganz frech gesagt hat,
so hier, was erlaube Steve?
Kann man mal kurz hier reinhören. Vor allem seine Antwort ist dann einfach sehr insightful, wie immer.
Kürzer Einwurf, also zu dem Zeitpunkt hatten Sie, glaube ich,
auch noch Java auf Ihrer Roadmap mit drauf, weil da alle schrien, ja, Java,
Java, Java und irgendwie dachten Sie, die kriegen das auch schon hin und das
war auch im Betriebssystem mit drin.
Naja, vor allen Dingen war das bei Next, hatten sie so ein Projekt,
wo sie Java bridgen zu Objective-C und Java dann, also in Java man,
quasi Next-Apps bauen können sollte.
Das ist aber dann relativ schnell wieder verschwunden.
Ja, ich glaube, ihr ganzer Web-Store lief irgendwie am Anfang,
der Apple-Store lief am Anfang auf diesem ganzen Java.
Web-Objects war...
Genau, Web-Objects, genau.
Reden wir nicht drüber.
Genau, jetzt kommt Steve Jobs' Antwort.
Ja, und genauso ist es dann auch gekommen.
Tja.
Und was er ja auch nochmal anspringt, dieses vom Ende her Denken.
Und das fehlt mir einfach zu oft.
Wir sehen das jetzt mit diesem AI, wir werden jetzt gleich wahrscheinlich auch
nochmal ganz viel über AI reden, weil wir reden ja immer viel über AI,
es gibt ja auch viel zu erzählen über AI.
Ja, Technology, Technology, Technology und das wird jetzt einfach rausgehauen und so weiter.
Und ich finde es sehr interessant, dass Apple sozusagen die einzige Firma ist,
die gerade nicht wie blöde Geld ausgibt für den ganzen Kram,
sondern einfach nur davon profitiert, wer da am besten überlebt und ja,
mal gucken, was dabei rauskommt.
Ich muss sagen, die Sache mit vom Ende her denken, vom User aus her denken,
ist eigentlich genau das, was in dem VW-Artikel drin stand.
So nach der Art, wir haben jetzt viel Technologie gemacht und jetzt müssen wir
uns mal darauf zurückbesinnen, ein Auto zu bauen, was die Leute auch geil finden.
Und ob es ihnen gelingen wird, steht auf einem anderen Blatt.
Also da kann jeder seine Meinung haben. Aber immerhin ist die Ansage,
wir wollen jetzt Autos bauen, die vor allen Dingen für die Leute geil sind, erstmal richtig.
Also wir haben jetzt parallel dazu ja auch das Video gesehen.
So wie er jetzt auch so was für eine Präsenz er so auf der Bühne hat.
Und das ist halt auch so ein Faktor, der mich bei Apple extrem angeturnt hat.
Das war einfach die Art und Weise, wie Steve Jobs Keynotes gehalten hat.
So, das war einfach ein Selling Point.
Da bin ich 180 Prozent bei dir, das hat niemand anders, egal wer es probiert.
Das gab es nur einmal, das kommt vermutlich nie wieder.
Und nichts und niemand auf der Welt hat mich auch so beeinflusst in der Art
und Weise darüber nachzudenken, so was macht eigentlich eine vernünftige Keynote
aus und wie muss man sowas eigentlich strukturieren.
Und natürlich wird man es nicht so machen, man muss auch seinen eigenen Weg finden.
Aber das mal sehr genau zu studieren, so warum er die Dinge so gemacht hat, wie er die gemacht hat.
Weil es hatte für mich Steve Jobs Keynotes hatten wirklich den Eventcharakter von Weihnachten.
Das war in meinem Leben zu dieser Zeit so wichtig wie Weihnachten.
Absolut, ja.
Das waren die ein, maximal zwei, häufiger waren die damals ja auch nicht.
Events, die hast du dir angeschaut und das war die heilige Messe und es war
vielleicht nicht alles geil, was da passiert ist, aber es gab Momente,
die man im Leben so nirgendwo anders bekommen hat.
Wenn man sich eben dann doch auf eine gewisse Art und Weise für Technologie
und Fortschritt und Zukunft irgendwie begeistern konnte.
Und umso härter, wir haben es sich mal schon angeprangert, so jetzt kriegst
du halt irgendwelche Video-Hochglanz-Produktionen mit lustigen Video-Effekt-Shi-Shi
und so und die ein oder andere lustige
Idee ist verbaut, wenn sie einem im Formel-1-Wagen oben über ihr hauen.
Ja, I get it, ja, aber einfach ein Typ, freiredend auf einer Bühne,
ja, der hatte auch seinen Teleprompter, ja, und dann haben Demos nicht funktioniert
und er hat sich aufgeregt.
Es ist wild, diese Story nachzulesen, wie gefaked das erste iPhone auf der Bühne
war, ja, nichts davon war quasi echt, was er da irgendwie geklickt und gemacht hat,
aber trotzdem, der Mann hatte einfach eine Präsenz in der Art und Weise,
wie er an die Zukunft geglaubt hat und wie er geglaubt hat, dass er gerade das
Richtige tut für sich und seine Firma und die Menschheit. halt so pathetisch das klingt,
dieses Destillat hat es da vor und danach, glaube ich, nie wiedergegeben und das,
zumindest ansatzweise hätte ich sowas gerne wieder...
Ja, wenn man sich Tim Cook anguckt, ich meine, er hat wirklich eine Entwicklung
genommen, aber er ist ja noch nicht Ansatz in der Nähe dessen, was Karma bedeutet.
Ich denke, dass Tim Cook auch nur im Ansatz versucht, das zu sein.
Deswegen müssen wir da gar nicht drüber reden. Ich würde gerne auf etwas anderes
kommen, was wir in den Notizen hatten. Das passt jetzt, glaube ich, ganz gut.
Um vielleicht auch mal diesen Apple-Part ein bisschen abzuschließen,
würde ich am Schluss nochmal so sammeln.
Okay, was sind denn sozusagen eure Apple-Momente,
wenn ihr zurückblickt, eurer Wahl,
die euch jetzt irgendwie als was Besonderes in Erinnerung geblieben sind und
man kann das jetzt vielleicht auch gleich damit verknicken, verquicken,
was sind so die Produkte, die für euch jetzt auch...
Speziell waren, die so ein, weiß ich nicht, irgendwas manifestiert haben oder
besondere Bedeutungen hatten und so.
Also für mich war der allererste Mac.
Als ich an dem saß, das war schon ein ganz besonderer Moment.
So dieses, überhaupt mal eine Maus zu haben. Der Mauszeiger,
der sich auch eigentlich immer bewegt hat.
Egal, was die Maschine sonst so gemacht hat.
Wir reden über eine Zeit, wo halt...
Alles geruckelt und gedauert hat.
Genau, es hat nie geruckelt.
Wo halt auf dem PC hattest du einen blinkenden Garser und Homecomputer,
naja, hatten halt nicht mal eine Maus oder so.
Also das war schon so.
Die Maus bewegt sich auch heute noch anders auf dem Mac als auf anderen Computern.
Ja gut, das ist eine andere Diskussion.
Das bringe ich an einer der nächsten Sendungen.
Aber dass die Maus sich über den Bildschirm bewegt hat und also technisch war
das glaube ich damals echt eine brillante Leistung und dass man so das Gefühl hat,
die Maschine reagiert immer, egal was man tut.
Ja klar, man muss warten, bis das System startet und all diese Dinge,
aber also diese Kleinigkeit, du doppelklickst ein Icon und dann geht so ein
Rahmen auf, du merkst, oh,
jetzt passiert was und dann löscht sich der Bildschirm und klar war es alles
viel langsamer, aber es war irgendwie...
Keine Ahnung. Also das war das erste Mal eine GUI, die halt nicht,
also die einfach funktioniert hat und konsistent war.
Und wenn man sich überlegt, dass schon damals Copy und Paste die gleiche Tastaturbelegung
hat, wie sie jetzt noch ist, das finde ich eines der faszinierendsten Dinge überhaupt.
Auch Command-S als Save oder Command-W, um ein Fenster zu schließen,
gab es damals alles schon. Das hat sich alles nicht geändert.
Das war so einer der Momente. Der zweite Moment war der iPod.
Ich hatte zu dem Zeitpunkt kurz bevor Apple den iPod rausgebracht hat,
war ich schon am hin und her überlegen, ja so ein MP3-Player so einen portablen
aber vielleicht doch mit Festplatte, damit ein bisschen was drauf passt und so,
irgendwie, das war alles nicht Fisch und nicht Fleisch, was es da draußen gab,
es gab halt diese Flash-Teile mit 64 Megabyte Speicher oder was die hatten und dann boom,
kommt Apple mit dem mit dem ipod mit der mit der festplatte drin mit fünf gigabyte
speicher was haben sie damals gesagt 2000 cds oder 1000.
Songs in your pocket.
Irgendwie sowas keine ahnung und dann habe ich dieses teil tatsächlich also
mehr oder weniger direkt auch aus dem laden getragen und der der erste ipod
ich weiß nicht ob ihr euch erinnert der hatte ja firewire,
Ja gut, kann man geteilter Meinung zu sein, aber damals, als FireWire neu war,
war es schon auch magisch, wie viel über dieses Kabel ging.
Sehr, sehr schnell.
400 Megabit.
Und dann habe ich diesen iPod angesteckt und habe iTunes aufgemacht und habe
die gesamte iTunes-Library, die ich damals hatte, auf den iPod kopiert.
Und zwar nicht in zwei Stunden, sondern in zwei Minuten oder so.
Und das war echt auch so alter Schwede. Und dann hatte er ja auch dieses,
nicht dieses Trackpad-mäßige Scrollwheel, sondern ein mechanisches Scrollwheel.
Man hat ein Stück Plastik gedreht und das fühlte sich auch so geil an.
Also das Teil war auch immer ein bisschen langsam und so, aber das war echt
auch ein magischer Moment. Dieser verdammte iPod, kann man sich heute auch nicht
mehr vorstellen, MP3-Player, ey, was ist denn das?
Aber das war schon, das war schon, und dann gab es so diese,
diese geheime Tastenkombination, wo man das Easter Egg freischalten konnte und
dann konnte man Pong spielen, das war ja erst später wurde es ja ein offizielles Spiel.
Am Anfang war das ja nur ein Easter Egg, von dem man wissen musste,
wie man rankommt und so, also das war großartig.
Und danach, danach wird es schon schwierig, würde ich sagen.
Können wir es mal weiter erreichen.
Ja, also das Licht hatte ich ja schon gesagt, macOS zum ersten Mal gesehen,
halt die Aqua-Oberfläche, dann hat
es ja lange gedauert, bis ich dann auch wirklich einen echten Mac hatte.
Die vernünftige Antwort ist halt irgendwie diverse MacBooks und das erste mit Retina und so.
Da gab es einfach immer wieder das erste Unibody. Das war schon alles immer sehr schick.
Aber ich habe ein bisschen überlegt in Vorbereitung, was sind so die Hidden
Champions, die vielleicht immer so ein bisschen hinten runterfallen und die
aber bis heute für mich eigentlich so mit die wichtigsten Geräte,
Alltagsgeräte sind, wo es auch schwierig fände, die zu ersetzen.
Das ist das Apple TV, weil das so in meiner ganzen Medienphilosophie,
gerade auch mit meinen Kindern, einfach eine riesen Rolle spielt in seiner Flexibilität.
Du kannst mal eben von allen Geräten was drauf streamen. Du hast die ganze Medienbibliothek drauf.
Ich habe eine Synology drauf mit irgendwie meinem privaten Video- und Serienarchiv und it just works.
Und ja, es hat nicht genug Liebe und müsste doch und so weiter,
aber ich habe es an meiner High-End-Stereoanlage dran.
Ich habe es an meinem 77 Screen-OLED-Fernseher dran und das Das löst einfach
ein Riesenzoo von Problemen jeden Tag und es funktioniert einfach.
Das Zweite, das habe ich glaube ich auch schon mal erzählt, die ersten AirPods Bluetooth ohne Kabel.
Ich vergleiche das immer gerne, heutzutage kann man sich das ja kaum noch vorstellen,
wie das vorher war, als man immer überall halt nur noch diese Schnüre rumbaumeln hatte.
Aber das war, als man die zum ersten Mal ausprobiert hat, wie nackt schwimmen.
Ja, mit einer Badehose geht schon, aber ach du meine Güte, das ist ja aber mal ganz was anderes.
Das Wasser umströmt einen ganz anders.
Du machst plötzlich, stehst in der Küche, machst den Abwasch und hast nur diese
Teile in der Hand und nichts fusselt ständig dir in den Wasserhahn irgendwie
rein und es hat trotzdem einen geilen Sound und funktioniert und pehrt sich irgendwie vernünftig.
Also die Airpods, ich weiß, wir haben da unterschiedliche Vorlieben,
welche nun genau, aber das war, was heute irgendwie jeder für selbstverständlich
angeht, so lange ist das nochmal gar nicht her.
Ich weiß nicht, wann gab es die ersten kabellosen Airpods vor sieben Jahren oder so? Acht Jahre?
Die ersten.
Ich hatte dann ja auch wirklich die ersten, die noch auch nicht in ihr waren
und meine Güte, habe ich die instantan geliebt. So und die liebe ich auch bis heute noch.
Also das ist auch einfach ein Produkt, was mir sehr fehlen würde.
Wobei ich glaube, dass jetzt irgendwie Sennheiser und Konsorten irgendwie vergleichbar
gute Geschichten wahrscheinlich am Start haben.
Aber da war halt auch wieder Apple so gefühlt so die ersten,
die das irgendwie auf dem Level vernünftig durchgezogen haben.
Und die aber einzig vernünftige Antwort kann nur das iPhone sein und nichts
hat die Welt so transformiert wie dieses olle Ding halt und da halte ich mir nach wie vor,
ich habe das auch schon mal erzählt wir hatten damals ja schon Stud-LP und so
eine Community an der Uni wo dann darüber diskutiert wurde,
und ich habe dann da so irgendwie eine Rezension geschrieben so ab heute ist
die Welt eine andere, deal with it und niemand hat das verstanden und ich dachte
nur, can't you see it Ja, wie irgendwie hier der Lego-Gründer,
könnt ihr nicht sehen, wir können davon weltweit Millionen verkaufen, so,
hört auf mit eurer Kleingeistigkeit, das hat mich fassungslos gemacht,
dass große Teile meiner Umgebung überhaupt nicht kapiert haben,
was da gerade passiert ist.
Und es hat sich dann ja doch irgendwie bewahrheitet und heute machen es alle
und mit zum Guten wie zum Schlechten.
Es hat ja natürlich auch nicht alles nur zum Guten geführt, aber nichts hat
diese Welt so transformiert in den letzten Jahren, wie das so plötzlich...
Das Internet in deiner Hosentasche hast.
Ja, das erste iPhone. Ich hatte ja tatsächlich das Original-iPhone auch.
Ich bin ja auch irgendwie so ein early Adopter, ein unheilbarer early Adopter, glaube ich.
Das war schon auch magisch.
Jetzt mal abgesehen davon, dass nichts funktioniert hat am Anfang.
Das Internet war zu langsam.
Und man das dann erst jailbreakern musste, um dann hinterher das Lock wegzumachen,
das Simlock und diese ganze Scheiße. Aber es war schon magisch.
Und dann, was ich auch nicht vergesse, dass es ja ein Jahr gedauert hat,
bis der App Store dann dafür überhaupt rauskam.
Und selbst die schlauesten Leute in meinem Umfeld damals und mich eingeschlossen,
konnten sich ein Jahr lang nicht vorstellen, dass diese ganzen freien Slots
auf dem Original-iPhone jemals durch irgendwas anderes geführt sein könnten,
als vielleicht noch eine neue Apple-App.
Mir fehlte damals total die Fantasie und ich habe keinen gekannt,
der das vorher gesehen hat damals, sodass die das einfach öffnen würden.
Und dann kam das und ich dachte, scheiße, natürlich, sicher, das ist der Weg.
Warum habe ich das nicht gesehen? Das habe ich überhaupt nicht kommen sehen.
Wie gesagt, ich kenne auch keinen, der es damals vorher gesagt hat.
Also bei mir war es andersrum. Ich fand das total krass, dass dieses Ding so
zu war und dass es keine Möglichkeit gab, dafür Third-Party-Apps zu machen.
Das war für mich unvorstellbar, wie Apple es wagen könnte, sowas zu tun. Okay.
Und deswegen war so, als dann der App Store kam und das SDK und alles so,
boah ey, jetzt haben wir wirklich ein Jahr auf die Scheiße warten müssen.
Gut, jetzt mal abgesehen davon, dass iOS 2.0 so von der Programmierung,
also es war komplette Vollkatastrophe.
Ab drei wurde es dann erträglich, aber das ist ein anderes Thema, ne?
Sie hatten es damals noch quasi schnell zusammengeklimpt, als es dann kam, aber hey.
Ja, okay, also bei euch ist es so Produkte und Momente quasi eins.
Ich würde sagen, ein Apple-Moment, der wirklich enorm war und der auch beides
zusammenbringt, war halt dann die iPhone Keynote.
Also die gelt ja glaube ich sowieso ein bisschen als die Keynote von,
also es gibt ja die Mother of All Keynotes, ist ja nicht von Steve Jobs.
Das ist dir ja schon bewusst. Also als Mother of All Keynotes,
bevor ich jetzt was Falsches sage.
Ist das diese Xerox?
Also the Mother of All Demos, Entschuldigung.
Das ist dieses Xerox-Ding, ne?
Das war nicht Xerox, das war Stanford Research Institute Douglas Engelbart,
der die erste Maus demonstriert hat.
Das ist sozusagen the mother of all Demos.
Also er hat halt so eine 90-minütige Demo gemacht und hat da ein System demonstriert,
das hieß Online-System und wir reden von 1968.
Kennst du das nicht, Ralf?
Nee, das kenne ich nicht. Bin gerade auf der Seite.
Ja, ja, also das ist sozusagen, das ist so der Moment, wo wirklich der ganze
Future Tech irgendwie in einer Demo drin ist.
Also die haben da sich, der Typ, der hat sich also alles ausgedacht und Xerox
Park und so weiter, das war dann alles erst später und viele haben da sozusagen
da sich ihre Ideen hergeholt.
Ah, ich habe das schon mal gehört, aber gibt es das auf YouTube denn?
Ja, ich habe das mal gesehen, ist ein bisschen zäh, die ganze Präsentation.
Es ist 1968, dass das überhaupt als Video existiert, ist schon wirklich bemerkenswert.
Ja.
Und, aber da sind halt einfach so viele Sachen drin, das ist bemerkenswert,
das wollte ich an dieser Stelle nochmal sagen, ne. Und, ähm.
Aber the mother of all Keynotes ist schon die.
The mother of all Keynotes ist dann doch, glaube ich, die iPhone Keynote.
Ich weiß, dass das auch deine Lieblings Keynote ist, Ralf, du hast sie ja tausendmal kopiert.
Also zum Beispiel, dass du halt Spannungsmomente brauchst, wenn du eine Keynote hältst.
Es geht nicht darum, in einer Keynote eine Wahrheit irgendwie zu verkünden oder
Informationen zu vermitteln,
sondern du musst Spannungsmomente haben, wo die Leute mitfiebern und glauben,
etwas zu verstehen und dann fällt der Groschen aber doch auf die ganz andere
Seite und die Leute denken so,
what the fuck, das habe ich nicht kommen sehen. solche Momente.
Alfred Hitchcock, der ja auch, wenn du dich mal umdrehst, hinter dir auf diesem
Think Different Poster, was hier in meinem Studio hängt,
drauf ist und der ja auch in dem Think Different Video und so weiter kurz auftaucht
und sozusagen als einer dieser Geniuses vorgestellt wird, die also immer gewagt
haben, anders zu denken.
Der nennt diesen Effekt Suspense in seinen eigenen Filmen. Dieses,
ja, das Licht im Psycho und so weiter.
Also das ist das sind alles so diese ganzen Sachen, die er immer berücksichtigt
hat, weil er wusste, wie er das aufbauen kann und seine Herleitungen waren halt auch irgendwie gut.
Hier hat er das so ein bisschen auf die Spitze getrieben bei dieser iPhone-Demo,
weil er halt erstmal so ja, wir haben drei neue Produkte für euch und das war
natürlich schon so drei,
dass wir alle so ein bisschen auf die falsche Fährte führen.
Ich habe das gesehen,
Und damit war dann, und ich meine, ich erinnere mich vor allem noch an die Monate
davor, als die Gerüchteküche kam mit, werden sie ein Telefon rausbringen.
Das war ja so im Busch und auch so iPhone war auch tatsächlich so der Name,
der kolportiert wurde, aber alle so, ja, weiß ich nicht, iPhone ist eine Trademark
von Dings gewesen, hier von Cisco damals.
Man hatte ja vorher, gab es ja noch dieses Motorola-Phone,
was irgendwie iTunes Player eingebaut hatte,
wo sich Steve Jobs bei der Vorstellung einen abgebrochen hat,
um das zu benutzen und du hast so richtig während der Keynote noch gemerkt,
wie er innerlich immer mehr gekocht hat.
Und das ist eins der Geräte, die er nicht von der Bühne geworfen hat,
aber es wäre auch, würde gut in den Kanon passen, wie diese Kamera,
die nicht funktionieren wollte und die er dann einfach von der Bühne geworfen hat.
Aber da war alles drin, da war auch Humor drin und we call it iPhone und dann
so, and here it is und weißt du noch was, dann kam dieser iPod mit einer Wehlscheine.
Ach so, mit einer Wehlscheine, ja.
Also er hat einfach die Welt damit geradet, irgendwie mit dieser Kino,
das war einfach, alle waren in der Bann und danach war ein halbes Jahr,
hat die ganze Welt über nichts anderes geredet, also über dieses fucking iPhone.
Oder, also es ging ja überhaupt nicht mehr aus dem Newscycle raus.
Der Hypetrain war full steam.
Also das war einfach die maximale so. Und meine, was ist jetzt seitdem passiert? Das war 2007.
Das haben wir fast 20 Jahre iPhone. Und die,
Das Ding ist halt nicht nur das erfolgreichste Smartphone der Welt,
es ist auch nicht der erfolgreichste Computer der Welt, es ist das erfolgreichste Produkt der Welt.
Es gab noch nie ein Produkt, was in solchen Massen verkauft wurde,
so viel Geld hatte und so viele Nutzer hat.
Aber du zählst jetzt alle anderen iPhones mit?
Ja klar, iPhone im Sinne von diese Produktlinie, die ja durchgehend ist.
Also es gab ja nie irgendeine nennenswerte Disruption jetzt in diesen 19 Jahren.
Es war immer iPhone, nächste Version, wurde besser, wurde besser,
wurde besser und es ist ja auch heute noch im Prinzip dasselbe Gerät wie am Anfang.
Es kann mehr, es ist schneller, pipapo, alles das, aber an sich hat sich ja
in dem Modell nichts geändert und sie haben halt radikal Multitouch eingeführt,
also wieder einmal alle neuen Bedienungskonzepte reingebracht.
Gut, das würde ich sagen, ist schon so der Moment, der am meisten Welle gemacht hat.
Mich persönlich hat natürlich seinen Tod noch sehr viel mehr berührt.
Wenn ich es jetzt mal auf Produkte bringen muss, also aus meiner persönlichen Perspektive,
ich hab da lange drüber nachgedacht, was eigentlich so was ist eigentlich wirklich
mein Apple-Gerät so, was so wirklich aus meinen Cold Dead Hands raus,
friebeln muss und das ist das MacBook Air das MacBook Air finde ich ist ein
fantastisches Gerät, ich hab's geliebt von Anfang an Ich hatte nicht das allererste,
aber ich hatte so glaube ich das dritte Modell,
also nachdem dieser Wedge so richtig schick war und seitdem habe ich keinen anderen Computer,
keinen anderen tragbaren Computer gehabt, außer jetzt iPads und ja, hoffe,
dass ihr auch bald wieder welche machen, die mir gefallen, dann kaufe ich mir noch eins.
Eins habe ich noch vergessen.
Nämlich macOS 10. Da habe ich auch irgendeine Developer Preview irgendwann installiert.
Das hast du vorhin schon erzählt.
Nee, macOS 10 jetzt wirklich, wie es auf Mac lief.
Nicht Rhapsody, sonst was, sondern macOS 10, irgendeine Beta.
Und das Ding lief so gut,
dass Classic-Mac-Apps unter Mac OS X besser liefen, als wenn man das Ding nativ
unter Mac OS Classic gestartet hat.
Bis hin zu dem Punkt, wo irgendwie irgendein anderer Musikplayer,
da gab es noch kein iTunes, das war, du dudelte so vor sich hin,
da habe ich es halt zugeklappt.
Und in dem Moment, wo es zugeklappt war, hörte die Musik auf und ich habe es
wieder aufgeklappt und bevor ich es ganz offen hatte, dudelte die Musik weiter.
Also so schnell ist der von Betrieb auf Sleep und wieder zurückgegangen und
das war komplett magisch irgendwie,
wie viel besser dieses Betriebssystem funktioniert hat und da rede ich jetzt
überhaupt nicht über Design oder ähnliches, sondern einfach wie gut es funktioniert hat.
Wie Fenster hin und her schieben und dieses und jenes und so weiter.
Das war wirklich auch ein echter Moment.
Und da saß ich mit einem Powerbook damals im Zug.
Und es tat plötzlich alles irgendwie gut. Das hat mehr Strom verbraucht.
Also das Mac OS X Beta irgendwas. Aber das war schon echt hart.
Ja und ich finde auch heute, dass macOS 10 immer noch eine super Mischung ist,
weil es hat ja ganz am Anfang schon gesagt, diese Mischung aus Mac und Unix,
auf die sie ja auch nie haben es nie sein gelassen.
Ja, es gab immer diese Angst, nehmen sie uns das Terminal weg.
Genau. Und das Terminal ist nach wie vor da und das Terminal ist auch nach wie vor wichtig.
Und ich fand es auch sehr interessant, als der Mac rauskam, macOS X,
das war ja die Zeit vom Titanium G4 Laptop, da kam dann irgendwie so macOS X raus, glaube ich.
Und es war so, alle Admins, alle Leute, die so vom Status her Computer-Admins
waren, haben sich sofort so eine Kiste gekauft.
Also bevor irgendwie der Mainstream das dann sich mal genauer angeschaut hat,
bevor irgendeine Hype aussetzte, aber was sofort passierte war, Admins.
Geil, Unix-Rechner in Bund.
Das geht jetzt. Und da ist alles da.
Und ich glaube, es waren dann auch die Admins, die dann angefangen haben,
in den Unternehmen mit diesen Kisten rumzulaufen und zu sagen, so hier, geil.
Und dann hat sich das auch in Businesses mehr rumgesprochen.
Und das hat dann schon erheblich dazu beigetragen.
Ich meine, auf wen fragst du denn, wenn du einen Computer kaufst?
Du fragst deinen Super-Nerd.
Und was heißt der Super-Nerd vom Beruf? Admin.
Und das war, glaube ich, schon ganz entscheidend.
Aber es gibt noch ein weiteres Produkt, was ich erwähnen möchte,
was für mich auch, glaube ich, fast das Wichtigste ist.
Das ist wieder nicht das iPhone, auch wenn das wichtig ist.
Du hast schon AirPods erwähnt. Ich würde spezifischer werden. AirPods Pro.
Die AirPods Pro, das ist wirklich der ich habe die Dinger mir gekauft kurz bevor
ich irgendwie in den längeren Flug gestiegen bin und diese Noise-Cancellation
und auf einmal war alles anders.
Also das, diese Dinger, die halten einen irgendwie an den Maschinen dran.
Ich bin ja auch so ein Gerätewechsler. Ich sitze immer an mehreren Macs,
also mein Laptop und was auch immer mein Desktop ist und dann noch ein iPad
und das iPhone und wechsle da auch flüssig mit, wo ich jetzt gerade mal mir,
wo ich Ich telefoniere oder irgendein Video konsumiere oder was auch immer oder Musik höre.
Und naja, das funktioniert zwar nicht immer so, wie man sich das so vorstellt,
aber man kann schon relativ seamless so hin und her schalten.
Ich stoppe irgendwas auf meinem iPhone, was gerade läuft. Ich habe die Stöpsel
drin. Ich starte irgendwas auf meinem Mac und ich höre das.
Also dieses Hand-off-System.
Feature ist, glaube ich, sowieso das am wenigsten beachtete und trotzdem geilste
Integrationsfeature, was die Plattform überhaupt hat.
Ich hatte es, glaube ich, letztes Mal schon angesprochen, Copy und Paste oder
was weiß ich hier, auch diese Universal Control. Ich hüpfe hier einfach mit meiner Maus.
Ich habe den Laptop vorne in meiner Nase. Ich schiebe die Maus nach rechts.
Ich bin auf meinem Bildschirm von dem anderen Macintosh. Hätte ich jetzt hier
noch ein iPad daneben stehen, könnte ich nach links gehen mit der Maus.
Ich wäre da. Ich kann eine Datei nehmen und auf diese Art und Weise auf den
anderen Rechner rüberdragen und hinkopieren. Völlig irre.
Und diese ganze Übernahme von Audio und Kontext oder Telefonanrufe,
die ich irgendwie auf dem Macintosh beginne und dann nehme ich mir das iPhone
und dann wird es darüber übergeben.
Und das ist genau dieses Wunder dieser Vollintegration, dass eigentlich dieser
gesamte Gerätepark wie eins wirkt.
Und das finde ich am faszinierendsten. Und das kriegst du mit deinem scheiß Android.
Auch nur nicht im Ansatz, kriegst du das nicht auf der Kette.
Das ist einfach nicht existent, dieser Bereich.
Die AirPods Pro würden bei mir auch noch einen Honorable Mention bekommen,
vor allen Dingen, weil ich sie zunehmend immer mehr als Gehörschutz benutze.
Also dieser Transparency Mode, der ist halt nicht nur, also so im normalen Leben
ist, man hört ihn ja fast nicht, Transparency Mode, aber bei sehr viel Lärm.
Reduziert es immer noch die Lautstärke. Ich benutze es inzwischen bei Konzerten,
weil man da einen geilen Sound hat.
Ich benutze es im Probenraum, weil man da einen geilen Sound hat.
Und trotzdem ist es relativ leise. Es gibt keine Ohrpröppen,
die einen ähnlich guten Sound machen.
Ich habe ja nicht die,
mit dem wirklich abdichten, sondern nur die, die die quasi halt das Gegensignal, Gegenphase ist.
Das ist ja, glaube ich, irgendwie reinspielen. Und dadurch habe ich dann mal
ein neues Cancelling, wohingegen ihr bei dem Pro ja auch noch wirklich dieses
Silikon drumherum habt.
Ja, aber er macht trotzdem neues Cancelling.
Er macht noch zusätzlich genau auch dieses adaptive Noise Cancelling.
Aber ist das vom Frequenzverlauf her denn dann wirklich so linear,
wo du gerade sagst, es klingt einfach gut, dass das in einem Konzert sich dann
auch wirklich irgendwie mit rums?
Deswegen sage ich Transparenz.
Ja.
Weil nämlich der Transparenzmodus hat eine quasi lautstärke Begrenzung,
sodass du Dinge zwar laut hörst, aber es ist nicht so, dass die Ohren schon
in die mechanische Sättigung gehen,
es alles fürchterlich verzerrt, es wehtut, sondern du hast ein klares Klangbild.
Es ist laut, aber du hast ein klares Klangbild und kannst wirklich gut hören. Das ist der Punkt.
Wenn du Noise-Canceling anmachst, dann hast du das so, dass ...
Dass vor allen Dingen viele Bässe rausgefiltert werden, die Höhen durch den
Plopp, den Stöpsel sowieso weg sind und er dann manchmal versucht,
noch Stimmen zu erkennen und die so reinzumischen.
Beziehungsweise, wenn du selber was sagst, dann schaltet er ja auch mitunter
das Noise Cancelling aus, was ein bisschen doof ist, wenn man in einem Konzert
ist und mitsingt und plötzlich… Ja.
Ich sehe den Punkt.
Also das ist so, oder sich mit irgendjemandem unterhalten will oder so.
Aber nee, der Transparenzmodus, der ist wirklich geil.
Und was ich mir wünsche, das habe ich ja auch schon vor Sendungen schon gesagt,
ist, wenn man das justieren könnte, wie laut ist der Transparenzmodus tatsächlich,
wie stark ist das Noise Cancelling tatsächlich.
Das fände ich super, aber Gott, bleibt jetzt bis auf weiteres erstmal ein Wunsch.
Gut ich denke dann können wir den Apple-Huldigungsteil auch mal abschließen,
und vielleicht noch ein paar andere Sachen hier mal auf den Tisch bekommen,
ich wollte, das passt jetzt auch eigentlich ganz gut zu dieser ganzen Diskussion
der Modernität der Betriebssysteme,
und hab mir so einen Artikel durchgelesen und war dann selber doch erstaunt,
dass ich das so einfach noch gar nicht auf der Kette hatte mit den Apple Exclaves.
Habt ihr davon schon mal gehört?
Ich habe davon noch nicht gehört.
Die Enclave war mir bekannt, aber nicht die Xclave.
Genau. Und zwar hat das ja alles was mit Speichermanagement und mit Security zu tun.
Also wir hatten ja jetzt auch schon erwähnt, damals das gute alte macOS,
da teilen sich die Apps halt alle den Speicher.
Ja, wenn dann irgendeine App irgendwo was hinschreibt, dann haut sie halt den
anderen irgendwie die Füße weg oder sich auch selber oder gleich dem ganzen Betriebssystem.
Und sie teilen sich auch den Prozessor. Wer den Prozessor nicht abgibt.
Der lässt das ganze System hängen.
Aber es geht jetzt erstmal nicht so sehr um das Scheduling, das sei jetzt mal
außen vor, sondern es geht generell einfach um Security. Wo kommt Sicherheit einfach her?
Und ganz am Anfang und eben noch so bis Mitte der 90er Jahre war das jetzt mal
mit der Ausnahme von Unix, was das ja von Anfang an eigentlich richtig gemacht hat.
Naja, nicht von ganz Anfang an.
Aber ja. Also ich bin auch ein bisschen am Grübeln, also in den 60er Jahren, ich weiß nicht,
also da hatten ja Computer auch noch keine MMUs, also eine MMU ist eine Memory
Management Unit, das ist so eine spezielle CPU, die halt den Zugriff auf den
Speicher verwaltet und damit quasi illegalen Zugriff feststellen kann.
Also wenn Code gerade läuft und das System befindet sich eben nicht in einem
privilegierten Bereich,
dann kann man eben nur auf bestimmten Speicher zugreifen und da gab es dann
so verschiedenste Instrumente, wie das gemacht wurde.
Bei den früheren Prozessoren gab es dann sowas wie Segmentation,
dass man nur so bestimmte Blöcke zugreifen konnte.
Bei dem 80286 war das zum Beispiel noch so.
Xenix hat so gearbeitet und so weiter.
Das war aber eine Hardware-Limitation. Also eine MMU hatte ja erst die 386er.
Ja.
Da gab es dann eine Gruppe in der CPU, die hieß so MMU.
Aber im Prinzip hattest du halt schon eine Zuordnung von Code zu Speicher.
Gab es in gewisser Hinsicht auch. Funktionierte nur ein bisschen anders.
Translation Layer, vor allen Dingen war das für, also wenn bei der MMU ist die
Translation ja so, von der eigentlichen Hardware-Adresse zu dem,
was dein Programm sieht,
ist ja eine komplette, es ist ein komplettes Umrechnen der Adressen.
Genau, das sind virtuelle Adressen.
Und wo nichts gemappt ist, da kannst du nicht zugreifen.
Genau, also virtuelle Adressierung, das kam dann eben mit diesen MMUs und Page-Tables,
also man hatte so Memory-Pages,
die dann quasi gesagt haben, was jetzt die Zuordnung ist von deinem virtuellen
Adressraum, von dem das Programm annimmt, dass es auf es zugreifen kann,
zu den tatsächlichen physikalischen Adressen, um überhaupt erstmal Speicher auseinanderzuhalten.
Das war so die im Wesentlichen, die Neuerung, die bei PCs dann zumindest,
bei den größeren Maschinen früher gab es das schon immer,
aber bei den PCs kam es dann halt in den 90er Jahren, ab dem 3.86er im Prinzip
dann auch noch mit dazu und die Betriebssysteme haben halt auch immer schon
unterschieden zwischen einem Kernel und einem Usermodus.
Also die neueren Betriebssysteme, also sagen wir jetzt mal Unix,
beziehungsweise Windows NT hat es dann eben auch gehabt.
Man hat halt Unterschieden zwischen, jetzt ist das Betriebssystem dran,
das darf auf alles zugreifen und jetzt ist hier nur ein Programm dran,
das läuft im User-Modus und das darf halt nur auf die Adressen,
die ihm zugeteilt sind, zugreifen und wenn es darüber hinaus irgendwo zugreifen möchte,
dann macht es knallbumm und dann ist das Ding abgestürzt, also das Programm.
Und wenn der Körnel scheiße gebaut hat, dann hat der ganze Körnel abgestürzt.
Und ja, Apple hat ja dann...
Mit Darwin, also mit der Basis von dem macOS 10, also das heißt Darwin als Open
Source Projekt und basiert auf dem Mach Projekt.
Also Mach war quasi der ursprüngliche und ist auch heute noch der Kernel von macOS 10.
Mikrokörnel.
Genau, ein sogenannter Mikrokörnel, der schon mal versucht hat,
auch innerhalb des Körnels so ein bisschen aufzuräumen und so ein bisschen mehr dafür zu sorgen,
dass besser geordnet ist, wer darf denn jetzt hier eigentlich auf was zugreifen.
Das ist dann auf der Hardware-Ebene nicht unbedingt immer unterstützt,
aber man hat zumindest so softwaremäßig schon mal was gemacht.
Aber dieser Bedarf für besonders geschützte Bereiche, der ist halt in zunehmendem Maße gestiegen.
Und mit dem iPhone, also als Apple dann seine eigenen Prozessoren gemacht hat,
mit dem A7 Prozessor auf dem iPhone 5S gab es dann das erste Mal die sogenannte Secure Enclave.
Und diese Secure Enclave war quasi ein separater Processingraum innerhalb der CPU selber.
In dem nochmal ein eigenes kleines Mini-Betriebssystem läuft mit einem eigenen
Adressbereich und diese Enclave kann mit der gesamten CPU nur über so ein definiertes
API miteinander kommunizieren.
Also es gibt dann so einen Kommunikationskanal zwischen dieser sicheren Enklave
innerhalb des Prozessors und der eigentlichen CPU und da lief wohl ein Betriebssystem
und läuft wahrscheinlich auch heute noch ein Betriebssystem drauf,
was irgendwie ZappOS heißt und auf diesem L4 Microkernel basiert.
Das ist schon ein Produkt, also so ein Projekt, was aus Deutschland kommt, soweit ich weiß.
L4-Körnel, das sind so wahre, echte Micro-Körnel,
die quasi so ein absolutes Minimum definieren, aber vor allem erstmal Schutz
bieten und die für so super secure OS-e immer hergenommen werden.
Also nicht überall, aber so nahezu überall, wenn du mal genauer reinschaust,
was die dann nehmen für so Super-Secure-Systeme, dann basiert das in der Regel
auf so einem L4 oder L4-Derivatsystem.
Das heißt, dieser Enclave war so ein eigener Core und hat halt mit dem Rest
der CPU kommuniziert über so enkriptete Wege.
Man kann also da quasi auch nur mit einer entsprechenden Berechtigung sprechen
und wenn man die halt nicht hat, dann kommt man da halt auch nicht rein.
Und das hat das iPhone dann eben benutzt, um...
Touch-ID zu machen, um irgendwie den Fingerabdruck abzuspeichern,
damit der quasi nicht Teil des Betriebssystem-Images ist. Also er ist nicht im RAM.
Man kann ihn nicht auslesen.
Das ist der Punkt. Genau, man kann ihn nicht auslesen. Das Einzige,
was man machen kann, ist, du kannst einen anderen hingeben, den du gerade gelesen
hast, also den du gerade auf dem Sensor gelesen hast.
Kannst du dieser Enklave sagen, hör mal, entspricht das dem,
was ich irgendwann mal in dich reingespeichert habe.
Dann sagt der und dann hast du ein Unlocked Phone.
Vier Jahre später kam dann das iPhone 8 und dieses iPhone X gleichzeitig raus.
Da gab es dann schon so eine weitere Steigerung. Das hieß irgendwie Page Protection Layer.
Keine Ahnung, kann ich nicht viel zu sagen. Und mit dem iPhone 13 haben sie
das dann nochmal weiterentwickelt mit einem sogenannten Secure Page Table Monitor.
Und das sind alles so Versuche, weitere geschützte Bereiche zu implementieren.
Es gibt da im Rahmen dieser ARM-Prozessoren eine Technologie,
die heißt Trust Zone, die halt so Secure Insecure Worlds auseinanderhält und
das ist vermutlich darauf basiert.
Und seit 2024 gibt es aber jetzt etwas, das nennt sich XNU-Xclaves.
Also wir hatten die Enclave und jetzt gibt es auch noch die Xclaves.
Und die Xclaves sind in diesen moderneren Prozessoren drin, also alles ab dem
M4 und dem A18-Prozessor.
Also der A18 ist ja der, der im Neo jetzt ist und in dem iPhone 16 drin war.
Und zeitgleich kam ja M4 auch raus, also quasi die Generation letzten Jahres.
Seitdem gibt es eben diese Technologie der Exclaves. Und es gibt ja ein Detail
bei diesem Neo, nämlich dass der nicht mehr neben der Kamera so eine Lampe hat,
die sagt, wann diese Kamera an ist.
Das haben ja alle Macbooks und sie haben auf Hardware-Ebene sichergestellt,
dass wenn die Kamera eingeschaltet wird, dass immer diese Lampe angeht.
Und beim Neo haben sie sich aber diese Lampe gespart, weil Sparen.
Und dann haben alle schon gesagt, ist denn das noch sicher?
Stellt sich raus, dass sie ja trotzdem
so ein Pixel anmachen auf dem Bildschirm, wenn diese Lampe an ist.
Und die Kontrolle über diesen Pixel, der liegt in einer sogenannten X-Clave.
Und das ist quasi ein parallel laufendes Mini-Betriebssystem,
was in dieser Exklave läuft, wo auch wieder so ein L4-Körnel drin ist,
also ein SE-L4, Secure-L4-Betriebssystem.
Und das ermöglicht so einen exklusiven Zugriff auf diesen Pixel,
an den das normale Betriebssystem nicht rankommt.
Und über diese Methode implementieren sie das jetzt.
Technisch alles sehr kompliziert und aufwendig und da muss man sich nochmal
so ein bisschen tiefer reinlesen,
aber tatsächlich haben wir es jetzt mit mehreren Betriebssystemen gleichzeitig
zu tun, die einerseits in dieser Enclave und bei den neueren Modellen jetzt
auch in einer X-Clave laufen und ja,
das ist alles technisch ganz interessant.
Das wollte ich mal hier so wiedergeben, auch wenn ich jetzt gerade ein bisschen
blänke in meiner Erinnerung,
wo diese Exclave jetzt genau implementiert ist.
Ist auf jeden Fall krasserer Scheiß.
Das ist ja absurd.
Genau. Also da ist halt noch mein eigener Kernel, der da läuft und du kannst dann halt in dieses,
Secure World rein callen und über definierte Memory Buffer da eine Kommunikation machen.
Ja.
Das ist alles ganz aufwendiger technischer Kram.
Anyway, kleine Fußnote zu dem Thema noch.
Du hattest vorhin beschrieben, Kernel Land, User Land, was so ein klassischer,
Teil von so einem alten Kernel ist.
Windows NT 3.5 glaube ich war das, hatte Grafiktreiber noch im User Land.
Und war dadurch relativ stabil, auch bei beschissenen Treibern.
Und bei Windows NT4 haben sie dann die Treiber ins Kernelspace gezogen, die Grafiktreiber,
weswegen das eine Weile lang sehr instabil war und auch letzten Endes dann auch
dazu geführt hat, dass Windows Vista war das, glaube ich,
und Windows XP ja auch so eine Katastrophe an Security war.
Also gerade Windows XP war ja so eine Security-Katastrophe.
Und ich glaube, sie haben es dann wieder rausgemoved, beziehungsweise sich da
ein anderes Modell überlegt.
Aber das war, also da muss man immer aufpassen.
Was darf mit wem sprechen?
All right. So.
Jetzt können wir noch über AI sprechen.
Wir können ja auch einfach mal eine Sendung ohne AI versuchen. Wie wäre denn das?
Schwierig.
Ah, stimmt natürlich.
Also ich habe ja noch zwei Sachen, weißt du.
Ja, was war ja da?
Jenseits der AI, meinst du?
Release Party und was zur Republika.
Ja. Dann hau das doch erstmal weg. Ich habe ja jetzt schon so viel geredet.
Dann hau ich mal was weg. Ich hab mal wieder was gebaut.
Aha. Auf dein Zimmer.
Ich konnte es mal wieder nicht lassen. Und zwar habe ich Mit AI. Ja.
Seid doch geweibt.
Aber ich hab's vom User her gedacht.
Und hab nicht versucht die Technologie vorzuschieben, sondern ein reales Problem zu lösen.
Also ich bin ja irgendwie so in diesem Management-
Viechern irgendwie unterwegs. Wisst ihr denn, was ein Gant-Diagramm ist?
Ja, weiß ich.
So ein Zeitplan-Ding mit so Linien und Balken und Milestones und so.
Genau, wo so Start- und Endezeiten drin sind.
Ich könnte jetzt nicht sagen, wofür Gant steht, aber ja.
Ja, das kriege ich auch immer nicht zusammen, was G-A-N-T-T ist, genau.
Genau, ich habe jetzt mal.
Also ich habe mal so mit Omniplan gearbeitet auf dem Mac, das macht sowas ja
auch und Und ich habe es aber dann, glaube ich, nie wirklich benutzt.
Genau, ich habe jetzt mal so einen Screenshot von Microsoft Project,
was da so ein klassisches Break-Management-Tool ist, hier reingeworfen.
Und da sehen wir jetzt, also ihr hört und wir versuchen es zu beschreiben,
so einen klassischen Gantt-Chart.
Das heißt, man hat Aufgaben, einzelne Arbeitspakete und Milestones,
die man im Prinzip ähnlich wie in einer Excel-Tabelle unzulander wegschreibt.
Und die haben ein Startdatum und die haben ein Enddatum. Und dann hat man rechts
daneben einen Bereich, in dem diese Zeiträume und diese Einzeltasks so als Balken
dargestellt sind und meistens entsteht im Großen und Ganzen eine nach unten weisende Treppe,
weil Dinge hängen voneinander ab.
Wir können diesen Task erst starten, wenn jeder fertig ist und dann kann man
die noch in verschiedene Cluster meistens zusammenbringen. was weiß ich,
für irgendwie erstmal Erprobungsphase und Rolloutphase und was auch immer.
Und das Problem mit diesen Gun-Charts ist, keiner mag die so richtig.
Es ist erstmal pain in the ass, die irgendwie erstmal alle rein zu modellieren für so ein Projekt.
Und dann hat man die und innerhalb von einer Woche läuft man sowieso aus allen
Zeiträumen raus und dann muss irgendeine arme Sau die ständig irgendwie anpassen
und irgendwie neu strukturieren.
Und von der Optik her, wenn man sich das so anschaut, kommen die immer so ein
bisschen freudlos irgendwie daher.
Und auf der anderen Seite visualisieren
sie aber eben schon eine gewisse Komplexitätsebene in so einem Projekt.
An der ZLB haben wir uns jetzt ja aufgemacht, so Richtung digitale Souveränität. Willst du was sagen?
Weißt du, warum es Gantt-Chart heißt?
Ja, du wirst es uns jetzt sagen.
Du weißt es nicht.
Ich wusste es mal und habe es vergessen.
Es ist nach Henry Gantt benannt.
Okay, gut. Nein, dann habe ich es nicht gewusst. Echt? Ich dachte,
das ist ein Akronym für Jürgen.
Ich dachte auch.
Wäre auch meine Erwartung gewesen.
In welchem Jahr steht da irgendwas, von wann das ist?
Er ist 1916 geboren und er hat wohl ganz viel so Projekt.
1910 hat er das ganz schade erfunden.
Na schau, okay.
Also noch sehr analog.
Es sei ihm gegönnt. So, was wir jetzt an der ZLB gerade machen,
ist, dass wir uns doch einigermaßen ernsthaft in Richtung digitaler Souveränität auf den Weg machen.
Das heißt also, wir wollen von Microsoft weg und hin zu Open Source Varianten
und das in ganz unterschiedlichen Bereichen.
Und da stand ich jetzt halt als einer, der da so mit den Hut auf hat,
halt so vor der Frage, okay, wie visualisiere ich das jetzt irgendwie so eigentlich
meinen ganzen Leuten und auch irgendwie den ganzen Normalsterblichen bei uns?
So was, welche Schritte folgen worauf?
Dann habe ich mich gefragt, so gibt es nicht irgendwas, was so die Grundlogik
von Gantt aufgreift, aber irgendwie so ein bisschen netter daherkommt,
was die Leute irgendwie so mögen und interessant finden?
Und dann bin ich auf den Trichter gekommen, U-Bahn-Pläne.
Menschen mögen U-Bahn-Pläne. Die sind schön.
Kenne ich auch andere Meinungen.
Also lass mich erst mal meinen Case machen. Die sind erst mal schön bunt.
Also Leute verstehen U-Bahn-Pläne.
Sie kennen es. Sie haben sich schon mal dazu verhalten.
So ist man denn in einer Stadt wohnt, die eine U-Bahn oder Tram hat.
Das ist ja auch nicht in jeder Stadt gegeben.
Aber es ist irgendwie eine Art von Informationsvermittlung, mit der die Leute
erstmal einen Erfahrungswert haben und es hat so Linien und die haben Stationen
und die haben auch noch Namen,
nämlich irgendwie wie die Stationen halt heißen und gibt es nicht irgendein
Framework, womit ich quasi eine,
Projektvisualisierung machen kann in Form von so einem U-Bahn-Plan.
Und dann habe ich so rumrecherchiert und irgendwie so richtig gibt es da aber nichts.
Es gibt so ein, zwei Frameworks, wo man selber dann so U-Bahn-Pläne zeichnen
kann, Aber das hat mich alles irgendwie überhaupt gar nicht glücklich gemacht.
In dem Zuge bin ich mal über SAP gestolpert. Mach mal den Chat wieder auf und
da das klassische über SAP.
Genau, die haben vor, ich glaube vier Jahren, ist noch gar nicht so lange her,
haben die mal angefangen, so verschiedene ihrer Geschäftsbereiche in so einem
U-Bahn-Plan-Logik zu mappen.
Oh Gott, oh Gott.
Mit acht verschiedenen Linien.
Also wir blicken auf ein SAP Business One Process Metro Map mit verschiedenen
Farblinien, die sozusagen aufteilen die einzelnen Sachen.
So wie Finance, Production, Purchasing, CRM und SRM. Ich weiß nicht, was SRM ist.
Inventory, also CRM ist Customer Relationship Management und SRM ist wahrscheinlich
Service Relationship Seller, keine Ahnung Inventory, Reporting, Sales und Service, ja.
Also dieser Plan hat so dermaßen London-Vibes, dass ich irgendwie schon den
Geruch von der London-Metro und das Gequitsche und Mind the Gap im Ohr habe.
Also das ist echt schlimm, das Ding.
Ja, also ich fühle es. Also als ich das gesehen habe, dachte ich so,
ja, ich sehe, was ihr vorhabt, aber ihr habt jetzt hier acht verschiedene Linien,
alle gleichzeitig, alle übereinander.
Und das, was hauptsächlich eigentlich transportiert ist, da ist irgendetwas,
das ist wahnsinnig kompliziert und wir haben uns Mühe gegeben,
dass es ein bisschen bunt und knubbelig ist, aber schau da besser nicht so lange
drauf, du wirst nur verwirrt.
Das ist so ein bisschen, finde ich, die Grundbotschaft, die hier dieses SAP.
Vor allen Dingen, warum sind manche Linien gestrichelt?
Naja, es wird Grund nachher.
Welche gepunktet und es ist irgendwie, es ist überhaupt kein U-Bahn-Plan.
Also in der Stadt möchte ich nicht U-Bahn fahren.
Vor allem hat das Ganze ja noch eine Business-Flow-Direction,
die von links nach rechts geht.
Richtig.
Und das heißt, alles beginnt irgendwie links. Das heißt, die U-Bahnen fahren
alle nur in eine Richtung und nie wieder zurück. und nach der ganzen Logik ist
das Letzte, was dann stattfindet, das ist Financial Reporting.
So, wir müssen auf jeden Fall einmal kurz gucken.
Dass es in der Business-Sicht gibt. Diese Map gibt mir gar nichts, Ralf.
Das sieht irgendwie hübsch aus, aber ich weiß nicht genau,
wer da eigentlich, okay, also man kann so verstehen, in welcher Reihenfolge
sollen Dinge passieren und was hat auf was Einfluss, aber dieser Einfluss,
da ist ja nicht wirklich eine Zeitabhängigkeit mit drin, wie in diesem Gunshot.
Ich glaube, was dieses Diagramm dir eigentlich zeigen soll, Business ist unglaublich
komplex und bunt und die Einzigen, die das können und im Griff haben, ist SAP.
Das ist das, was dir dieses Ding zeigen soll.
Also da bin ich ganz bei euch, das war es also auch nicht.
Nee, okay, aber nice try.
Aber wenn ihr euch jetzt mal zurückversetzt, wo ihr zum letzten Mal so U-Bahn
oder Tram gefahren seid und dann euer Blick mal Richtung Decke einer solchen
Tram gewandert ist, was findet sich dort?
Decke, was, der Station oder der Bahn?
So über den Fenstern innerhalb von einer U-Bahn in Berlin.
Über den Fenstern, Werbung?
Nein, ich glaube auch in fast jeder anderen Metro der Welt.
Ach so, man hat die einzelne Linie nochmals ein Strich.
Ein Nothalt.
Mit allen Stationen und den Bezeichnungen und so weiter.
Man hat den sogenannten Linienverlaufsplan. Das ist das Fachwort,
zumindest der BVG dafür.
Das ist dann nämlich nur noch die Linie, in der du gerade sitzt, mit ihren Stationen.
Plus kreuzende Linien oben drüber und unten drunter, wo du also sinnvoll umsteigen
kannst mit den Umsteige.
Wieso gibt es für Linienverlaufsplan keinen Eintrag in der Wikipedia?
Tja, das darfst du mich nicht fragen.
Wir müssen unsere Community auffordern, das mal zu ändern.
Und in Berlin, wenn du da U-Bahn fährst, dann hast du halt alle Linien,
auf der dieser Wagen fahren könnte als Linienverlaufsplan und du musst wissen,
welchen du angucken musst.
Ja genau, das hat wieder so Tücken, aber im Großen und Ganzen dachte ich so,
okay, die Richtung, das wäre es doch vielleicht.
Naja, und dann habe ich halt geguckt, sowas gibt es nicht und wisst ihr,
ich bin keiner, der sowas dann hinnimmt und dann habe ich mich halt mal dran
gesetzt und jetzt können wir also hier mal den großen App-Reveal machen und
schiebe das doch mal auf den Screen.
Ich habe es jetzt auch in die Timeline reingebracht.
Am besten klappst du erstmal ein paar Sachen zusammen. Du kannst die einzelnen
Zonen nämlich einklappen.
Klick mal unten auf Social Media. Ja, ist egal.
Lass mal oben den Messenger vielleicht mal auf und die anderen machst du mal zu.
Also wir schauen auf eine Digital Independence Roadmap 2026,
also totaler Masterplan zur Weltübernahme.
Wir blicken auf einen farbig markierten Zeitverlauf mit vier Kategorien, Messenger,
Karten, Büro und System und Social Media.
Das sind jetzt vier Zonen, so nenne ich die. Das ist also so wie die Zonen in
einem U-Bahnplan. Da hast du ja auch eine Zone A, B, C.
So und wenn du jetzt also eine dieser Zonen mal aufklickst, dann siehst du,
eine Zone kann eine oder mehrere Linien enthalten.
Und diese Linien stehen jetzt eben in diesem Beispiel, das ist jetzt mehr oder
weniger sind das Dummy-Daten, die jetzt hier angezeigt werden,
stehen jetzt mal für Technologielinien.
Das heißt also wir haben jetzt die Zone Messenger aufgeklappt und das ist quasi
jetzt eine Visualisierung eines Digital Independence Day Plans.
Wie komme ich jetzt also bei meinem Messenger von WhatsApp weg und hin zu Signal.
Und diese Linien zeigen jetzt mit ihren Stationen, was man also wann gedenkt
zu tun, um diese Migration eben durchzuziehen.
Das heißt also, wir haben dann oben die WhatsApp-Linie, wie bei einer U-Bahn.
Wir haben unten drunter die Signal-Linie.
Wir haben den Status Quo, der beginnt halt mit WhatsApp und ich habe noch gar kein Signal.
Und dann ist also die nächste, die erste Station auf der Signal-Linie ist so,
ich muss es mir erstmal installieren und dann habe ich eine Zeit,
wo ich meine ganzen Kontakte darüber haben muss.
Dann haben wir, und das hat mir halt bei dieser U-Bahn-Metaphorik auch gut gefallen, Umstiegspunkte,
Wo also man eben dann gut von einer Linie auf die nächste rübersteigen kann.
Das ist dann diese verbundene Linie da an der Stelle.
Und von da ab ist dann oben die WhatsApp-Linie nur noch für den Kita-Chat da.
Die ist dann ausgegraut etwas und hat nicht mehr dieselbe Intensität.
Endgegner Kita-Chat.
Endgegner Kita-Chat, genau. Und unten drunter, die Signal-Linie ist dann demgegenüber
dann plötzlich dichter.
So, und jetzt kannst du also auch mal über die einzelnen Stationen drüber havern, so mit der Maus.
Dann siehst du, dass sich da noch weitere Informationen zu öffnen.
Dann kannst du also nämlich.
Du hast geklickt.
Geh mal oben auf den Edit-Button wieder zu, weil das kommt als nächstes, genau.
So, dann siehst du also Informationen zu der Station, wie lange es quasi dauert,
bis die nächste Station erreicht wird auf dieser Roadmap.
Also das sind so Meilensteine oder einzelne Aktionen.
Die können auch unterschiedliche Parameter bekommen, müssen wir jetzt auch nicht
super im Detail uns anschauen.
So und jetzt kannst du mal das nächste aufklappen, Karten beispielsweise,
wo man dann also von Big Tech Karten hin zu Open Street Map migriert,
nach derselben Logik und bei Büro und System migriert man dann wieder irgendwie von was anderem.
Weg von Apple Maps, aber da gibt es jetzt demnächst Werbung.
Ja super Tim.
Die verpasst du ja dann.
Hurra. So und der Clou ist, das Ganze ist halt komplett programmatisch.
Das heißt also, wenn du jetzt oben mal auf den Edit-Button klickst.
Dann öffnet sich links ein Edit-Bereich, in dem du all das, ich hoffe,
einigermaßen menschenfreundlich eingeben kannst.
Das heißt also, dort definierst du deine ganzen Zonen und ein bisschen runterscrollst.
Das sind also erstmal die Hauptmetadaten, von wann bis wann geht der Zeitstrahl
und was steht irgendwie oben drüber.
Dann kommen als nächstes Events, das sind dann Deadlines oder Termine,
wo irgendwo was passiert.
Hat man ja auch immer dann so als Querstriche drin, dann unten drunter definierst
du als nächstes deine verschiedenen Zonen und dann innerhalb der Zonen hast
du dann die unterschiedlichen Linien, die kannst du dann auch aufklappen,
wie du es jetzt auch schon gemacht hast und siehst dann die einzelnen Stationen,
denen du dann wieder natürlich einen Namen geben kannst oder sie verblassen
kannst, kannst Umstiege definieren,
kannst Beziehungen zu anderen herstellen, um zu sagen, so erst muss das erfüllt sein, dann das.
Kannst Farben schick vergeben in einem einigermaßen flünftigen Farbraster.
Und all das wird im Hintergrund zusammengebaut zu einer JSON-Datei.
Die kannst du oben bei den Tabs umstellen.
Das heißt, du hast jetzt nicht irgendwie eine Datenbank dahinter,
sondern da das ja doch an Daten einigermaßen übersichtlich ist,
was da am Ende entsteht, ist das alles in einer einzigen JSON-Datei verbaut.
Und das liegt jetzt alles, wie ich das gerne mache, als GitHub-Page und wenn
du oben auf den Share-Button beispielsweise drückst.
Wird dir die ganze JSON-Datei plus der State, in dem die App gerade ist,
alles in eine URL zusammengebaut, die du jetzt sonst wo abwerfen kannst und
du kannst es wem anders rüberschicken.
Ohne, dass du also vorher irgendwo die JSON-Datei speichern musstest oder dich
darum kümmern, wie du das jetzt irgendwie in Pastebin angekoppelt bekommst oder ähnliches.
So dass also auch das Wie lang wird denn die URL?
Nicht so rasend lang, so aber es ist natürlich von Vorteil wenn du ein System
hast, wie beispielsweise jetzt hier in Slack, dass du einen Text eingibst und
dann die URL dahinter setzt, so aber das ist relativ harmlos das ist eine Kompression unten,
dahinter, das ist, muss ich mal eben gucken,
welche das ist,
da ist eine,
Schon amtlich.
Ja.
Mal eben gucken. Eine LZ-String-Kompression ist da am Start.
Also es kommt dann kein menschenlesbarer URL-String dabei raus,
sondern es ist halt zusammen komprimiert.
Aber das ermöglicht es halt mir wieder ohne eine Datenbankhaltung trotzdem den
Leuten ein Framework anzugeben.
Sie müssen sich nicht installieren, sie müssen sich keinen Account anlegen,
sie nutzen wie bei der Masterwall, die ich gemacht habe, einfach die URL.
Tragen dort ihre Sachen ein und können es trotzdem mit anderen Leuten sharen
und ihre Planungen für was auch immer schnell machen.
Sie können es natürlich auch sich einfach runterladen und selber betreiben.
Es sind keine wilden Abhängigkeiten drin, aber ich baue ja immer gerne Dienste,
die so out of the box direkt nutzbar sind, ohne dass die Leute sich irgendeinen Account holen müssen.
Eine RL, die 4907 Zeichen lang ist. Das ist doch schon sportlich.
Das ist sportlich, je nachdem wie umfangreich das halt auch ist,
was du da aufbaust und zeigen willst.
Okay, aber so shared daran arbeiten, daran geht natürlich nicht.
Ja, schon, indem du sagst, also nicht, wir arbeiten jetzt exakt zur selben Zeit
auf dem selben Datenbestand, sondern du schickst halt quasi dann die URL an
wen anders, der arbeitet weiter und schickt dir dann seinen Stand wieder zurück. So geht's halt.
Du kannst auch sagen, das kannst du bei Import, klick mal oben Import an,
da hast du verschiedene Optionen, Klicken Sie bitte mal Import an.
Klicken Sie Import an, da habe ich verschiedene Optionen.
Klick.
Ah, das JSON-File.
So, da kannst du entweder einen JSON-File hochladen oder du gibst eine URL an.
Das heißt, also du könntest jetzt auch sagen, okay, ich habe jetzt irgendwo
eine JSON-Datei in einem Pad-Bereich oder sowas, wo die Leute dann halt dann
doch zeitgleich drauf editieren könnten.
Aber das ist nicht unbedingt der empfohlene Weg, würde ich mal sagen.
So, und dann kannst du noch einmal bei Export draufklicken, was das dann alles
so rauswirft, weil es dann natürlich dann da will man ja auch ein bisschen,
variabel sein, da kannst du halt als SVG exportieren oder als PDF oder als PNG
oder was haben wir da noch für Optionen?
Womit erzeugst du das PDF?
Das PDF wird aus dem, also intern wird ein SVG erstmal aufgebaut und der PDF
Export passiert mit JS PDF und SVG to PDF JS.
Okay.
Also den Technologie-Stack ist natürlich auch alles schön. Genau,
es ist alles reiner Vektor.
Du kannst unendlich reinzoomen und sauber auf dem Farblaser ausdrucken und es sieht Bombe aus.
Der Technologie-Stack ist hier beschrieben.
Ja, schreit ja geradezu nach Phoenix Live View, diese Anwendung.
Ja, feel free.
Also da müsste man es natürlich anders implementieren, aber das wäre sozusagen
die Möglichkeit, dass mehrere Leute auch gleichzeitig daran arbeiten im Web.
Und zwar at the same time und nicht so abwechselnd oder so.
Ja, also ob der Use Case so groß ist, müsste man mal gucken.
Ja gut, wie hast du dir denn in diesem Workflow gedacht? Also man baut das so
zusammen, damit man dann am Ende im Wesentlichen so ein PDF bekommt oder vielleicht
auch mal jemand anders das übernehmen kann.
Genau. Und man speichert es sich halt selber irgendwo lokal ab.
Also es wird im Browser-Storage gespeichert, das Ganze.
Das heißt also auf einem und demselben
Rechner kannst du auch verschiedene Versionen oben überspeichern.
Kannst ja auch mal draufklicken, was dann passiert. Es wird auch alles ein bisschen
erklärt, was da so genau die Technik hinter ist. Gehen wir oben auf den Speichern-Button.
Ich habe hier gerade einen.
So, dann kannst du jetzt diese Roadmap 9 geben und dann siehst du halt,
okay, es landet dann also im Local Storage Bereich des Browsers.
Das heißt also auf dem Rechner hast du es dann auch in dieser Dropdown-Liste
daneben, kannst du dann verschiedene Versionen oder unterschiedliche Dinge,
die dann wieder hervorzaubern.
Aber wenn du natürlich deinen Rechner wechselst, musst du halt erstmal wieder
einen Import anschleißen.
Aber das ist halt immer so meine Bedingung, dass ich sage, ich will meine Apps
halt simpel halten und will nicht selber irgendwie als Data-Maintainer auftreten,
da habe ich keinen Bock drauf.
Und was waren jetzt deine Tools, um das zusammenzubauen?
Das war eigentlich ehrlich gesagt ein One-Shot von Gemini 3.1 Pro.
So, ein One-Shot.
Also natürlich nicht mit allen Features und erst im Planungsmodus gesetzt,
aber die ganze Grundarchitektur, auch die Softwareentscheidung,
also liegt jetzt ein D3JS hinter für die Linienfahrtführung,
für Kollisionserkennung.
Das heißt also, es ist schon relativ schlau auch, wie es diese Linien aufbaut.
Die sind ja auch etwas komplizierter gemacht, als sie es sein müssten. Das ist Absicht.
Das heißt also, dass man auch häufiger diese 45 Grad Abbiegewinkel drin hat,
damit es eben auch sofort nach U-Bahn sich anfühlt.
Die eine oder andere Linie könnte auch einfach gerade verlaufen,
aber dann sieht es halt nicht so cool aus.
Das ist schon ein bisschen Hirnschmalz reingeflossen und du kannst oben nochmal
auf Textfassung, da hast du noch einen Umschalter, wo du auch nämlich sagen
kannst, neben Metro-Map oben in der Menüleiste.
So, da hast du auch immer gleich nochmal einen Markdown deines ganzen Projektplans,
den du dir auch irgendwie rausgeben kannst.
Dass du also auch immer das Nebeneinander hast von, so ist es auf der visuellen
Ebene und so ist es jetzt auch mal einfach als Markdown, was ich irgendwo reinballern kann.
Jetzt musst du aber mal ehrlich sein, also dieses Beispielprojekt,
was du hier angelegt hast, ist natürlich extrem simpel.
Also wenn man das jetzt als Gantt-Chart modellieren würde, sähe es auch nicht schlimm aus.
Aber nicht so schön bunt.
Nicht so schön bunt, ja okay, aber ich meine, also ja.
Modellieren wir das SAP-Ding. können.
Ja, aber das ist ja auch kein Projekt, sondern die wollen ja halt irgendwie
eine Systemumgebung insgesamt.
Und hier geht es halt schon darum, irgendwie ein Projekt im Zeitverlauf mal
etwas anders und charmanter darzustellen.
Und denkst du, das ist jetzt im Wesentlichen so ein Tool für dich oder hast
du da, siehst du da jetzt auch unmittelbar innerhalb deiner Organisation andere Leute?
Ich sehe da ehrlich gesagt weltweit Leute, die sich da vielleicht drüber freuen,
weil ich glaube, dass dieser Use Case so, wie visualisierst du ein bisschen
interessanter einen Projektverlauf, ich glaube, dass es ein relativ universeller,
Bedarf dafür gibt.
So, und da glaube ich, ist das jetzt vielleicht mal ein hilfreicher Beitrag
zur Debatte, wie man sowas vielleicht auch mal visualisieren kann.
Gucken wir mal, was da so passiert.
Alright, schicko schick.
Also probiert es mal aus.
Wie ist es?
Die URL findet ihr in den Shownotes. Metroviz heißt das Ganze aus naheliegenden Gründen.
Liegt alles auf GitHub.
Kann man damit auch U-Bahn-Pläne machen?
Nee, nicht sinnvoll.
Das ist ja schade eigentlich jetzt.
Also klar kannst du, aber es ist halt quasi immer in einer Zwei-Dimension.
Ja gut, das sind ja quasi 1,5 Dimensionen.
Das machen wir dann zur nächsten Sendung.
Da muss man vielleicht jetzt ganz kurz noch ein Spiel pluggen. Mini-Metro.
Das ist wirklich auch ein wunderschönes Spiel. Es wird ganz schön schwierig.
Ja, bitte erklären.
Naja, du hast,
also du baust eine U-Bahn-Map auf. Es kommen immer wieder neue Stationen und
du kannst dann, ich glaube, du fängst mit zwei Linien an und,
Du verbindest dann mit der Linie die U-Bahnen und dann steigen da immer Leute
ein und aus und es gibt verschiedene geometrische Formen, wie eine U-Bahn-Station sein kann.
Also rund ein Viereck, ein Dreieck und dann steigen an den U-Bahnhöfen halt auch Figuren ein,
die rund dreieckig oder viereckig sind und die müssen mit der U-Bahn dann zum
nächsten Bahnhof gelangen,
der die gleiche Form hat von den Figuren.
Und das Ganze ist am Anfang super simpel und wird dann aber zu halt so einem Logistikproblem.
Das gibt es auch schon ewig, das Spiel.
Das gibt es so fünf Jahre mindestens.
Schöne Weile, ja.
Es ist erstaunlich einfach zu verstehen und erstaunlich hart.
Schwer zu meistern.
Schwer zu meistern, ja wirklich, weil das dann relativ schnell sehr komplex wird.
Man bekommt immer nach einer gewissen Zeit, kann man dann neue Wagen bekommen
oder man kann eine neue Linie dazu bekommen oder so.
In vielen Städten gibt es einen Fluss und den kann man nur überwinden,
wenn man auch eine Brücke hat und und und. Also das ist so…,
So ist das.
Ja, da habe ich auch eine Zeit lang gerne gespielt, aber das hat auch so eine
steile Kurve, dass es dann doch relativ schnell sehr fies wird.
Ich würde mir bei solchen Spielen immer dreimal so viele Levels im harmlos Bereich wünschen.
Ja, da gibt es halt dann so Städte, da gibt es auch Schnellzüge und die fahren
halt dann schneller und dann ist es sinnvoll, Strecken zu bauen,
die halt weniger Stationen haben, damit der Schnellzug relativ,
ja, jetzt in der Map, Tim spielt es gerade, während ich das erkläre,
in dem Map, in der Map gibt es halt keine Brücken, sondern Tunnel,
aber das ist ja irgendwie, Also man muss,
braucht irgendwas, um die Barriere zu überqueren.
Vom gleichen Hersteller gab es dann später ein Mini, wie heißt denn das,
mit Autos das Ganze nochmal, wo man dann Straßen bauen muss.
Da ploppen dann so Häuser auf und da muss man die Häuser ins Straßennetz anbieten,
binden und dann wollen die Leute immer mit ihren Autos irgendwie zum Einkaufen
fahren oder zur Arbeit oder so und da fahren die immer hin und her und irgendwann
droht dann der Verkehrsinfalt.
Mini Motorways.
Mini Motorways, genau. Ist das.
So und Mini Metro, Tim und ich haben recht, ist 10 Jahre alt.
10 Jahre alt.
Das ist von 2011, 2015 ist das.
Ich sagte ja nur mindestens fünf Jahre.
Und Mini Motorways ist 2019. Ich habe hier gerade die...
Ah ja, okay, das ist auch schon so alt.
Das ist aber glaube ich noch stressiger. Das hat mich noch mehr gestresst.
Ja.
Aber ich erinnere mich gerade wieder daran, wie geil eigentlich Mini Metro war.
Das ist wirklich ein geiles Spiel. Das ist wirklich eine super Idee.
Okay, aber genug gespielt. Okay.
So, ja, AI.
Wisst ihr, wer sich zum Thema AI geäußert hat?
Wer hat sich denn noch nicht geäußert?
Ja, der Papst.
Der Papst, na super. Und?
Der Papst scheint, also ich meine, wir haben ja jetzt mal echt einen modernen
Papst, der ist so modern, dass er sogar von Trump beschimpft wird.
Das will ja mal was heißen.
Also ich meine, mal ehrlich, all diese Päpste, die ihr bisher so wahrgenommen
habt, vielleicht in eurem Leben, bis zu dem aktuellen Papst, das waren auch alles so,
geistdurchströmte halt so Päpste. Also es war so, weiß nicht.
Reaktionär-konservative Herz. Naja gut.
Die beschäftigen sich irgendwie im Wesentlichen so mit der Kirche und mit ihrer Community.
Und dem Glauben.
Hier dieser Ratzinger, das war doch irgendwie der Typ, der hat doch dann gleich
so komplette, wie heißt das, Bücher, diese Lehren da aufgezogen und so theoretische,
Diskussionen wie vor 200, 300 Jahren.
Ja, aber Ratzinger war ja auch extrem in der Hinsicht.
Ja, der war extrem. Und der vorletzte Papst, der war ja irgendwie ganz nice
und so, der war ja irgendwie recht charming, der aus, wo war der,
aus Argentinien, glaube ich.
Ja, das war so ein Partypapst.
Ein Partypapst?
Ja, so ein bisschen kam er immer rüber, als wäre er irgendwie der Juwelate.
Der ist es doch immer noch, oder?
Habe ich was verpasst?
Weil das doch der Nachratze also Ratze ist abgetreten.
JD Vance hat ihn besucht, danach ist er gestorben.
Oh Gott, ich war ja mal katholisch. Ich sollte das eigentlich wissen, wer aktuell Papst ist.
Und jetzt ist ein Amerikaner Papst.
Ja, wir haben jetzt einen US-Amerikaner Leo.
Das habe ich schon wieder komplett verdrängt.
Und der Typ ist ganz cool. Der ist wirklich cool.
Und man mag es nicht glauben, aber es gibt jetzt eine Message of His Holiness, Pope Leo, der 14.
In vielen Sprachen. Und da wird dann doch mal erzählt, was Phase ist.
Der hat sich also wirklich zum Thema AI gemeldet.
Oh, das war jetzt ernst? Das war ein ironisch gemeinter Schuss ins Blaue. Okay, gut.
Ja, genau. Und zwar Botschaft von Papst Leo XIV zum 60. Welttag der sozialen,
Kommunikationsmittel.
Okay.
Alter, es gibt es nicht auf Latein. Ich werde Was ist denn da los?
Naja, da ist wahrscheinlich bei Social Media so ein bisschen dann der Doch da.
Latine.
Was, wirklich?
Achso, nee, man schaltet die ganze Webseite um. Oh, die sieht auch so aus,
als wäre sie noch von Was.
Man kann die ganze Webseite auf Latein umstellen?
Ja, es gibt da so ein The Holy See und rechts oben ist dieses Dropdown.
Okay, ich versage jetzt ein bisschen da drin, das alles,
zusammenzufassen was so der Papst da von sich gegeben hat, aber das liest sich
alles sehr gut und ich kann das nur empfehlen, dass man das mal geht.
Also vor allem fand ich es sehr schön, wie er schon zu Beginn mit Begrifflichkeiten
arbeitet und sozusagen über die menschliche Kommunikation resoniert.
Und ich hatte dann gleich so ein Aha-Element, als er meinte,
ja, das Wort Person kommt von...
Was ist sozusagen der Ursprung des Wortes Person?
Persona, wahrscheinlich.
Personare, genau. Ich kann dich hören.
Das heißt, das Wort Person ist gebunden an die sprachliche Kommunikation und
dass man eben so direkt miteinander agiert und auch so Face irgendwie kommt
so aus dem Griechischen und sozusagen so das,
was ich in meinem Sichtbereich habe.
Also FaceTime quasi.
Und ja, er hat da so eine längere Abhandlung abgelassen, die also überhaupt
nicht verbrämt rüberkommt, sondern einfach mal eine ganz klare,
trockene Analyse ist und natürlich auch eine Predigt in gewisser Hinsicht für,
wie er das so sieht, für echte menschliche Interaktion, weil er eben sagt,
Menschen, also Gesicht und Stimme sind einfach unersetzlich.
Und diese Simulation durch AI,
ohne dass es hier wirklich so ein Embodiment gibt, das ist halt einfach kein
guter Trend und der befürchtet,
dass also AI die kognitiven und kreativen Fähigkeiten von Menschen reduzieren,
wenn man sich eben zu sehr darauf verlässt.
Also weniger unabhängiges Denken,
weniger Kreativität, weil man eben einfach, klar, sich nur noch auf diese Systeme
verlässt und befürchtet halt einfach,
dass die Menschen dann einfach zu passiven Konsumenten werden und dass das dann
eben auch für kulturelle Werke problematisch ist,
weil die ja einfach sozusagen nur noch mehr für das Training von Maschinen als
für menschliche Konsumtion gedacht sind.
Also auch diese Aspekte sind dabei. Dann spricht da natürlich auch das Problem
von Wahrheit und Realitätswahrnehmung an,
dass das also dadurch dann doch eher brüchig wird und dass Deepfakes hier einfach dazu beitragen,
dass Realität und künstliche Welten miteinander verschwimmen und dass das eben
auch die Vertrauen in die Kommunikation beeinflusst.
Und appelliert, dass halt also Technologie den Menschen dienen muss und dass
das sozusagen so ein normatives.
Prinzip ist, dass also hier die Maschine dem Menschen untertan zu sein hat.
Er sagt nicht, dass man jetzt AI generell ablehnen soll, das lässt sich ja eh
kaum verhindern, aber dass man also hier so eine Art ethisches Government an
den Tag legen soll, um dann einfach in Vielen Dank.
In der Bildung eine entsprechende Literacy herzustellen,
dass man generell sich darüber Gedanken machen sollte, ethische Rahmenwerke
aufzubauen und dass das halt einfach eine kollektive Verantwortung ist in der ganzen Gesellschaft,
einschließlich von Entwicklern, Institutionen und den Nutzern und dass halt
die menschliche Kommunikation hier weiterhin im Mittelpunkt steht.
Also bemerkenswert finde ich, dass er sich überhaupt zu diesem Thema äußert.
Bemerkenswert finde ich, wie er sich dazu äußert, dass jetzt überhaupt keinerlei
religiöse Verbrämung und Gotteslästerei leitet das natürlich so ein bisschen
ein mit Gott und hat uns ja so und so erschaffen.
Was halt so Bäbse dann so sagen, aber darüber hinaus ist es also wirklich ein
interessantes Pamphlet und ich fand es bemerkenswert, dass der Papst sich dazu äußert.
Ich finde es steil, dass der Papst wirklich reinschreibt, nicht auf eigenes Denken verzichten.
Weil ich glaube, wenn es eine Kernkompetenz der Kirche ist, dann den Leuten das Denken abzunehmen.
Also das ist so, ich weiß nicht.
Naja, wir müssen jetzt ja vielleicht nicht in tiefere theologische Debatten,
aber so die Macht der freien Entscheidung ist schon eine Kernannahme des Christentums.
Also dem kann man sich da jetzt nicht erzählen.
Jody Wenz hat ja gesagt, der Papst soll sich jetzt mal aus theologischen Debatten
raushalten. Das finde ich bemerkenswert.
Ja, also das fand ich dann doch bemerkenswert.
Was fand ich noch bemerkenswert dann gab es noch diesen,
also das verfolge ich ja wirklich nur so am Rande ich habe das so ein bisschen
mitbekommen es gibt wohl so einen YouTube Video Kanal der sich so mit Filme
machen und Special Effects und sowas beschäftigt Corridor heißt die Truppe.
Und einer dieser Leute also ich kenne den Kanal nicht gut ich habe mir jetzt
ein, zwei Videos dabei angeschaut, die beschäftigen sich halt mit so Filmproduktionsthemen.
Unter eher technischem Aspekt so und machen halt selber auch Filme und sind
irgendwie so halt so aufgeweckte Mit-30er, die das irgendwie,
betreiben. Kann gut sein, dass die super bekannt waren schon.
Ich kannte die vorher gar nicht, weil ich mit dieser Welt einfach nichts zu tun habe.
Aber das ist dann wirklich sehr interessant. Sie haben, ich muss mal dieses
Video nochmal raussuchen,
ein generelles Problem der Filmemacherei angesprochen, nämlich Greenscreens.
Was ist das Problem mit Greenscreens?
Das Problem mit Greenscreens ist, dass du also was du erstmal versuchst damit ist ja,
Videocontent auf du nimmst einen Film auf oder nimmst eine Szene auf und du
möchtest dann später gegen einen anderen Hintergrund setzen also hast halt irgendwelche Schauspieler,
die jetzt irgendwas machen in der Halle und danach soll das halt irgendwie Star
Wars irgendwo auf einem anderen Planeten stattfinden etc.
Und.
Das ist alles gar nicht so einfach, weil die Technologien, die existieren,
um das Grün im Hintergrund dann durch Transparenz zu ersetzen,
man kennt ja dieses Freistellen-Problem auch, wenn man jetzt so Photoshop und so weiter arbeitet,
das ist halt gar nicht so einfach und erläutert dann auch in dem Video sehr
ausführlich, was es alles so ist.
Also du hast halt keine wirkliche Transparenz, dann leuchtet dieses Grün dann
auch in deine Farben rein, dann hast du halt grüne Haare, hast du Probleme mit
Motion Blur und so weiter.
Also es ist generell schwierig und in vielen Filmen bedeutet Greenscreen Arbeit
in den Film reinzubringen, sehr viel Handarbeit bis hin zu retuschieren jedes einzelnen Frames.
Also nicht immer. Und der Typ hatte halt so ein bisschen Schnauze voll und hat
sich gedacht, gibt doch jetzt hier dieses AI-Ding, das müsste man doch irgendwie besser hinkriegen.
Wobei man könnte noch den Zwischenschritt sagen, das was bei The Mandalorian
beispielsweise jetzt immer zum Einsatz kommt,
dass die Leute gleich in so einer riesigen LED-Halle sich bewegen und spielen,
wo dann schon das fertig gerenderte im Hintergrund in hoch genug Auflösung abläuft,
dass du hinterher im Endprodukt nicht mehr siehst, dass es halt ein Pixelscreen ist, der da.
Beziehungsweise, dass du das tatsächlich mit einer Game Engine machst und dann
Kamerafahrten machst und dann die Perspektive, die auf der Greenscreen,
also auf dem Hintergrunddings gezeigt wird,
mitpannt, sodass der Eindruck entsteht, dass tatsächlich das dahinter ist.
Genau, ich habe ja meinen Beitrag reingeworfen jetzt hier in den Chat,
wo das mal so ein bisschen durchdekliniert wird, aber das ist halt auch irrer
Aufwand, der der Betrieb wird.
Unreal Engine brüstet sich damit, dass sie das verdammt gut können und überhaupt.
Und das ist eine Anwendung, die aber mehr Geld kostet als ein Spiel machen.
Ja, und das ist halt noch mehr Aufwand als ein Greenscreen. Weil das halt alles
in Echtzeit quasi bauen muss.
Genau, aber das generelle,
Problem ist halt, wie trennst du Vordergrund von Hintergrund.
Ich meine, klar ist das geil, wenn du bei Disney da so eine riesen LED-Wand
aufbaust und das alles da schon fertig hinrenderst, aber was für ein Aufwand.
Also wenn du so ein normales kleines Filmstudio bist und du willst einfach mal
da irgendeine Szene drehen.
Niemand hat, also heutzutage hat kaum jemand die Möglichkeit,
so einen Aufwand zu machen.
Das mit dem Game-Rendering und so weiter, auch ein interessanter Ansatz.
Aber der klassische Greenscreen ist halt Manchmal einfach die einfachere Methode
funktioniert in der Regel auch ganz gut, macht aber eine ganze Menge Arbeit.
Tatsächlich ist dieses Problem allerdings schon vor langer, langer Zeit von
Disney mal gelöst worden.
Jetzt muss ich kurz mal darüber nachdenken. Und zwar, das kann ich jetzt glaube
ich gerade nicht so richtig erklären.
Und zwar arbeiten die mit speziellen Lampen.
Ich weiß gerade nicht, ob das so Quecksilberdampflampen waren oder irgendwie
sowas ähnliches, die halt so ein sehr spezifisches Licht machen,
was wirklich nur so in einem ganz, ganz, ganz dünnen Frequenzband,
scheint und mit der Technik haben sie zum Beispiel diese ganzen Aufnahmen für
Mary Poppins gemacht, wie sie da durch die Luft geflogen ist,
das ist schon so eine uralte Technik die aber von irgendwie Disney auch patentiert
ist und ich weiß gar nicht, warum das nicht,
generell mehr zum Einsatz kommt.
Aber die Leute von Corridor dachten sich so, wir haben doch jetzt irgendwie
AI, vielleicht kann man das ja mal irgendwie benutzen. Und,
Das Interessante ist, dass er dann jetzt gesagt hat, ja gut,
also wir wollen also so Personen, Objekte von diesem Grün trennen.
Wäre doch geil, wenn man so eine AI aufsetzen kann, wo man das einfach so trainiert
und dann lernt die AI, was ist vorne und was ist hinten.
Also das ist sozusagen das Grün des Hintergrunds, raustrennt von dem vorderen,
sodass du ein beliebiges vor einem Greenscreen aufgenommenes Bild da reinpipst
und der gibt dir die perfekte Maske zurück.
Und der Ansatz, den er gewählt hat, der ist wirklich cool,
weil du brauchst ja für AI, brauchst ja positives Material, was halt sagt so,
hier, das wäre jetzt diese Maske gewesen von diesem Bild, aber du hast ja das eigentlich nicht.
Und hat einfach festgestellt, naja gut,
also man kann ja heutzutage mit 3D eigentlich super geil Personen machen und
super geil beliebige Objekte machen und hat dann halt einfach sich sein ganzes
Trainingsmaterial zusammengerendert.
Das heißt, er hat halt irgendwie Personen mit Haaren und alles mögliche Computer generiert.
Das scheinen sie da ganz gut zu können und vor einem Greenscreen, der dann halt,
tausend Varianten hat, mit unterschiedlicher Beleuchtung und Falten und was
nicht alles und hat dann einfach mal so ein AI-Model trainiert und siehe da,
das hat ganz gut funktioniert.
Dann hat er das irgendwie auf GitHub geworfen und er meinte,
ich bin ja eigentlich gar kein richtiger Programmierer, aber er hat sich da
irgendwie ganz gut reingenerdet, so ein bisschen wie du auch hier mit deinem Code.
Hat dann der Community gesagt, so, ja, hier funktioniert im Prinzip,
braucht noch ein bisschen viel RAM, also braucht irgendwie, keine Ahnung,
16, 33, 32 Megabyte V-Rahmen und so weiter, also funktioniert sozusagen nur.
Gigabyte wahrscheinlich, aber ja.
Was habe ich gesagt?
Mega.
Ja, ja, genau. Also irgendwie extrem große Datenmengen und lief also sozusagen
nur auf voll ausgebauten fetten Kisten,
und meinte so, ja, vielleicht könnt ihr ja mal helfen und naja,
das Internet kam natürlich dann schnell zur Hilfe und zwei Tage später brauchte
das Ding dann irgendwie nur noch die Hälfte oder ein Drittel von diesem Speicherbedarf
und es wird die ganze Zeit verbessert und sie trainieren jetzt irgendwie weiter
und sieht ganz so aus, als ob hier,
eine sehr interessante Lösung gefunden hat, weil die Ergebnisse sind dann stunning.
Also die haben halt dann die krassesten Sachen gemacht, also sie haben so alle
Probleme gezeigt, die auch das sieht man sehr schön in diesem Video,
was da so ist, so mit transparenter Kleidung, Haare, Wasser, Gläser.
Schnelle Bewegung, Gläser, Reflektionen, alles mögliche.
Und sie haben dann diesen neuen Key dagegen, also dieses Corridor-Key,
so heißt dieses Plug-in, das haben sie jetzt getestet.
Und jetzt gibt es das so als fertig runterladbares Plug-in für,
wie heißt diese Videosoftware, die jetzt alle benutzen?
OSC?
Nein. Insta Studio?
Wenn man nicht aus der Welt ist. Also After Effects war es nicht.
Das hier von Blackmagic, das Ding.
Wie heißt es? Da Vinci Resolve.
Da Vinci Resolve, ja.
Keine Ahnung, ob das dann auch schon für andere klappt, aber das war jetzt erstmal so das Target.
Und ja, das existiert jetzt so. Und das fand ich bemerkenswert.
Vor allem fand ich es bemerkenswert, wie sie jetzt ihren Trainingansatz gemacht
haben, dass sie quasi mit 3D generiert, also das 3D-Generierte ist so gut, also sieht so echt aus.
Das ist fürs Training völlig ausreichend.
Und die haben halt perfekte Kontrolle über alle Umweltbedingungen,
weil es ist halt gerendert.
Genau, es ist halt gerendert und das ist das Geile und dadurch entsteht jetzt
also ein Modell, was jetzt wahrscheinlich gerade as we speak deutlich besser
wird von zack zu Tag, aber jetzt schon hervorragende Ergebnisse liefert.
Das heißt, wenn man jetzt geile Greenscreen-Aufnahmen hat und man möchte das
mal ordentlich raustrennen, dann wäre das unter Umständen ein Weg.
Ich habe wirklich mit Videobearbeitung so überhaupt nichts zu tun.
Deswegen gebe ich das jetzt hier einfach mal nur so wieder, wie ich es verstanden
habe. Aber das fand ich dann doch ein bemerkenswertes Projekt.
Das hätte auch den Papst erfreut.
Wer weiß.
Ah ja, der Papst ist cool.
Also generell so im Bereich Bildgenerierung habe ich ja erzählt,
aber auch Video, da tut sich im Moment wieder schröcklich viel so.
Kann ich zu einer der nächsten Sendung vielleicht auch mal das ein oder andere
Live-Experiment mitbringen. Das ist schon...
Da ist die Menschheit auch alle noch nicht drauf vorbereitet, was da passiert.
Ja, aber OpenAI hat so rar abgeschaltet. Das hat so viel verbraucht.
Ja, aber weil sie das Nachfolgeprodukt aber auch gerade wieder irgendwie lancieren.
Ja, das war die Schlagzeile, aber wenn man dann irgendwie genauer nachgelesen
hat, hatte das dann auch gleich wieder noch einen Spin.
Aber da kann ich irgendwann mal ein paar Sachen noch vorbereiten.
So, was heißt das, dass wir schon fast durch sind?
Ich habe noch ein paar Kleinigkeiten, die können sich noch hinten ranschmeißen, dann bin ich das los.
Und ich habe noch einen Aufruf, den muss ich auch noch loswerden.
Einen Aufruf?
Einen Aufruf.
Dauert der lange, der Aufruf?
Nur fünf Minuten.
Okay, dann mache ich nochmal kurz zwei kleine oder eine kleine Sache.
Ist euch das schon mal passiert, dass euer Mac zu viel Platz braucht auf der
Platte und ihr gerne Platz frei machen möchtet?
Ja, ja, ja.
Ja?
Ständig.
Und was tust du dann?
Dinger auslagern.
Aber du hast trotzdem das Gefühl, eigentlich müsste da genug sein zum wegschmeißen.
Ja, eigentlich schon. Also ich habe auch mal hier von dem aus hier,
unser Schwester-Podcast hier ATP.
Achso, ATP.
Der hat ja ein Tool gebaut für Duplikate finden.
Ja, ja, Hyperspace.
Hyperspace, genau. Hat nichts gebracht. Ich habe keine Duplikate.
So was habe ich ja auch mal gemacht. Aber gut, das ist 15 Jahre her.
Naja, also ich weiß nicht, ob es dir hilft, aber du könntest es mal ausprobieren. Sehr einfach.
Und zwar kann man mit Homebrew einfach ein kleines Tool installieren. Das heißt MOL.
Brew Install MOL.
Das machen wir doch jetzt live in der Sendung.
Da muss man natürlich dann auch Vertrauen haben. Wie der Maulwurf.
What could possibly go wrong?
MOL, der Maulwurf, arbeitet sich durch dein macOS und findet alles,
was bei 3 nicht auf den Bäumen ist.
Das ist so der totale Durchwühler für so alle möglichen Cache-Dateien,
die irgendwo rumhängen.
Du hast damit auch so ein Uninstall-Feature und,
Und, wo ist denn hier eigentlich der MOL?
Deep, clean and optimize your Mac.
Genau, also es gibt da so verschiedene Modi, die du da fahren kannst.
Und machen wir erstmal Analyze.
Ihr seid schon dabei, ne?
Ja.
Genau, also du kannst den auch erstmal in einem Machen-noch-nix-Modus starten.
Du kannst aber hier auch YOLO machen und sagen, hier, Rotpasswort, gib ihm.
Ja, aber das ist recht effizient und ich kenne Leute, die haben damit signifikante Ergebnisse erzielt.
Also er hat hier, zeigt schon mal 126 Gigabyte Old Downloads an, älter als 90 Tage.
Ja, zum Beispiel, so eine Sachen. Genau, das ist der kleine Moll,
der könnte euch vielleicht helfen.
Wenn wir bei Kommandozeilentools sind. Apfel heißt das Tool.
Das ist auch ein Kommandozeilending, womit man das Sprachmodell von Apple selber
per Kommandozeile benutzen kann.
Also das ist ja kein, ich weiß nicht, ob man es ein LLM nennen kann.
Achso, das Sprachmodell.
Das Siri-Ding von Apple.
Das Siri-Ding oder das Apple-Intelligence-Ding?
Apple-Intelligence.
Muss man da zu Apple-Intelligence eingeschaltet haben?
Ja, ich glaube schon.
Das habe ich ja nicht. Habt ihr das eingeschaltet?
Ich kann das nicht ertragen, weil es dann immer diese komischen Sachen in meinem
Messages-Programm einblendet. und dann muss ich das leider ausschalten,
weil man das Feature nicht ausschalten kann. Das ist zum Heulen.
Ja, ich habe es, glaube ich.
Apfel heißt das.
Das heißt Apfel, ja.
Auf Deutsch.
Auf Deutsch, das deutsche Wort für Apple, Apfel.
Ja. Man merkt so richtig, dass den Command-Line-Tools langsam der Namespace ausgeht.
Also es gibt ja jetzt zum Beispiel auch, wo man früher ASDF verwendet hat,
um so spezifische Versionen von Programmen zu installieren, mehrere Versionen
gleichzeitig vorrätig zu halten,
gibt es jetzt das schöne Tool Mise.
Mise en jour.
Mise en place.
Mise en place, ja.
Genau.
Ja, das ist ein bisschen aufwendiger zu benutzen, ist aber, wenn du wirklich
genaue Kontrolle über deine Tools haben willst.
Ich finde es viel einfacher.
Mit welchen Versionen auch immer, dann ist es ganz schön.
Genau, und jetzt kommt auch noch Deutsch ins Spiel und jetzt ist Apfel dabei.
Apfel, ja.
Apfel.franzai.com, okay.
Und dann kann man was genau tun?
Das Sprachmodell benutzen mit allem, was man so haben will.
Man kann auch irgendwie einen Server starten und dann kann man da irgendwie,
was man mit so einem Sprachmodell macht, Prompts machen und dann spuckt er irgendwas aus.
Guck mal, im Slack ist der Preview mit einem anderen Font als auf der Webseite
und der Font ist ja wohl mal richtig geil.
Alter.
Wow.
Opinionated.
Ja, absolut.
Okay, und was kann man dann zum Beispiel damit machen? Kann man was tun?
Ach so, man kann Apfel und dann einfach eine Frage stellen. Okay.
Ja, oder Echo, irgendwas, Pipe Apfel.
Ja.
Lustig.
Okay, das ist cool.
Was man halt so auf der Kommandozeile macht.
Ja.
Pipes benutzen und so weiter. Also wenn du auf die GitHub-Seite gehst, dann hat er da ganz viele,
Beispiele, was man da machen kann.
Ja.
Du hast ja vorhin gesagt, Apple sind die einzigen, die da gerade nicht und so.
Du hast bestimmt auch gehört, hier Marco Arment mit seiner Mac Mini Farm zum,
Transkribieren sämtlicher jemals publizierten Podcast Folgen.
Der war ja auch sehr begeistert von dem Speech-to-Text-Modell,
was Apple da jetzt rausgebracht hat. Das muss ich auch nochmal gegentesten.
Das hatte ich doch mal vorgestellt, dass das auch vor allen Dingen verdammt schnell ist.
Ja, verdammt schnell.
Das muss ich für Ultraschall echt nochmal antesten, ob das weil ich habe im
Moment das Whisper halt und das ist super von der Qualität her, aber dauert halt.
So fünffach Real-Time schafft das auch, aber er hatte da ja irgendwie Faktor
10, also sprich irgendwie 50-fach Real-Time oder sowas hatte er da rausgegeben.
Ich hatte in der Firma auch gesprochen mit einem Chef vom Chef irgendwas weiter
oben und der kam so völlig begeistert an und meinte so, hey man kann diesen Mac Studio mit...
Weiß ich nicht mehr, was sagt der? 192 Gigabyte Speicherkaufen für nur,
20.000 oder was der kostet und so.
Und da kann man das so und so Modell drauflaufen lassen ohne Probleme.
Vielleicht sollten wir einfach einen mal kaufen und bei uns hier hinstellen,
dann können wir Sachen machen. Ich dachte nur so, in welcher Welt lebe ich denn jetzt hier?
Aber ja, es ist halt auch so, die Modelle brauchen vor allem Speicher.
Also Rechenkapazität ist gar nicht so entscheidend.
Aber das ist natürlich spannend jetzt hier, was du hier rausgekramen hast.
Das werde ich natürlich mal durch meine Standardtests durchlaufen lassen.
Ich bitte darum.
Ich werde berichten.
Also du kannst es mit minus minus Chat starten, dann hast du ein richtiges Chatinterface
und du kannst es auch mit minus minus serve machen und dann verhält es sich
wie eine OpenAI API auf Localhost.
Das heißt, du kannst dann jedes Tool, was du mit OpenAI API reden kannst,
kannst du dann auch quasi lokal auf deinen Rechner hetzen.
Sag nochmal das Kommando für die fürs Chatinterface.
Also wie gesagt, ich hatte den Link gepostet und das ist der Link zur GitHub-Seite
und da ist alles erklärt.
Apfel minus minus chat einfach.
Ah, okay. gibt auch einen ordentlichen.
Ja, kannst du einfach Apfel eingeben, Return und dann sagt er dir alles.
Ja, also das ist ganz schön. Und Apfel minus Benchmark run internal performance Benchmarks.
Aha, dann kann man mal gucken, wie schnell die eigene Büchse ist.
Ich habe hier als Fehlermeldung die Arm64 Architecture is required for the software error.
Arm64 eigentlich?
Was hast du denn?
Ja, keine Ahnung. Ich habe jetzt einfach hier...
Ja, weiß ich, dass ich das habe. Homebrew behauptet was anderes.
Das habe ich doch gerade eben geupdatet.
Was sollst du sonst haben außer Arm64?
Ja, gute Frage. Nächste Frage.
Gibt ja eigentlich nichts.
Okay, jetzt habe ich mal einen Grund, Apple Intelligence anzuschalten.
Ich werde es wahrscheinlich gleich wieder abschalten.
Ja, okay, gut. Jetzt sind wir
ja fast am Ende. Jetzt kannst du noch deinen Aufruf starten an die Welt.
Meinen Aufruf an die Welt, genau. Ähm,
Wir sind ja immer eher so Kongressmenschen, aber es gibt ja auch noch irgendwie
andere Welten von Kongressen, wo die Leute irgendwie hin pilgern und sich treffen.
Und einer davon ist ja jedes Jahr im Frühling in Berlin die Republika, so für Netzpeople.
Und da sind wir diesmal vom Föp mit einem eigenen Stand, den uns Senkult,
Senatsverwaltung für Kultur und Zusammenhalt in Berlin gesponsert hat.
Und dort, also wir heißt der FÖB, die Berliner Bibliotheken.
Und wir stellen dort im Wesentlichen drei Dinge vor.
Zum einen, was wir alles im Bereich Digitalangebote eigentlich haben mit einer
Bibliothekskarte für 10 Euro, mit so Zugang zu Statista und ähnlichen feinen Sachen.
Dann stellen wir vor Digital Zebra als Projekt,
wo es darum geht, an unseren Bibliotheksstandorten quasi Digital Literacy Stationen
einzurichten, wo Leute hin können, die Schwierigkeiten haben mit Online-Formularen
der Stadt und ähnliches.
Und dort starten wir auch ein Projekt vor, was ich hier noch nicht breiter geplagt
habe, sondern immer nur so angedeutet.
Nämlich unsere Initiative, ob man nicht eigentlich für so eine Stadt wie Berlin
auch eine andere Art von digitaler Grundversorgung mal angehen sollte.
So im Sinne von, ist nicht eigentlich auch eine Welt denkbar,
in der der Kita-WhatsApp-Chat nicht der Endgegner ist,
sondern das Ganze auf einer öffentlichen Infrastruktur läuft und in der man
nicht Google Docs braucht und in der man kein Dropbox braucht und kein Google
Groups und dazu basteln wir schon jetzt so seit anderthalb Jahren an Konzepten und wir sind jetzt so,
dass wir dort einen ersten Prototypen vorstellen,
früher hätte man gesagt irgendwie so Beta und.
Das wird, glaube ich, ganz gut funktionieren. Das Backend dazu,
also quasi das, worauf das Ganze läuft, ist Discourse.
Also das Online-Community-System von den Leuten, die hier Stack Overflow gemacht haben.
Die wissen ja bekanntlich, was sie tun. Und das haben wir tüchtig uminterpretiert
und erweitert und haben jetzt quasi ein lokales, an Bibliotheken gehostetes Community-System.
Und das wollen wir auf der Republika mal ausprobieren. Und dafür suche ich noch Kollaborateurinnen,
sprich Leute, die auch auf der Republika sind und vielleicht selber dort auch
einen Stand betreiben oder einen Vortrag halten oder dort mit irgendwelchen
kleinen Communities aufschlagen und die Lust und Laune haben,
mal unser System auszuprobieren.
Dann würden wir nämlich euch für die Republika dort quasi eine Mikro-Community
mal bauen und bereitstellen.
Und dann könnt ihr das dort mal vor Ort auf der Straße ausprobieren.
Weil der unique selling point, den wir reinbringen in die ganze Geschichte ist
so, wir sind auf der Straße.
Wir haben als Bibliotheken physisch reale Orte und da kann man einen QR-Code an die Wand hängen.
Und Leute, die in einer echten Veranstaltung sind, sei es eine Lesung oder ein
Makerspace, ein Kurs, was auch immer, scannen mit ihrem Handy diesen QR-Code
und sind direkt in ihrer lokalen Bibliotheks-Community drin.
Und das wollen wir auf der Republika mal probieren. Wem das jetzt alles zu kurz
und zu hektisch war, in den Shownotes findet ihr einen Talk von mir dazu.
Der ist auch knackig kurz, 18 Minuten.
Da wird das ganze Konzept nochmal erklärt. Und
Wenn ihr auf der Republika seid und denkt, das hört sich doch ansatzweise spannend
an, was die Bibliotheken da macht.
Also A, kommt an unserem Stand vorbei und B, meldet euch bei mir im Vorfeld,
ob ihr nicht eine dieser Republika-Test-Communities werden könnt.
Und was ist an dieser Community jetzt bibliothekspezifisch? Geht das jetzt nur
mit, wenn man eine Bibliothek ist?
Ja, wir werden eine Authentifizierung haben, wo auch dein Bibliotheksausweis hilft.
Aber du kannst ja auch einfach nur mit Nutzernamen, E-Mail, Account shoppen.
Also wir haben jetzt keinen Filter drin.
Du musst einen Bibliotheksausweis haben, um da mitmachen zu können.
Aber der Gedanke ist schon...
Ich sage nicht weniger als User, sondern mehr als Anbieter. Also wenn man jetzt
da seine eigene... Ich habe das so verstanden, dass man seine eigene...
Das ist jetzt nur ein Proof of Concept auf der Republika. Da geht es nur darum,
wir spielen das mal drei Tage lang durch.
Also ihr habt nur eine Instanz, die nicht jeder seine eigene kriegt.
Genau, aber die ist halt mandantenfähig. Das heißt, wir können beliebig viele
Communities auf dieser einen Instanz betreiben.
Ah, okay, aber das müssen nicht Bibliotheken sein.
Nein, überhaupt gar nicht.
Genau, weil so kam das jetzt gerade.
Nee, nee, das können Firmen sein, da bin ich also auch völlig kontaktfreudig.
Also wer auch immer meint, dort irgendwie das mal ausprobieren zu können, sagt Bescheid.
Und von den Features her ist es dann schon relativ wuchtig, was wir da vorhaben.
Also wir versuchen wirklich in einem Zug WhatsApp, Google Docs, Dropbox,
Google Docs, Groups, was auch immer, Facebook Groups, Kopplungen an Spheediverse werden wir haben,
Umfragen kannst du damit machen, Terminverwaltung für deine Community, also das ganze Paket.
Was halt auch so ein Versprechen ist, du musst dann für deine Community nicht
fünf verschiedene Tools haben, sondern nur ein einziges.
Und das ist noch nicht mal eine App, sondern rein webbasiert.
Das heißt, die Leute müssen auch nichts installieren.
Das Ganze ist also versucht, so niedrigschwellig wie überhaupt nur irgendwie möglich zu haben.
Wenn wir das fertig haben zur Republika, können wir uns dann gerne das hier
dann irgendwann in der Sendung danach dann nochmal live angucken,
ob das Ganze funktioniert hat.
Ob das überhaupt funktioniert, der ganze Kack.
Aber ich bin da Ganz zuversichtlich, weil ich halt weiß, dass die Technik dahinter
geil ist und wir haben gute Partnerfirmen, die auch im Clubumfeld nicht ganz unbekannt sind.
Also Leute, die auch ein bisschen was verstehen von ihrem Handwerk,
haben uns damit an Bord geholt und gucken wir mal, ob das nicht ziemlich geil wird.
Also guckt euch mal dieses Video an, da erkläre ich das hoffentlich einigermaßen verständlich.
Weil irgendeiner muss mal anfangen mit dieser digitalen Souveränität hier.
Vier Stunden Freakshow, aber Ralf haut noch einen raus.
Es gibt nichts Gutes, außer man tut es.
Ja, das stimmt allerdings. Da hast du mal sowas von recht.
Alright. Machen wir Schluss, wa?
Wie wir immer magisch diese vier Stunden hinbekommen, wir wissen es selber nicht.
Aber so ist es nun mal. und insofern schön, dass ihr wieder uns zugehört habt.
Wir haben auch schon irgendwie einen nächsten Termin, der dann hoffentlich nicht so weit weg ist.
Der ist bei mir glaube ich schwierig, da müssen wir gleich nochmal gucken.
So ist das nämlich immer. Das ist das Problem. Na gut, wie auch immer.
Macht's gut. Tschüss bis bald.
Tschüss.